hello everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel today we will take you
through the top mongodb and react js
full course we will see the various
database operations and react components
that will increase your in hand
knowledge of mongodb and react.js
mongodb is a nosql document based
database management system
and react is a front-end javascript
library
it is an open source and a leading web
application framework of javascript
by the end of this full course i can
assure you that you will have a brief
knowledge of mongodb and react.js
but before we begin let me tell you that
we have regular updates on multiple tech
videos
so if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and press that bell icon to
never miss any update from simply learn
so without further delay let's get
started
let's go through the agenda for this
full course
first we'll see what is mongodb
after that we'll see how to install
mongodb on windows machine moving ahead
we'll see different curved operations
performed on mongodb
moving ahead we'll see how to connect
mongodb with python
then we'll start the react component
we'll see what is react.js after that
we'll see advantages and disadvantages
of react.js
we'll see features of react.js
components of react.js
react props and state
then we'll see how to connect react.js
with node.js and some projects of react
so let's begin
so what exactly is mongodb
it is a document oriented nosql database
it was initially released in august 27
2009
mongodb
replaces the concept of rows of
conventional relational data models with
something called as documents
it offers developers the flexibility to
work with evolving data models since
it's document based mongodb allows
embedded documents arrays and represents
complex hierarchical relationships using
a single record it is also schema free
which means that the keys defined in the
document are not fixed
as a result massive data migrations can
be ruled out
but you must be wondering when there's
something like sql why is nosql or
mongodb used
there are a few reasons why mongodb is
widely used
first up is flexibility
mongodb's notion of documents that can
contain sub-documents nested in complex
hierarchies is really expressive and
flexible
flexible query model a user can
selectively index some part of a
document or a query based on attribute
values regular expressions or ranges
next up is native aggregation
native aggregation allows its users to
extract and transform data from mongodb
and either load them in a new format or
export it from mongodb to other data
sources it makes it extremely compatible
lastly as mentioned earlier the schema
free model now applications get the
power and responsibility to interpret
different properties in different ways
now that you know what mongodb is and
why exactly it's used let's have a look
at the characteristics of mongodb
firstly it's a general purpose database
now mongodb can serve heterogeneous
loads and multiple purposes within an
application
again it has a flexible schema design
document oriented approaches with
non-defined attributes that can be
modified on the fly is a key contrast
between mongodb and any other relational
database
next up is scalability and load
balancing it's built to scale both
vertically but most importantly
horizontally using sharding and
architect can share load between
different instances and achieve both
read and write scalability
when it comes to load balancing this
happens automatically and transparently
to the user by the shard balancer
again we have aggregation framework now
mongodb offers an extract transform and
load framework that eliminates the need
for complex data pipelines
native replication now data will get
replicated
across a replica set without complicated
setup
security features both authentication
and authorization are taken into account
in mongodb
next up is json now json is widely used
across the web for front-end and api
communication and as such it's easier
when the database is also compatible
with the same protocol
lastly we have mapreduce now again
mapreduce is an excellent tool to build
data pipelines and mongodb uses
mapreduce readily now let's quickly have
a look at the working of mongodb
data is stored in documents with the
help of key value pairs now the data is
stored in the bson format
at the back end mongodb converts json
data into a binary format known as bson
mongodb also makes provision for nested
data
now all of these documents are stored in
a collection
these collections hold multiple
documents and since mongodb is
schema-less the documents in one
collection need not be similar now again
these collections are stored in the
entire mongodb database as mentioned
earlier mongodb makes provision for
nested data
this makes fetching of data extremely
efficient when compared to other
databases now you must be wondering
where exactly mongodb can be applied or
used so let me help you with that
several areas of technologies use
mongodb as their dbms currently some of
them are internet of things
mobile applications real-time analysis
personalization
catalog management and content
management
now all said and done let's look at some
of the companies that use mongodb
currently
companies like toyota sap astrazeneca
adobe verizon cisco
barclays and google among others readily
deploy mongodb as their database
management system in this video i'm
gonna help you install and set up
mongodb on your windows system
you will have to navigate to the
official mongodb website
and here
you can see
software
so go ahead and click on community
server under software
and you can see that the current version
is 4.4.4
and the platform is windows and make
sure that the package is msi all right
now go ahead and
press download
so this could take a while
all right so once it's downloaded
go ahead and install it
now since it's already installed on my
system uh the installation process will
be different but you just need to follow
the steps there and finally install it
so once you're done with the
installation you can go to your c drive
and here you can click on program files
and you can see that mongodb is
installed
and inside of it you have the server
folder and then you have the 4.4 folder
and then you have the bin folder right
so here you have the application that is
your [ __ ] and the mongod applications
both are executable files now the mongod
file or the application is the daemon
process
now this is the background process that
make sure you retrieve the data from the
database access the data so it does all
the background tasks so after the
installation now you need to create a
path to this file
by doing this you don't have to always
go to the bin folder and then execute
the file you can directly execute the
file on your command prompt right so for
that let's just
go to our environment
variables but before that let's just
copy this path
right
and here under the user variable section
click on path and say edit
and go ahead and just paste it right
i've already pasted mine so just go
ahead and paste it and click on ok
and
say okay
right so now you've created the path
successfully now let's head to our
command prompt and run the [ __ ] file so
here you can just directly type [ __ ]
since the path has already been created
so just go ahead and say [ __ ]
[Music]
and here you can see
that your
[ __ ] server has been generated
and with this you know that your in
mongodb has been successfully installed
and your server is up and running right
so just for confirmation let's see if
there are any databases and how much
space they've occupied so you can right
now just type
show
dbs
and when you click on it it says admin
config and localhost and all of it is
zero so with that you have successfully
installed mongodb on your system and
it's up and running
all right in this particular tutorial we
will be learning
what mongodb is all about and their
advantages and some practical
demonstrations so let's get started now
so here in mongodb we would like to
discuss about what is a mobile db so as
we know the mongodb is known to be
called a traditional
document based database
okay which stores the data in a document
okay no sql means
it doesn't says like no to sql
instead it says not only sql that means
it is not only sql but it is supporting
the other approaches too
okay so the document based when you talk
about it actually represents the typical
hierarchical relationship using the
single records
that means how the records are related
with each other so that's how exactly it
represents
and it is a pure schema free environment
so that you really do not need to have
a schema before you go and develop this
program so it is a pure schema-less
environment
due to that it is giving you far more
better flexibility when you talk about
completely unorganized involvement
so what is nosql so the here's the idea
about a nosql
so it is completely into the
non-relational database like
traditionally if you see
any non-relational database
uh you talk about
uh typical nosql
it's purely into the document base here
nosql does not use any tables like in
rows and columns a traditional idb base
approach if you see there they are using
a complete table structure like they
talk about columns they talk about rows
and are all about
so here
in nosql it stores the relationship data
in the documents
so the different type of nosql databases
are available like you talk about called
document based you talk about key value
base you talk about white column based
and graph based
different options are available for the
nosql but the one which we are using it
mongodb it is a purely document based
database
now here we would like to go ahead with
some demonstrations like talking about
like how mobo db installation works and
the other aspects
okay everyone so now we're gonna start
working on
the first option called mongodb
installation
[Music]
okay see mongodb installation is very
simple
if you open a website and go for
this website name called
mongodb
download
if you talk about mobile db download
you're gonna see
the official website called mongodb
community download is available
when you click here
so you can see it is taking the current
version to 4.4.6
mac os it by default detected my
platform however you can select depends
on which platform you have it and after
that you will be clicking on this
download okay so it will get ready for
if you are from windows
i would say in this windows
you can
select
appropriate option like two options are
available you can talk about msi or talk
about zip
my recommendation is you can stick to
the zip powered portion because it won't
start any mobile dv services behind the
scene
that is really helpful because you
really do not want the mobility to be
there running unnecessary even if it is
not required my suggestion is to stick
to the zip file so
here once the mongodb is there so you
will be seeing that two files available
inside the mongodb folder inside the bin
so once you download the zip you will
find two different type of files are
available let me mention those
so inside the bin folder
you will see
two files one is called mongodb
okay another file which is available
called mobo
mobo d is to basically start the mongod
server
and the [ __ ] t mobile is actually the
client which will connect with the
mongodb
clear so if you are in
windows environment
so once you are inside this bin folder
of your
zip file
you will get the mongod so you have to
double click on this it'll start a new
command prompt
so you do not need to do anything
further just minimize this command
prompt and go inside the bin folder
again and click on the
another binary file called mobile so it
will get start as a client
okay since i'm using the macbook here
the concept is little
different about how mongodb
can be used okay so this is just a basic
way of how the moon is being used into
your code
okay everyone so now
as we are in the
macbook so here to start mongodb we have
a very special way to start with so here
i'll start with my terminal
and here i would like to paste one very
simple command to start my mongodb
database
that is called mongod
and after that you could say hyphen
iphone db path it is the place where
your database will be starting and one
more important thing i forgot to mention
like
mongodb would not start automatically
inside your
windows machine unless
inside your c drive you have to create a
new folder name called data and under
this you have to create a new folder
name called db
because automatically when the mongod
starts it looks inside the c drive data
inside a db folder there your all
records will get stored so do not forget
whenever you're trying to use the
mongodb so you must make have you must
have this particular
folder structure in place in your local
machine otherwise this is not going to
start
every time you start your mongodb
without this
location it automatically terminates so
to avoid those make sure that you have
this data db folder ready with you
however you could also change the
location of this particular folder
structure for which we will discuss it
little later on but as of now
we can see i'm giving my
location that is called iphone 7 db pass
slash data db
i hit enter you can see now my mobile db
is starting now
and since it's stuck so i have to start
the new terminal now
so here i open the another tab
and type [ __ ]
and the moment i type mobile now you can
see it is now connected with my mongodb
and now it is ready
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay
now to check
which other databases are available to
you so you can just type show
dbs
so it will show you the number of
databases which are already there
inside your existing
newly installed mongodb
but you can go back and create
new database too here you can see some
databases are already present however
you go back and create the new databases
into your system
and to create this database
we have very simple option available
here
name call
use
simply db
if i say use simplydb it automatically
creates this database and take you
inside
let's see now you can see you say use
simplydb it automatically creates though
it is not there but automatically takes
you in while creating those
okay so that means your current database
name for simplydb
so if you're not sure which database you
are in so you can just type dbs
or db
and it will show you that your current
database is simply db
that's it so your database is set
and we are all good to go ahead with our
next level development
hello everybody and welcome back
in a previous videos you have seen like
how to create a database and
how to identify whether my database is
there or not so if you remember
previously we have created our database
using use keyword so if i just see my
databases which we have created is last
time so how we can check this out we can
say
show
space dbs
okay so you can see we have a got
database
list but we do not have any database
which we have created last time is
registered here that's quite surprising
because
when we have created our database it
should be listed here but it is not
let's do one more time i'm saying use
sn db
and
i'm saying switch to sldb
now when i say once again show dbs
so i still don't see my databases listed
here there is a reason
the reason is according to the mongodb
rule unless we have minimum one
record or collection stored inside my
mongodb it really can't show in the list
now i want to tell you about a few
important things
now
here when we talk about called mongodb
in this mongodb
compared to the relational database
here the table which is actually in rdb
message is called here it is called
collection
okay
db
is still called
db here
okay that means the database will be
still called database but
row
what you use this word in a traditional
rdbms here it is known as called
document
if you remember i told you
like it is a document based database so
here every single record what you try to
insert it is not
called a typical row it is instead
called a document so every table is
called collection and every single row
it is called
document
that's what exactly the difference is
okay
now here once it is ready we will go
ahead and talk about our next feature
now
well
we have to basically go and create a new
collection
okay so what you can say db dot
create
collection and here i can pass my
collection name i can say
demo
collection so once it is done
i can see it is collection is created
in typical language i can say the table
is created and now when i try to see
same show dbs
i can see my database is now listed
okay that's how exactly it works so the
very simplest way of how we use in my
code
well in our previous examples we have
seen like how we can create a collection
and we can give the name and i can see
the details are listed
when i say show dbs but there's a
another alternative option available
where you can just do that without even
saying db.createcollection
well
if i want to create a collection i
really don't need this particular
functionality called create collection i
can directly use this statement name
called
db
dot
db
dot sl
student
dot
insert
and here
we would like to add the property like a
name
and here we can say
admin
now what is that meaning is when you say
db.slstudent.insert
and i hit enter you can see the
uninserted one
and surprisingly when you try to say
press enter
you will see this sl student is not a
collection which we have created earlier
so what this line does this line
not only create the collection for you
but also add a record inside with this
property called name because that is a
mongodb and mongodb is always following
the json-based structure and due to that
it goes with the key in value appears
so db is a predefined keyword sn student
is a collection name insert is a command
through which you are trying to insert a
record
now to check how many collections are
there
okay so we have one
property called
show
show collections
when i say show collections i can list
down those number of
collections or else i can set tables in
a typical rdbms language which are there
added in my system
so essence student in which i can see
the record is inserted so if i want to
confirm i can simply say
db dot sl
student dot find find is a function
through which i can list out those
number of records which are added i say
fine and you can see that the records
are
received at the same time when i say
db
dot the name call demo collection
okay db.democollection.find
i'll find no record reason because this
collection was created but there was no
record which was inserted in
but you will see when i
write this command called sl student dot
insert it not only
create a new collection for me but also
insert the record into my
table also called a collection
that's where exactly
it is giving you the advantage when you
want the collections to be created along
with the data this is the way how you
can really do this
clear
but
whenever you talk about
dot create collection many people always
think about what is the significance of
having this db.create collection
look
db.createcollection is having its own
significance we never recommend this
technique
okay to create a collection because when
you create a collection you always
bring some restrictions
some terminology which missed out
whenever you talk about this line
so having this dot create collection you
can also offer some
additional capping which is not possible
when you use t bit or
collection input insert so you might be
thinking what those cappings you're
talking about let me try to brief you
when i say db
dot
create
collection and here we are providing the
first name called support student
okay when i say student
so after this student
additional parameters what we can pass
is this when i say
capped
colon
true
what are we saying cap colon true so you
are enabling the capping
after that the next parameter i'm going
to pass that is normal is called size
in this size we are providing the size
suppose i am saying
5 2
4 and also we are saying 2 double 8 0
that is the size of 5 mb and here we are
giving call max
colon
5
what exactly that meaning is see the
meaning is very simple whenever you try
to bring this create collection option
so capping true means you are enabling
the capping so what is that meaning is
it is trying to say
in this particular collection name
called student
maximum number of
documents
can be either 5
or less than 5.
clear and the collective size of
documents cannot be increased to more
than 5 mb that means you're trying to
say
either
by adding the total number of 5 records
the collective size of 5 document will
reach to 5 mb
okay or else the maximum number of five
documents can be
stored so whichever fills earlier you
may have a total number of four
documents which are pretty heavy and
they
reach to the size 5mb and beyond that
the next document won't be added or else
you can have the five documents which
has not yet even reached so any option
will help you to achieve this
so that's where exactly you can offer
the capping but this is only possible
when the user is trying to say db dot
create collection this option is not
possible when you're trying to use this
so that's the benefit of having this
db.create collection and this is what we
always recommend
well
now we would like to talk about our next
feature here
inside the same
mongodb so we now know how to create a
collection how to create a database and
how to switch from one database to
another database
now we will tell you like how to insert
a document so far we have already seen
how to insert a document inside the
mongodb now we would like to also show
you how we can insert the documents
using multiple techniques
so remember one thing
mogu tv comes with two different type of
documents
one is called
relational document and second is called
embedded document
mostly while working with mongodb we
always recommend you to use
embedded documents because that helps
you to scale up your application without
any hurdle
okay the embedded documents means what
that means the
i would say the parent record as well as
the child records both stores in the
same location
fine so
how exactly that is let's take a look
about this example
here we would like to insert some
records by saying db
dot
student i do not have a student
collection but i'm just telling you
db.student
dot
insert
here
we would like to add
some records what i'm trying to say the
registration number
registration number i'm just saying
one two three four
you can give anything
now the next one we will talk about
called name
this name we can say
student one
followed by
the next one i'm talking about which
course the student has registered so we
can say
course
inside this course we would like to say
the course name let's
say course name we are given the course
name called
mca
okay
followed by
another property called duration
okay i am giving this duration
is called
three
years
like that
after that
this curly braces is closing
that means
see
the idea is like you see the course is
an embedded document because from codes
you have got few more properties like in
course name and duration
i am closing this and starting the
another
property and that is called address
okay
sorry let me remove from here
and from address and address
we can say one more curly braces
and inside this address we can say city
giving the name called what
bangalore
another one we are using that is called
state
um
let me remove this state
colon
ka
okay and the third property we are using
that is known as call country
here is saying
ie that is called india
so it is closing here
okay and it is closing here so the inner
document and out document both are
closed
hit enter and now you can see the
records are inserted one thing you might
notice
the course
and the address these two are embedded
documents and they do not have
any
primary key of its own instead the
course and address both are directly
dependent on
the student object
or the student database so
i will say student have the registration
number
fine
and the primary key so the primary key
will be associated with the most outer
document and the inner documents are
directly
associated associated with them and now
when i try to say db
dot
student
dot find
you can see now the records are
fetched
i can understand many of you are
thinking every time
while adding the record we do not add
any object id
and here you might have observed and
there also you have option
then what exactly that id is now let me
brief you this id is nothing but a
unique primary key your mongodb has
offered you
that means mongodb says whichever data
you are inserting it
so by default with every single document
mobodb will associate this by default
property called underscore id which you
can't even ignore
however you can override
i haven't provided any
underscore id as a property because this
is a predefined property associated with
every single
mongodb document if you want to override
it you can override
from this value to any value because if
you do not pass any value
this value will be automatically
provided that is a typical hexadecimal
value
however if you want to override it you
can override the value of underscore id
but you can't change the key name
let's try
with some
another record
so same record if i try to add
let's go
i'm using call
student two
and here i'm saying one two three four
five here if i want to override it i can
just say underscore
id
colon now i can give the value call what
1 0 1
this you need to remember so i'm
overriding this value with 1 0 1
now adding it now the records are added
now let me call find now you see this
time the records when i fetched
so in this record
the first record contains a default
underscore id in a second record it is
the one which i have provided
and remember one thing in mongodb you
really can't offer any property other
than underscore id as a primary key
here there is no concept of having the
cons
like in composite key which you used to
do
in tradition
rdbms here you have only underscore id
and this is the only property which you
can override it else by default the new
value will be
given to you so this is the first way of
how the insert document has been done
will be telling you the another ways
where the other documents are also added
okay so
in the previous examples you have seen
like how we can add the records
but i also tell you there is another
alternative options are available if you
want to insert the records in a bulk
that option is also possible in [ __ ] tv
how we can do let's try to understand
here
here we would like to use one very
simple concept for var
my
emp equal to now starting with
a typical
object
like this and after that i mean
adding this
and within this i'm adding
the first property called emp
id
colon one
after this
okay now you can see it is not
understanding because that is a
challenge when we talk about call
uh
you know
the logical part
because you go with multiple lines it is
not supporting however you have to
follow the same lines now
amp id 1 and we just give the second
property called emp name
so
amp id
just
remove this i just say emp id and i say
amp
name
colon
admin
okay adding it here
so
first record here
again i'm adding another one that is
called
emp id
colon two
okay and now
colon
manager
okay again
colon three
and
colon
add
it okay and this curly braces is closing
after this
your square bracket is also closing
and once it is done you come down
and say db
dot
new amp
dot
insert
okay and here you pass the name
of the object called my
afb
and you can see now it is telling you n
inserted three that is known called bulk
insert when you're inserting multiple
records in a single shot
see how easy it is for you
okay
now you simply use
db
dot the collection name is what
your new erp
dot find
and you can see now all three records
are inserted with its default object id
okay so that
is a really nice idea to have
the id to be provided
okay remember this statement
so
you understood finally how we can
add the records in a bulk
going forward we will also talk about
which is related to your
update as well as delete in your
upcoming demos
okay but here that is the first thing
which you realize it how we can perform
those kind of operations in very very
simple and straightforward manner okay
everyone so now we have got three
records with us and in case if i'm
planning to perform update on any of my
records how will i do this now so we
have a predefined functions available
name called update function
let's see how this update function can
really work so we use this statement
name called db
dot
what is my collection name which is
known as call a new emp new emp
okay
dot
update okay
so
what i will do i will say db dot new emp
dot
update here
okay
now when we talk about call update we
ever
statement available
okay what is that that is called
emp id what we call emp name so we say
wherever the emp id is this i want to
change what the name how can i do this
now
very simple
to perform this what i would like to do
now
i want to basically add few more records
to give you some more better idea
you can see now here we have a call
admin
id name
so
i just do one thing
i just change the ids
one two three i just say four
i say five
this is six
okay
and i
call this
again the three records are inserted now
let me try to call find
now we have total number of
six records are available where
admin is repeated manager is repeated qa
is repeated
now let me try to update the record
okay now i want to say db
dot
new emp
dot
update
here
i would like to perform the property
like in what
[Music]
name
as an emp name
amp name
colon
i say admin
okay
so i just close that
and i use
another curly braces with dollar
set that means you want to set the new
value
here we are giving
emp name
okay what i want to do
i say wherever the name is admin change
to what
admin new
that name i want to change it
close this
closes
and run
now you can see it is saying n match to
one
and the record fields are updated like
this let me check
well here i will see
uh the value called admin new is updated
but i have one more admin call admin it
is not changed and that is something
which you need to notice
what you need to notice is notice is
like when you try to perform update so
what mobo dv does it starts from the top
find the first record
change the value or modify the value and
come out from the loop
it doesn't carry forward its search
process for the next level of results
and that is something which is
i really want to do that
so in case if you are planning to change
those values
multiple times so what you need to do
let's take a look here in the similar
example
here we have a column name admin second
property we will call manager let's try
to say
managers are repeated twice we just want
to change to
new underscore
manager and i want to update multiple
values so what i will do here
i will put
comma and say
multi
colon
shoot
okay saying multi-colon true that you
want to say hey i want to update
multiple
search or multiple repetitions hit enter
this time you can say it is saying
and match to and modify to that means
two records found and two records are
modified let's check
there we go we have got new manager is
updated in both the location
that's something which is really awesome
because this is how you try to perform
the multiple changes
well in our previous examples you see
like how we can perform the update part
but we have one more beautiful feature
available inside the mongodb and that is
called how exactly we can perform absurd
clear let's talk about absurd upside is
a combination of update and insert
let me try to show you one magic here
when we talk about call update part
you see now
here
we are trying to say
uh
this point
yeah you see what multi-tool we have
used
now here
this
multi true
is we're trying to update
but let's talk about something called
manager 2
enter now you can see it is saying no
records formed
clear now no records formed
but there's one concept available in
call absurd absurd means if i try to
perform upset it means if the records
are not available it will insert the
record
i want to show you one simple example
now here we are using multi-troop
okay
so
as i can see we're using something
called name
and we're performing this update part
so in this update part we're using this
dollar set new manager
so here rather than using multi true
we are saying
absolute true
when i say absurd rule so what happened
now
they say
n matched 0 and up inserted 2 and
modified with id this that means
when i try to call this find function
you will be seeing now we have a got
the another record has been added
are we clear now
as a new record
so absurd does what upset says like if
the records are found
i will update it if it is not i will
insert it
that means if i try to call the same
thing manager 2
fine it is added as a new manager now if
i just try to say
uh
not manager to i will call qa
qa and here we are saying emp equal to
new
underscore qa
and now you can see it is saying n
matched one and upsorted zero and
modified one so it is clearly telling
you like hey i did not find any
uh
inserted part but yes i matched one
record i found one record and the one
record is updated now
that is very very beneficial feature
when you really want to perform absurd
so that is the
advantage of upsell that is what's
called update plus insert
very
important feature that depends on the
requirement if you want to add you can
certainly add this so the way we have
tried to add this
up certain part we can also try to
perform the delete part also
okay so momodb
also helps you to perform the delete
part and how you'll be trying to add it
now let's try to understand here in my
code if i want to perform any delete
part i have this statement name called
db
dot
the option we are using it that is known
collection name emp
new emp sorry
dot we have option number remove
in this remove we would like to offer
the property
okay and what we're talking about now
here
let's try to add
the id here
or the name which you would like to
import so i want to say like
emp name admin new so we just say
p
name
okay
and then
name scoreboard
admin new
okay emp name admin new when i say
remove
you can see it is record removing the
first record
so you can see now the records are
removed
fine because there is only
one admin noise available
okay now in a similar way if i try to
remove
the property call
new underscore manager
new underscore
management hit enter now you can see the
three records are removed so it's not
like update which removes only one sorry
update only one record it can also
eliminate more than one records at the
same time
that's the benefit of remove so now you
can see we have already implemented some
records
as i seen earlier like we have
performed the delete part now
now when i try to say db
dot
new emp dot find
three records are available with me
three four and six
now
when it comes to c in third part we have
seen update part we have seen delete
part we have seen now it's time to
basically fetch the records
so find function we've already seen but
in find function we also have some
conditions so called queries so in case
if you want to limit the number of
records into your application you can
also do that
let's see db
dot
uh
new emp
dot
find
clear now so in fine you can also
pick up the specific records too
like when i'm saying dot find and here
we can just say
name
colon
admin
sorry
here to put curly braces
it says there is no record with a name
called admin
because it is a emp name not a name so
let me change back to
now you can see it finds
one record
so like that you can also apply a
condition
okay enter your code
now
in a similar line if you really don't
want to offer any condition
okay but you want to limit the number of
records to be
shown so you have this function
available name called
limit
to two means only two records now you
can see
though i have three records but it is
only showing me two records because i
have limit
those number of records into my code
also we can perform sorting in case if
you want to perform the sorting in
ascending and descending order that also
you can also do
so here rather than saying limit
we just put this option name called sort
and in this sort on which property you
want to sort it that out you can mention
so we can just say emp name
okay and using ascending order or
descending order so we can just say
minus one let's go descending order
okay
now you can see it is showing the
descending order now if i just say
minus one if you just say one
what is showing you in an ascending
order so you can pick up the specific
property we have on which
you can tell it should be either on
descending order or ascending order so
that option really works very fine
okay
so that's like how you can perform the
queries but remember one thing you can
also
search
the records based on the embedded
columns too because if you see in a
previous records we have
some records added
okay that is
let me try to say show
collections i will call
sl student
and student
okay
db dot
dot
find
okay
you can see we have records which are
embedded records
now if you want to search the records
based on their embedded properties like
i'm talking about address this is one
property name called city
fine so if you would like to pick up
those records these are also possible
so how you can do this
very simple so you say tb dot
student
dot find
okay so inside this file
you can provide the specific properties
like
my outermost property name is called
what address so we are using this option
called
address
dot
dot
city
so we say
city
are we clear colon
i'm giving the city name call what
bangalore
okay
let me close this
and that's it
okay
so we have to start passing
another curly braces here hit enter and
you can see now i find two records
because both the records belong to what
bangalore so i'm getting this
city bangalore with me
that's really awesome like you can also
pass the city accordingly
a part of that we also have
the other details also
okay in which
you can
have the conditions based on less than
greater than
or whatever values you would like to
make it
is available and
possible okay so that's how the
conditions are
satisfied
so suppose if you would like to pick the
users
i'll be clear
where the range which you would like to
consider so those are also possible like
you can see we have this property name
called what emp id 3 and 6.
i just want to pick up only those
records whose id is greater than
what 2. so what i can say
db
dot new
emp
okay
dot
find
and inside this file we can say
the property
okay so what's property we're using emp
id we're saying emp
id here
colon here we will be using
dollar
gt
gc stands for what greater than colon we
are giving the value call what one
fine
close this
run you can see you have received
three records three four and six
in case if i just look forward for
higher than five
you will see only one record so greater
than
that's called gt
okay
same option if i just say
lt
you can see we have found
two records so less than greater
than okay so that's how exactly you
offer it
okay and also you can provide
the condition so-called limit as i can
say find emp id the way we provide it
so here i will not use
less than
okay
instead i'll be providing another
property let me show you what
so here in emp id whatever we have taken
so let me try to take the property call
file and here we are providing emp
id
and then
and we're using other curly braces and
we're using dollar in
is very important property dollar in
colon here you provide the details
i'm saying
uh inside so the property is three four
six we are saying
three
comma
six
close this
and you can see we got two records
which matched with three and six that's
the benefit of having
this
okay everyone so in our previous example
we have already seen lot many activities
this time we are trying to offer you
something very interesting feature and
that is known as called working with
indexing see mongodb is one of the most
popular tool
and one of the reason why it is very
popular because it is having the
facility of having indexing now what
exactly the index does so friends main
job of having this index is to basically
give you the concept of like how
one particular
uh
document which is huge document
in case if you would like to perform any
sort of indexing inside this how you
will be applying this
so to apply indexing into my code
let's
try to understand why index is really
required
without indexing
and with indexing how will be making a
difference into the code
so to make it happen we would like to
insert some records
to confirm
okay
so what i will do is in step number one
previous records if i see i have got
four six three four one depends on
what early records we had it
so we had to call
new emp
so db dot new emp
dot
find
so we have total number of three records
are available so it's okay we can have
this three requires with me
now
let me try to apply indexing
without indexing if i want to find a
result what outcome i'm gonna receive so
to know about
how much time it gonna be taking if if i
have a got large number of records with
me i'll be using this statement name
called db
dot the name is called new emp
dot
explain
and here i will be using one predefined
functionality called
execution stats
execution starts
okay
now here after the execution starts
we'll be using dot
fine
we'll be using the first property here
okay
and
what user would like to find it that you
need to basically offer it so we are
giving the name called emp name
colon
giving the name call
qa
okay let's close
okay
now when i press hit enter execution
stats is a predefined
functionalities which will tell me
when the query was executed what exactly
the query plan was
hit enter and now you can see
a lot of details
are available with me
like you can see
pass query winning plan and everything
one thing you need to remember by
default
here when i try to run
it says end return one
advance one need time
total everything it is showing me
but one important thing which you will
see here
is
total number of documents is scanned
so it is telling me total number of
document examined is three
clear now and return one that means one
result is returned
and the total number of documents
examines three in order to find this
record
just imagine a use case here
when i say total number of documents
examine three in case if i ever got
millions of records with me
that means to search the record it will
examine all the millions number of
records to search the result which
certainly gonna be taking huge amount of
time
and that's where exactly when you try to
search the record
fine when you have no indexing is
available
okay so you need to understand one
important thing is
by default
index is applied
on your underscore id db
dot
new emp
um
yeah db dot num p dot
when i say db dot new emp dot get index
is a predefined function it tells me
like hey
by default index is applied or
underscore id
that's the
fact because by default
index is applied on underscore id not on
the other properties
so i need to identify
which are the properties are required to
be get indexes
mongodb advantages it is supporting
multi-column indexes
and that's what exactly we would like to
see so let's see in our next demo
now we will try to apply indexing on our
own property
okay so to apply the index what we need
to do we have to say db
dot
certainly we will be talking about
called collection name called
um
new emp
dot
create
index
here you have to pass two things number
one
on which property you would like to
apply
okay and it has to be ascending or
descending
so i am trying to apply on
emp
name
and i want the index to be applied on
ascending order
okay so here
colon one
hit enter you can see now
it is telling me
like uh
number of indexes before one and number
of indexes after two that means earlier
index was available only on one
particular property now it is apply on
two properties
if you want you can check
now you can see there's another
properties added called emp underscore
now if i try to execute a similar query
which i executed earlier
qa
now you'll be seeing there's a different
statistics all together
here if i see
in my code
see it will tell you total document
examined one
see now earlier the number of document
examined were three but since this index
is applied notice telling me the total
number of document examined is one so
performance is
certainly improved
so to search your document it won't be
searching the complete
collections okay rather it will search
what
only
that particular column in which it is
actually applied for
so that's the benefit in fact i would
say when you will be using these kind of
indexes into your code
okay
so hope we all are clear and understood
about this concept so let's go ahead and
get this implemented into our system
well this is the first way of how the
index can be applied so you can also
apply index on multiple properties
clear so that we will show you one by
one how it is
okay everybody so we have already seen
in our previous example how we have
applied
indexes in our existing mongodb
application
so
it is also a possibilities where we want
to also apply the index on other number
of properties too as you can see in our
existing database
okay an existing collection my
collection name is new emp which
contains
two different properties one is called
emp id and second called emp name just
now we have applied index on our emp
name but in case if i want to apply
index on emp id i will be using the same
technique okay let's try to apply index
on the same
so first of all get indexes i'm having
this index applied on two different
property
now we would like to say db
dot
create
index
and here in this db dot create index we
can just
i will say db dot collection name so our
collection name is called new emp new
amp
dot create index
first parameter is certainly the name
of which property we are applying so
here using emp id
and in this amp id we will just offer it
has to be ascending or descending let me
decide descending order so we are saying
-1
okay
now let's
press enter and check the status
okay now you can see earlier indexes
which we have created that was 2 and now
it turns to 3 so it is very clear that
index is improving now let's check this
out
db dot
new mp dot get indexes now we have a
total number of three indexes are
available
so you can apply index or
n number of columns if you want
okay at the same time
the way we have created the index in
case if i want to drop an index
so we can also drop so what we can do db
dot new emp
dot
drop index
drop
index
and in this drop index we have to
provide
which particular index we would like to
draw
remember this point in case if you're
planning to drop any sort of index so
you need to provide which
index so you should have that particular
index name
okay so here we are providing my index
name so it should not be uh i would say
the traditional name called emp id no it
has to be emp id
underscore minus one or
emp name underscore one so this should
be the name i'm saying emp
name in case if you try this
you see it is saying index not found
with the emp name because internally it
maintains with this name
let's try this out we say emp
name
underscore one let's try
and now you can see new index was
three okay one
okay
now you can see we have a call emp id
and underscore id
so now we have
only two indexes left
there's no emp name anymore this is how
exactly you can drop the indexes
so it is very simple and straightforward
way of how
in mongodb you can perform your
activities hello everybody and welcome
back
in a previous examples of mobodb you
might have considered
we have used lot many operations in our
last video we have seen
how to utilize uh indexing into our code
now in our next
journey of our mongodb we will see how
aggregation works see in mobodb
aggregation plays a vital role and
aggregation comes with so many handy
functions with mongodb which will help
you to perform
and to apply
some very simple code snippets into your
ongoing
i would say the requirement which can
make your query so much seamless now we
will see how this aggregation really
works and to work on an aggregation we
have taken some default database name
called aggregatedb and here we have a
call student as a by default collection
in which we have some set of records are
already added
now
if i just want to apply aggregation now
i would like to tell you about what
exactly the aggregation is
see ideally when you talk about call
aggregation
okay so aggregation is nothing but a
call aggregate like rdbms if you see
medical aggregation there so the unix
command like you talk about shell
pipeline means the possibility to
execute an operation on some input and
use that output as an input for the next
command
that means the output of one particular
execution becomes an input for others
so mongodb also supports same kind of
concept in aggregation framework there's
so many type of functionalities are
available which we will see one by one
into our next code
okay now here we want to confirm about a
few important things
now here let me try to bring some of the
important
well-known
i would say the functionalities of our
aggregation framework first we use the
term name called dollar project
the project is basically designed for
select
a specific
specific fields
dollar project is designed to select
what specific fields from a collection
we used to talk about call what
dollar match
the match is responsible
to filter out the operations
are we clear now it is designed to
filtering out the operations
you talk about dollar group
talk about dollar group so it does the
actual aggregation
fine we talk about call dollar
sort
okay it basically sort the document
okay like that there's so many
operations are available which we will
see one by one in our aggregation
behavior now my first example the one
which i want to execute i have a call
student record with me which contains a
student name
okay the section
and the marks and the subject on which
subject the person or the student is
appeared now here my first requirement
is we want to filter
data based on a section a because
students belong to the different
sections
as you can see now it is a they belong
to different section section a b c d
so i just want to
filter the data based on a section a
okay so for filter out i would like to
use dollar match
let's see how it works so i just would
like to filter out only those students
who belong to the section a
so how we would like to use it now i
will say
db
dot
student dot
aggregate and inside this we would like
to use this
square brackets and then curly braces
and then use
dollar
match
with this
i would like to use another curly braces
can i say
section
a
okay and i close this
close this
close the square bracket close this
okay so db dot student dot aggregate
aggregate should be always associate
match is known as aggregate
functionality section a hit enter and
you can see now it lists down all those
students who belong to the section a
okay very simple and straightforward
example
now we would like to use the second
example so we want to find out all the
records
where the section is a
and we are using and operator
marks is greater than 80 there are so
many students over different marks like
70 19 and whatever
so we want to use both the conditions
together so how are you going to be
using this now
remember
not only the section a
but also marks were greater than 80.
so similar thing we have a call match
okay after this match we're starting
this curly braces
okay
so
after this match we would like to bring
and
we say dollar
and
and again colon
again we are starting this square
bracket now
okay we talk about what
section a
number one
and after the first
curly braces we would like to use marks
we say
marks
colon and once again
they would like to start
curly braces and here we use
dollar
gt that is called what
a greater than
colon
80
okay
all are closed
so you see like here we ever got this
square bracket and non brackets
so
what else is left
so we recall 80 we are using another
curly braces needs to be closed here
and then
square bracket
okay and followed by again curly braces
again curly braces
again
square bracket okay round brackets
okay
let's see where it is gone wrong
so we're using this db dot student dot
aggregate we use this
yeah square bracket
then curly braces then we use
dollar match
okay after the dollar match
we are using another curly braces
and we will call and operator after this
and we have a call
this square bracket then curly braces
section a
after section is getting closed we are
using another curly braces marks
colon dollar gt
okay and we are using what
colon
80
after that we are closing this
and using two more curly buses square
bracket in this okay so this where
exactly you can utilize that so
db.student.aggregate and like this it
will be able to get it now okay so in a
previous example that was the only
missing point was after this
uh
this dollar match we didn't apply this
curly braces
that was only missing point which was
there and now we have applied another
code is giving me this outcome and i
have only one user who's scoring greater
than 80 well that was the first thing
which we have it now
along with this i would like to go ahead
and talk about few more things now i
just would like to bring selective
fields not all the fields like as you
can see we have a call student name
section marks everything i'm getting it
so i really don't want to bring all the
properties from this
document i would like to selectively
take specific property
so
let's talk about how we can use this so
we'll be using project you remember
about project is responsible to select
the specific record
so
i just use this statement name called db
dot
student
okay dot
aggregate we're using it now after that
now square bracket
and curly braces
now we are trying to say
dollar
project
what you would like to use dollar
project and colon we are trying to use
student name
okay column
okay remember one thing one means i want
those zero means i don't want so
whichever property will be enabling it
by giving the one as a digit that means
it is
it is expected to be displayed so i'm
saying one
comma i'm saying section
colon
one
okay and i'm also
looking forward for marks
colon one
that's it so now
you can see now i am once again picking
up only those
like student section and marks now if i
go back and
remove some properties like
i only want
student and section you can see i have
only student and sections
are used
here if i just use this statement name
call
underscore
id colon zero
now you can see only
the names
and sections are visible id is not
because i really don't want id by
default id is shown but if i says is 0
that means the id will not be visible
here so like that you can select
the columns or the properties
accordingly that was the one way another
thing i would like to use
what if you want to find out the student
name
section and marks from student once
again we want to find out the student
name
section and marks from the student
collection where the section is a
okay so here it will be the combinations
of match as well as the project
how we can use this let's take a look
towards my implementation
if you see the previous one what we have
used here
you remember about we have used this
statement
called aggregate match
okay so now we would like to go back and
utilize
after this dollar match
this is the curly braces i'm giving
section
colon
a
okay section colon a and after this i'll
close this
okay
and close this again
again i'm opening it up
by using this option called
project
dollar
project we are picking up the project
right now and here with this colon
symbol we can use again
and say
student name
student name
colon we're using one
comma
section colon one
and
one
marks colon one
and now
closing this
now you can see i got those
so the requirement was
we want to find out the student name
section and marks from
student collection where the section is
a
so you are not only using the match
okay but also using what the selective
details like this you can implement it
okay that's where exactly the projection
really works so projection
gives you lot many opportunities
which you can utilize it for your own
and also it comes with lot many
predefined functions like in some avgn
and all
so let's talk about those
functionalities too
so this is the first thing which we have
seen aggregations are taking place
now in case if you would like to perform
the group like if i want to find out the
total marks
group by
okay
section like each and every section i
would like to confirm the total marks
in every section then how do i basically
do that
so let's try to get this example also
so here
let me try to
go back
and we will not be using match here
because i would like to use the group
part
so
after this curly braces
we want to use
dollar
group
okay that is called group by in rdb is
how you use it
here we use this curly braces
again
here we are passing this underscore id
okay you have to provide underscore id
in a group because you cannot skip it
that part you need to be always remember
you really can't skip dollar id whenever
you're trying to talk about code group
this is a compulsory field you need to
have it
after that
i'm using this
section
in this section
we are saying dollar
section
because we would like to make it on a
section basis
after this closing
and here we are using what
total marks
colon
here curly braces
again
dollar
sum
okay colon on which we have i want to
use it mark so i can say dollar
marks
naming convention is very important
because it is a javascript so it is a
case sensitive
okay then
and you can see now
section wide i'm able to get all the
marks
isn't this an amazing that's where
exactly the aggregations are playing
very important role while retrieving
such kind of records
so hope you are clear about how we
utilize this together
so in a previous example we got it like
hope you are basically taking this
marks in my application
fine so
we are clear about how we are picking
that up but what in case if i would like
to take
marks for the specific section
so it is also possible so we'll be using
the same group but only thing is what
will be bringing the match between
because here we are trying to get
the all the section marks but if you
would like to bring it only for the
specific section we know it very well
what we need to do so here
before i talk about call dollar group we
can use one more curly braces here
okay so we can use this option called
dollar
match
okay and here we are using this
option called section a
sorry
here
in dollar match we are giving this call
section
colon
here we're giving a
so closing this
closing this
followed by
the other areas like in group which you
want to start now
so you can start with this curly braces
hit enter and you can see now only the
specific section you're able to receive
the records
and that's very simple now
okay
so
that's where exactly would like to
perform and there's another option like
in case if you would like to perform at
an average suppose if you want to
fetch the count of student in each
section and total marks
and average marks as well as so total
marks as well as the average marks we
want to get it so how are we able to
take it now
so it is very simple as you have seen
earlier also
into our code how we have taken call
group underscore id section talking
about section
total marks with this sum
we are also using this after that we can
also use the average
okay
so
this is we have taken
group underscore id sum
so here onwards we will start
so when we say sum marks
after that
we can just put curly braces
and we can just use
count
okay
and
after this
we'll be using this colon
curly braces and use
dollar
so
okay
colon
one
okay and after that i'll put
comma here
and we use
average
and inside this average i will use
in curly braces we can say
dollar
avg
okay
colon of what
dollar
marks
very simple so curly braces is closed
okay so total how many three curly
braces will be closed
one square bracket and round brackets
and now you can see you got the average
markings
in each and every section
so just imagine how easy it is for you
to deal with the aggregations so
aggregation seems to be very very simple
approach provided by mobo tv that really
create a difference of how
the
aggregation changes the way how you
react
okay everybody so after going through uh
the idea of like how we can utilize
the concept of
uh aggregation it's time to talk about
like how
when it works with mobo db mobile db is
properly known for
i will say
for replication that is called high
availability and that feature comes by
default with mongodb you really don't
need to install any software for this
because it is a building feature for the
mongodb
so when you download that it
comes along with this so no additional
uh configuration setup is really
required when it comes to the mongodb
part okay so let's get started and talk
about how mobodb
can offer the replication see the idea
behind the replication is what
the idea behind the replication is like
you are replicating it
okay
so when you talk about your replication
you are replicating your data to where
the multiple child so here in mobile db
we have one concept available
okay that is known as call master
okay
and
slaves
okay
master is one and there will be multiple
slaves okay so these slaves where your
records are actually stored and this is
a master which will be responsible to
replicate the data to all its childs
when the request comes due to that
in case of one particular node
fails so automatically the data will be
taken from the other nodes
that's the beauty of having this master
and not slave process so to make this
possible to be a very simple option
available
in mongodb we have one concept like
called mongodb atlas so there we can go
and get our cluster ready so here we
start with the concept name called [ __ ]
db atlas
let's search for mobile db atlas and
here i see mobile db atlas database as a
service see this is a free
tool it's a cloud environment where you
really don't need to install mobo db in
your local machine it is a cloud-based
mongodb support which is free to use
with a limited amount of space but yes
for the testing purpose it is the best
suitable
so i can start with the start free or
else i can say the login here
okay from there onwards i can go ahead
now it is getting ready
now this is the place from where you can
start working on your cluster
see as i've told you like initially when
you will be working on this
mongodb it will ask you
to create a cluster
initially
okay since i already have a cluster with
me
okay so
i really don't need to create it and as
a free
tier it will not
allow me to have more than one cluster
setup ready so if i say create a new
cluster
okay and i say
by default aws
okay and let me close on this
notification aws you can select any
other cloud provider
and uh
html cloud backup cluster name you can
see now it is taking me 0.54
per hour
reason being because i already have a
cluster with me hence more than one
cluster is not allowed in a free tier
cluster so i have to cancel this
but
you can go and create a cluster the way
it was offered there so if you want to
create you can just go ahead and do
nothing just select by default aws
select your location
okay give the name of the cluster you
want to give anything you can give it
here otherwise let it be the by default
name cluster and say create cluster it
will take a while minimum
two to three minutes depends on the
availability it creates a cluster for
you and your cluster once it is ready it
looks like that
okay so
here in this application
you have to go back and understand what
is there in a crystal when you click on
cluster 0
you can see now
here we have a got
three nodes available one is called
primary node which is called master as i
suggested earlier
and now we have a call slaves
automatically when the clusters are
created inside this mongodb by default
it will be three node cluster where the
one will be the primary and two will be
secondary
based on your package
whichever you have taken it you can
increase the number of nodes later on
but as a free i'm gonna get or i will be
receiving total number of three nodes
available here
so records whichever will be stored
it will get stored automatically in both
the nodes
secondary nodes and from the primary
i can insert the record and secondaries
i can read the records remember you
can't insert the records into the
secondary so you can only insert a
record only in your
primary record secondaries are not
allowed
to insert
so this is your replica set okay these
are the nodes which are available to you
so when you click on this primary here
you will see
it is telling you no whatever no data
available no data available
nothing is there because i haven't
stored any records as such
so i just go back to my cluster
so initially i would like to go back and
create few things now okay i would like
to go back and set up few initial things
at a time of creating the clusters
because when a cluster is created
clear now so in that point of time no
setting is configured you have to do few
settings now
first setting is you have to put it
remember the steps first step will be
your network access so in network access
you have to go
and you have to say add ip address
and in this ad ip address you have to
select this option
from which location you would like to
accept
only those ip addresses will be white
listed
otherwise what you can do you can see
here in my options i have given
0.0.0 that means all ip addresses are
acceptable
so all ip addresses are used
okay so this you have to enable it
otherwise you won't be able to get
this network access from any third-party
locations
next you will talk about call
database access which is required for
you to create a new user that already
some new users are created but it is
recommended that you to go and create a
new users here
okay so you can go back and add a new
user
so by default it is username and
password is given
so you can go back and create a new user
when i say add user
you can give the username as well as the
password
as per your own convenience so new user
i'm going to create it that is called
sl
okay
user
and here we're giving call
admin
123 so sl user admin 123
remember this will be the username and
password i'm saying add user
new user is automatically added as a
user and movement to three
so
once you have provided this network
access database access
next you have to create a new data
so what you need to do when you go back
to your
statement okay network access database
access it will ask you
like you want to create a new database
so i just go back to my project zero
will be on an option called collections
you have to go back and create a new
collection here
now it is
retrieving the list of databases
now you can see there are already some
collections are there mrdp is one of the
database which is there
demo db is there a lot many databases
are there so you can go back and create
some new database and connect through
so i just create database i already have
a simply learn db with me
user app
is already when collections are created
so creating a database in correction is
very easy if i give you the quick demo i
say create database
give the collection name called
sl demo
okay and give the username call
amp
slw employee like say create
now you can see sldm create it is there
with me
so there is no record right now
and uh once it is there ready so
remember slw
and employee i'll go back to my
code again project zero and from here i
can say connect
because i want to connect it so to
connect it from because your mongodb is
already there so you want to connect it
through so to connect it through here
very simple option available you can
just click on this connect option
multiple options are there through
mobile share connect your third party
application of the mongodb compass
so
since i already have a [ __ ] shell with
me
so mac os i have this mac os with me
so you can just use this line
okay so if you have a window you can
select your window since i have this mac
os
i'm selecting this line
but i need to replace with this
you can see this username
okay
and you have to give the username here
well i selected this i open my terminal
okay and this is i'm just closing this
i'm opening up
another terminal here
since i want to connect to the [ __ ]
shell now
so
what i need to do here in this
i'll just paste that
the command which i have it now
username is
you remember i told you
you call
some users which you have already
created
let's
check here
sl user
i say
sl user
i hit enter
it lasts me the password so i'm given
the password admin
and now you can see it is connecting
with me
to this particular
see
now see it is connecting me to this a
particular replica set you can see in a
logs it is telling you very clearly
okay saying that it is a username 4.2
and you can see it is correcting with
your shard cluster the cluster which is
created and this is where exactly i have
it with me
so i'm connecting with this environment
so primary is there if i just want to go
back and say
show
show collections
so i can go back and create a new
collection here
okay so
it's up to you now
by default collection which is their
employee so i can say tv
dot
employee dot
insert
and now here we can just add
name
okay
now you can see
some exception is raised
so
you understand
now you can see the records are added
into my primary cluster so if i just go
back and
go back to my project zero where we have
got
collections
here you will be getting
the
[Music]
sl demo
employee
loading the documents
so it takes time to get this but this is
where exactly
you see
the records will be stored
okay
so that's where exactly it works fine
for all of you
so we have this
record
okay so when i say
show collection so we have a call
employee and i say dv dot
employee dot
find
so i can see we have got new collection
name call
this is added right now okay so like
this you have got
the first connection established and the
records has been inserted in this
particular tutorial we will help you to
connect your mongodb
with the front end that is called python
as we know it very well about the
popularity of python in last recent
years it is growing like anything so we
thought why not to offer you
this connectivity where you can have
the mongodb
not in a local environment but in a
cloud environment so here we will tell
you how to create the mongodb complete
environment of cluster in your cloud
and we can have this connectivity with
our python which is running local to my
system so i show you what few important
things
one by one
so
why python mongodb
we understand mongodb is one of the most
important
database which is so called document
based database available in market and
it is fantastic phenomenal in terms of
speed and the reliability
it is purely called nosql database
okay and helps you to go schema less
now python is one of the most commonly
user-friendly programming language for
creating a complete web-based framework
so it offers you huge amount of
libraries with flexibility of connecting
wide variety of applications
so we would like to give you the idea of
like how python and mongodb works
together
okay
so you can
use both the
products together to develop
different varieties of
applications which can suits
to different type of ideas now here we
have one of the very very popular tool
available name called pi [ __ ]
so pi [ __ ] is actually the python
library which is the kind of driver
through which you will be able to
connect with your mongodb and perform
basic operations whichever you expect
okay so let's go ahead and start working
on those demos okay
so we will start with
creating a mongodb environment
with cluster in one of the very very
popular tool that is known as called
mongodb atlas so we'll be opening our
website
and go here and talk about call
[ __ ] db
atlas
i search for mongodb atlas that is
basically the mongodb
where i called database as a service
i'll be selecting the first option
go to the start free because it's going
to offer you by default some 500 db of
free space
i say sign up with google
going ahead and selecting this
okay i say accept
and say
submit
okay please starting up now
it will ask you about a few things
i would rather say to select skip
and continue
well it will ask you about which
environment you would like to take so i
like to take this shared cluster i say
create cluster
now here it will take a while to get
yourself ready for you can see it is
offering the sandbox of having five
kilometer free space
and this mongodb
no backup that is the by default cluster
name you can give the name of the
cluster if you want but let it be y d
for cluster zero i'm saying create
cluster
so my cluster is being ready so it will
take a while to get your cluster
set up
so just wait till the timer cluster is
getting ready so i tell you what this
cluster is gonna give you
by default two child and one parent so
called a one master and two
child nodes where your cluster will get
ready
so
you really don't need to set up any kind
of cluster in your local environment and
that is the best environment i would
suggest for
most of your development where your time
reduce
there will be no software requirement
because sometimes version 2 version
changes
and you can get all the benefits of
clusters
so we're just waiting till the time the
cluster is getting
ready so once the cluster is ready you
will be seeing some options
where
will help you to create the clusters in
your upcoming demos
friends your cluster is now ready
you can see now in this cluster you have
got this
environment so in this environment you
will see there are some options they
have given you one by one
build up your cluster create a first
database user
add an ip address multiple options
they're telling you know so how to set
up so the first build of the cluster
which we have anyways done next is
called create your first database user
so select this
it will highlight this area now i can
say like database access
and
i'm going to create a first new database
user and new database user
given that it is a name for admin
let's keep very simple username and
password admin
one two three so admin and win123
yeah same
and same add user
now you can see
the user is
created now let's go back to the next
option
it's telling me the network access now
go here
and say
sorry
now say add ip address
and
i'll say allow access from anywhere
so that i can take it from anywhere
i say confirm
now it is telling me about the progress
i select this
and tell me about which type of
collections you want
okay so i select this
and inside this i'll be selecting this
call collections
okay
and
it's getting
ready
so it is giving me some options
well two options that will give you load
sample data set add my own data i'll say
add my own data give the database name
sldemo give the collection name emp or
employee
remember
database name sl demo or i can better
give the name called srdb
sldp and employee i say create
that is getting ready
okay so my database and table is ready
that's it
so i think
we are all set
with this environment
okay
well once it is ready your collection is
also ready i'll go back and click on my
project zero
and here
yeah so once it is there then i'll be
clicking on this option called
connect
now it will give me the multiple options
how to connect
so it will say correct for the [ __ ]
shell or it will say connect with your
application correct using [ __ ] compass
i'll select
the python
python version
3.11 or later so certainly i'll be using
those version only
okay and
in this i'm having this
so i will be using this to connect with
my back end
so that's how exactly you have
the setup of mongodb cluster
everyone so we are all ready now with
our
setup
cluster we have already created earlier
you remember about we have taken python
3.11 or later
so here if i just go back and check
i have a god
3.8.5 which is python 3 version which is
available
so you can select based on
whichever we have it let's say three
point one one or later we can say three
point
six or later so there'll be no much
difference if i just see
even if i just talk about three point
four there's some change but here's 3.6
or later
it is same so i have a 3.8.5
okay so
i can use the same option
so here in my
vs core editor i am using for my
development so here is a simple demo dot
pi i have used welcome to check if it is
working fine so yes it is working fine
i'll start working with my first program
with mongodb so i just go back and say
demo
py or i can say
[Music]
py
demo
dot py
okay
and here if i want to go back and start
working on the development remember one
thing we need
first dependency called pi [ __ ]
okay what i need pi
[ __ ] and for this we have already
installed this dependency here
some time back this is how you need to
install
okay so we have this statement name
called what pip installed by
that's the first dependency which you
need to download in order to work with
this
okay
so
that's what we have taken this is
installed by [ __ ] so if you just see
you can go back and start developing
this statement
okay so let's go back and start working
on this
step number one you need to always say
import
number one the one dependence which
you've installed is called buy [ __ ]
so
you can just say p by m o n g o
that is the dependency we have recently
imported
from
okay let me go back and search from next
point so import pi [ __ ]
from
here we are saying pi [ __ ]
okay pi [ __ ] and we're also saying
import
[ __ ] client
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay after that we would like to go back
and use the cluster
so we say cluster
equal to
[ __ ] client and here i'll be passing
the complete values the one which we
have taken
so this complete line
i just take it
go back
and here
and pasting it
now here
i have to basically replace this
password with admin 123
okay and we are all
set okay
now
once it is ready
we can go ahead and define db
equal to
cluster
and provide which database you are
talking about
okay so you remember about we had a
database which was available to us that
is known as call
sltb so i can just use the same sltp
there
and accordingly i can use
which collection i'm connecting it to so
accordingly i can go back and insert a
record okay everybody so i can see i
have got this
file with me going forward i have to
tell so this is what exactly the
connection url you have received now you
could define which database you're
working on
let me say tp equal to
cluster and we have to provide in
double quotes the database name called
sltp if you remember we have used this
after that we have to mention which
collection it was so
collection
equal to
db and here we just give the name call
employee
that was our collection name
so once it is ready then i have to
basically perform some insert operation
so i just say post
okay it's just a name equal to
and here
we just provide the properties
like i would say name
so
you know to the json-based database so i
can just use the name
i say
armor
and once again you can just say
email
and uh
say
commentary email.com
that's it so this is just the data which
i have now i want to insert so i can
certainly say
collection dot because i want to insert
only one record you can see i have open
functions coming up collections dot
insert one and plus
post
isn't parameter now we are all done
let's try to run this
so i'll be running this with python 3
p mobile.py
hit enter
now it's done let's confirm
here into my code i will just go back
and check
here inside my
applications i can just go back to my
collections
and in employee
yeah there we go we have got some
records coming up here
okay so these records are nothing
but the one which we have recently
inserted in our application
okay
so fantastic so first example is working
perfectly fine how we can have the
records coming from the python and
insert it there like that i can have as
many number of records i can add it
so how we can basically add if i want to
add more than one records
let's see this now here in case if i
want to add more than one records so i
can just use call post one
i copy this url
and paste it below
and i say pause to
i say
i'm saying
email
um one two at the rightmail.com and
rather than saying insert one
i can use
insert many and inside this i'll be
using this
square brackets
and pass
post
post one corner
post two
that's it
okay so let's change the little name
because it's already there
let's insert
yeah records are inserted let me verify
once again
by refreshing it
well now we have a total number of three
records are available
yeah there we go so records are added
perfect so like this you can have
as my number of records you can
basically add it in a similar one the
way we have basically used this i can
also perform
the search part too
okay so in case if you want to perform
the search part we have a very simple
statement available with us what
i'll go here
the way we have added this so
in this i'll just
these records which are added inside my
application i would not execute this
rather
i would like to go back and say
no they are basically commenting now
and
in fact i would like to use this also
okay i will go here
and
find results
results equal to
same collection
dot
find if i want to find a name we can
just use
curly braces
name
colon
[Music]
okay
so let me say print
and trans
results
okay let's run this
okay so it'll print what
the results for me
okay
so
it is just printing what the cursor
object for me saying hey this is what a
record is available to me we can also
change in case if we do not think the
correct result is coming up we can also
go back
and uh
we can use some alternative option that
is called
okay so what we can do let's take a look
here
we can use for
with this for i can say result
okay in
results and
print this result
that could be one option through which
you can get the details with you
okay so what you can do you can run this
code again
oh i forgot to put this
semicolon here
or
we need to check
well that was my
requirement was so i'm having this
let's try to run this
well i got my result and this is what
the detail which i have available to me
so
very simple how you can basically find a
record and how you can basically
retrieve the records at the same time if
you want to have the specific field
rather than all the fields so here in my
code in this result
okay you can just put the square bracket
and tell which field you really want it
now suppose if you just want id or else
if you want name
you can basically pick that up okay so
if i just want that
id
the only id is printed that's it
okay everyone so you have seen like in
my previous code how we were basically
trying to fetch all the records we were
using this fine
now in a similar line you can also have
the option available because see when we
used to talk about confine it gets me a
lot many records
fine and because of that we were using
this loop but in case if you want to
fetch the individual records
i'll be clear so in such cases you
really do not want to use fine
you can just
use find one
so what we can do is rather than using
find
i can also use one more option called
find one and for which
i can come back
just remove this all
yeah so here in this case rather than
using this file i can use find
underscore you can see this option
called find one
here we talk about
which are the properties you want to
skip and which of the properties you
want
so i can just use this option called
underscore
idle
okay colon
zero okay i just remove this
undersquared zero and here
just print what
results
that's it let's run
so that will try to fetch some of the
records for you because if you do not
have that id which you overwritten it
will certainly not found it depends on
what you would like to take
so if i just say
is having some issues but no problem but
you know it very well how it basically
takes
now in a similar line we would like to
also perform one more activity
to talk about delete
so for which what i will do is this i
just want to uncomment it
okay and i would like to insert some
records here
so here i want to add the id by my own
with name
so we already have this name
email
i have it i would like to use underscore
id
okay
so
let me have this property underscore id
colon
101
okay
comma like this
copy the same
using it here
and this time
i'm using
one zero two
name and everything
it'll be taken let me say
user1
here we try to say
user
2
okay so
dot collections.many result five one i'm
just deleting it all
and uh let's try to
execute it first
okay so it's executed going back
okay so i have some records with ide one
zero one and one zero two
now here
i just delete this
and perform some actions here
here we say
results
equal to
collection
dot
delete
see the options are available delete one
and delete money it totally depends on
what you really want
okay so if i just talk about call delete
one it will be only deleting one record
delete money means where are the
matching records are available to delete
it fine so i'm just using this option
called delete many
okay wherever the property names are
matched cos quite possible name
sometimes match or whatever it is just
delete many so the option is up to you
now for you want so the selector name
you have to offer it
whether you want to match it with the
name or whether you want to match it
with the email or whatever it is
so that will be offering it but there's
also one option available where you
would like to delete everything
are we clear so if you're applying to
delete everything what you can do you
can just leave it as a blank and try to
run this
so collection
dot delete
underscore menu
let's check
great all records are deleted
so as i told you earlier also so delete
many means what it will delete all the
records whichever are present in your
code now
clear in a similar one if i want to
perform insert
so you remember about we have an option
called what
insert menu
and here
we would like to pass
post one
post to let's execute
so it'll add
the records inside this
okay
and next time what i want to perform
after adding this record i would like to
perform
the update part
okay so
what i really wanted my update let's
take a look update means certain
properties i'm looking forward to be get
updated
okay
so
in case if i want to check the record
has to be updated i would first go and
check
whether the record does exist or not
yeah we have two names user one and user
two let's go back and update part
here
i just
save collections
okay dot
update one
update you can see
update one here very simple
functionality
here you will go
and tell which id you would like to
perform an update
by saying underscore
id
colon
which i do want to consider i'm saying
101
okay
and what else
so i just use another curly braces and i
say
sorry
dollar
set
and after this
i use this colon
use the curly braces
name
okay and
use whatever you want to use it so
suppose there is a user one i'm saying
user
one two three
okay
let's see
it is loading and you can see the record
user 1v3 is updated
perfect
so
your code is absolutely working fine so
you talk about either insert you talk
about what
update you talk about anything it works
so insert update one
delete one
insert one as the name suggest they'd be
taking care about inserting updating and
deleting one one records but the moment
you use many they'll be performing
multiple records so this is a very
simple way like how the python will
connect with your mongodb in this video
we're going to learn about the
differences between mysql and mongodb
now i'm sure you must have heard about
these database management systems
but do you exactly know what set them
apart
don't worry i'll help you in this video
first let's look at what exactly is
mongodb
now as you all know mongodb is an open
source document oriented nosql database
it is document based which means that
the data stored is represented in a
hierarchical relationship using a single
record
and also mongodb is schema free which
means there is no set schema to define
how the data is being stored in the
database
this causes lesser data migrations
but what exactly is mysql then
now mysql is an open source relational
database management system unlike
mongodb which is document oriented
mysql is a relational database system
now this uses something called as a
structured query language and this is
used to access data which is stored in
the form of rows and columns
now as mentioned earlier data here is
stored in the form of tables with rows
and columns and each data field comes
with an index representing the data in
the table
and sql is developed and maintained by
oracle
so then what exactly sets them apart so
in the coming section we look at some of
the differences between mysql and
mongodb depending on certain features
first up is the data structure
now mysql requires you to define your
tables and columns before you can store
anything and every row in a table must
have the same columns
in mongodb you just drop the data in
these documents
also the data in the mongodb database is
stored in a binary format called as bson
next up we have schema now as discussed
earlier mysql requires a set schema to
define the tables in the database now
the database administrator is requested
to define a schema which defines how the
different tables are being stored in the
database
now this schema is crucial in case of
mysql
on the other hand mongodb doesn't
require a prior definition of a schema
next up is languages
mysql uses the structured query language
to perform actions on the database it is
used to retrieve data add data update
create a new data set etc in case of
mongodb it supports a json query
language to work with data
next up is foreign keys
now mysql supports the usage of foreign
keys now if you don't know what exactly
a foreign key is then sql uses foreign
keys to link one table to another now
these foreign keys make data retrieval
easy especially when there are multiple
tables interlinked with one another in
case of mongodb there's no support for
foreign keys
next up is replication
now mysql supports the master slave and
the master master replication in this
setup data set from one master database
server can be copied to other servers
in case of mongodb
it uses something called as sharding now
sharding allows partitioning of data
across multiple servers using a shard
key
don't worry if you're not able to
understand these concepts well in the
coming videos we'll explain these
concepts in detail
next up is scalability now sql database
can be scaled vertically while mongodb
can be scaled both vertically and
horizontally now horizontal scaling
means scaling by adding more machines to
your pool of resources
while vertical scaling refers to scaling
by adding more power like for example
cpu or ram
moving ahead let's look at performance
now mysql is optimized for high
performance joins across multiple tables
while mongodb is optimized for write
performance
talking about community support some of
the popular github repositories on mysql
currently are mysql js mysql and then
there's mysql server and at the time of
writing there were about 222 000
repositories on github with 7 million
comments for mysql in case of mongodb
few popular github repositories are
mongodb slash [ __ ] and doctrine mongodb
and at the time of writing there were
about 177 000 repositories with about
923 000 comments according to google
trends mysql is largely used compared to
mongodb
so now the question arises which one
should you choose
well
if your application requires multi-row
transactions
like for example an accounting system
then a relational database would be more
ideal but if you're using mongodb then
it is more suitable for
real-time analytics content management
internet of things mobile applications
and so on
also mysql is a great choice if you have
structured data and need a traditional
relational database
in case of mongodb
it is an ideal choice if you have an
unstructured set of data so you could
pick your choice and if you're partial
towards one dbms let us know in the
comment section below as to why you like
that particular dbms let's go ahead and
begin with what is react react is a
javascript library used to build fast
and interactive user interfaces for both
web and mobile applications now one
thing that makes react extremely
powerful is the fact that it's open
source any user can access its source
code modify it and enhance it in a
typical model view controller
architecture react defines the view part
of the application it is also
responsible for how the app looks and
feels fun fact react was built by jordan
walkey an engineer at facebook now let's
go ahead and see how react works in real
time consider a typical web application
say instagram the entire ui of the
webpage is divided into several
components we have the search component
a profile description component stories
component and a post list component
these components make the code easier to
debug and always remain discrete
components also make development and
maintenance of web applications faster
as multiple developers can work
simultaneously on different components
of the same web application now let's
see why react is so popular these days
the act helps in creation of dynamic web
applications it also provides
performance enhancements now there are
several performance enhancements like
virtual dom and one-way data binding
we'll learn about these topics a little
later in the video react uses reusable
components now this helps decrease the
development time react involves
unidirectional flow of data react also
has a small learning curve compared to
other frameworks like angular react is
much easier to learn react can also be
used for mobile applications react
recently released an extension called
react native that is used for developing
mobile applications that are
cross-compatible it also has dedicated
tools for easy debugging now let's dive
in to the features of react first let's
understand jsx
is a syntax extension to javascript
using jsx we can add html to the
javascript file all coding in react is
done using jsx it also helps in making
the code easier to understand and debug
ultimately jsx is a combination of
javascript and html now let's consider a
small example cons simple here is a
javascript notation h1 tags indicate
html again the semicolon indicates
javascript note that the semicolon is
not mandatory however it's a good
practice to include it moving on the
next feature is virtual dom dom which is
an acronym for data object model
actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual dom that is the
exact copy of the real dom traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real dom
are updated this makes it extremely slow
let's see how react counters this now
consider two objects whose states have
been changed react now compares the
virtual dom with the virtual dom
snapshot that was taken right before the
update by comparing the new virtual dom
with the pre-update version react
figures out exactly which virtual dom
objects have changed now react only
updates those objects on the virtual dom
this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed coming to the next
feature performance react uses virtual
dom as discussed earlier virtual dog
impacts the speed of the web
applications we also took an example of
instagram and learned how multiple
components can affect the development
time they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one way
data binding this means information
flows in only one direction one way data
binding is specifically used when
information is displayed and not updated
remember that the components of react
are functional in nature that is they
receive information through arguments
and pass information via their return
values the next important feature is
extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications it provides
server-side rendering which means that
the application is rendered on the
server rather than in the browser react
native which is a react extension is
used for developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them react native lets you build mobile
applications using only javascript a
react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices thousands of applications like
facebook instagram pinterest skype use
react native the next popular react
extension is flux flux is the
application architecture that facebook
uses flux implements unidirectional flow
which makes it easier to understand what
actually is going on now let's see how
it works when we trigger an action the
dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them to the stores a store is
what holds the data of an application
stores will register with the
application's dispatcher so that they
can receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views actions define the
internal api of your application they
capture how anything might interact with
your application the last feature of
react is debugging react applications
are easy to debug thanks to the large
and active developer community you can
practically debug react codes within
your browser now notice the small react
extension icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it moving on let's learn about the
building blocks of react components
state and props are the essential
concepts that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built now
what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application react divides the
user interface into multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element is viewed in the
application react components remain
discrete and are processed independently
another feature is reusability
components can be reused multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time consider the following
code snippet a component is implemented
as a javascript class having some state
and a render method state is the data
which we want the component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the ui looks and feels to the user
the next concept is state state of a
component is an object that holds some
data this data influences the output of
a component every time the state of an
object changes the component is
re-rendered onto the screen now let's
see what props are props or short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components properties help make
components more dynamic it is important
to define all the properties their types
and their default value props are passed
to components in a way similar to that
of html tag attributes now consider the
following code snippets this shows
exactly how properties are passed to
components also detailed illustrations
on components props and state will be
shown in the upcoming videos so stay
tuned for that moving on let's go
through some of the things that you
should know before you can actually
start working on react you should be
familiar with programming concepts like
functions objects arrays and classes one
should also have a basic knowledge of
javascript and a familiarity with html
don't worry if you feel like you're not
good at them once you start working on
them you'll get a good hang of it
finally let's go through the impact of
react on the it industry and get
insights into the salaries of react
developers statistics show that react
developers earn way more than other web
developers according to pay scale the
average salary for a react developer in
the united states is a whopping 91 000
us dollars the average salary for a
react developer in india is 7.25 lakhs
per annum over the recent years react
has gained immense popularity and is
being adopted by many companies
according to the data by google trends
react has had a better growth scale
compared to other frameworks like
angular and vue statistics show that
front-end developers have wholeheartedly
adopted this lightweight framework
foregoing other available options if you
are skilled and have a knack for
front-end development react can help you
gain fantastic career opportunities
lastly talking about a few companies
that use react devotionally we have
facebook instagram netflix dropbox
whatsapp among others in today's video
we'll be learning all about react
installation on windows so without
further ado let's get started to set up
the react development environment we
need two things installed node and the
text editor of your choice so let's
begin by installing nodejs we can head
to the official node.js website save
download
node.js so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version so i'm going to go
ahead and click on the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system i'm not again installing node you
can follow the installation guidelines
and download it once you're done with
node installation you can go ahead and
download a text editor of your choice so
i'd suggest vs code so let's head to the
vs code page say download vs code click
on the first link and download the
64-bit version for windows once you're
done with the installation of both node
and your text editor you can start
creating your first react application so
for that let's create a folder
i'm creating it on my desktop while you
can create it in any of your drives
let's call it
first
react now open your command prompt now
you can type in the path for the folder
that you just created so say
cd
users
first react now go ahead and type in the
command npm
install
hyphen g create
react
app okay so this command installs all
the necessary react.js modules now to
check if the version is correctly
installed you can type in create
react app version so you can see the
version here now let's continue and
develop your react application type in
the command create
react app
and you can give a name to your
application so i say my app
now this should take a couple of minutes
okay once you've successfully created
your application
they say to begin by typing the
following commands so let's do that save
cd my app and npm start this should
typically start your application and
here we go
all right you can also open your
application in the text editor that
you've downloaded so let's go ahead and
open vs code vs code file
open folder go to your desktop or the
drive that you've saved your folder in
first react
my app and i say select folder so as you
can see all your modules have been
imported you can click on app.js and
start editing in today's video we'll be
learning all about the most basic
infrastructure of react.js called
components without delay let's begin and
look at what's in store for us so we'll
be touching on topics like what are
components types of components nesting
components higher order in pure
components and a brief description about
component life cycle all right to begin
with what exactly are components
components are the building blocks of a
react application wherein each component
represents a part of the user interface
now to make it more understandable
consider the facebook home page the
entire ui can be broken down into
several elements say we have the
credentials component the signup
component the image component and the
logo component notice that each
component adds something to how the home
page looks all right reusability is one
of the salient features of react
components one component can be reused
several times across the application and
this improves the development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components in its minimal
form a component must define a render
method that specifies how exactly the
application looks and feels a component
can also receive properties from its
parent components also you'll get a
better understanding of all of these
when we start working hands-on so don't
worry so moving on let's look at the
different types of components first we
have the stateless functional components
and then we have the stateful class
components now functional components are
typical javascript functions that return
html now they can be contained in a dot
js or a dot jsx file coming to class
components these are regular esx classes
however it's mandatory that they contain
a render method that in turn returns
html they can also be contained in dot
jx or a dot jsx file okay then let's go
ahead and build our first react
application using components all right
so i've opened my text editor that is vs
code to build my application also i
suggest you watch the react installation
on windows video to help you get started
the video briefly explains how to
install node and how to start building
your first react application in my case
i've opened a folder called react
component tutorial and here in my source
folder i have app.js now app.js is the
main component that gets rendered to the
dom let me show you that here in
index.js you pass app.js which is a
component that gets rendered to the
react dom so app.js consists of several
other components that can be nested so
as you can see app.js is a functional
component and before moving on let me
get rid of all the unnecessary code so
let me delete all of this
and return
an h1 tag that says hello welcome to
sibling let me save it and if you look
at the browser you'll have hello welcome
to simply learn now let's go ahead and
display another message say h1
this
video is about
components let me save it and let me
check the browser it gives you an error
so jsx uses a conventional rule which
states that all html tags have to be
enclosed within a div tag so for example
i say div and i enclose it so let me
save and check my browser again here you
go so multiple html tags have to be
enclosed within the div tag moving on
let's create a first functional
component to do that i'll first create a
folder in my source folder say
components within that i'll create a
file say functional
component dot js all right so the first
thing we have to do is import react so i
say import react from
yeah the general syntax for a functional
component involves the keyword function
and say
functional
component
now you say return an h1 tag or i've
already used h1 tags so i'll say
paragraph and i say
this is
a functional component all right before
explaining to you how these components
are exported and imported let me show
you the general syntax for a class
component so i create another file say
class component dot js i again import
react from react the general notation is
using the class keyword followed by the
name of the class extending from the
base class the act.component so going
ahead i say class class component
extends react dot component now the key
feature of a class component is the
usage of a render method so i say render
within braces i say return a paragraph
tag saying this is
the class component all right so moving
on let's see how these components can be
nested into the main component that is
app.js components can be nested into the
main component using import and export
keywords so as the name suggests export
features used to export a particular
file or a module and import is used to
import a particular file or module into
the current existing module so we have
two different types of exports you have
default export and just export or named
export so a default export is used to
export just one object be it a function
a class a variable from the file and
there can only be one default export
profile and when you're importing it you
can specify the address and use the word
import before it so let me show you how
it works let's go back to our editor and
then functional component and here i say
export default and the name of the
functional component that is
functional com so let me save this and
going back to my app.js i say import
name of the functional component that is
functional com from and i pass the path
this components slash functional
component also let me get rid of these
unnecessary
files here now let's define functional
component in our app.js component so
here i say functional com let's compile
it and check our browser here it says
this is a functional component moving on
to my class component it's the same
syntax here as well i say export default
name of my component and in my app.js i
import it
import class comp from
the path and again i'll have to define
it in my return method i save so let me
compile it and check my browser it says
this is the class component one unique
feature of default export is that i can
rename the file while i'm importing it
so for example i can rename it as say
fc and while i'm defining it i'll have
to make sure i use the same naming
conventions so i say fc again and when i
check it it says this is the functional
component there's literally no
difference the next type of export is
the named export or just export so a
named export can be used to export
multiple objects be it functions class
etc from a file now there can be several
named exports from a single file one
hack is that while you're importing it
cannot be renamed so let me show you how
this works okay so let's create another
class in our class component so i'll
just copy paste this
let me give it another name say class
comp one and the message that i want to
display is hey i'm another class all
right so when i'm exporting it i don't
want default so let me take it off and
say export here all right in my app.js
while importing it i want to import both
the classes so i'll include them within
curly braces here i say class com comma
class comp one and then again i define
it here class comp one let's compile it
and run it and here we go here you can
see hey i'm another class so we've
successfully exported both the classes
from the class component and imported it
back in our app.js component one
advantage of using named export is the
fact that i can choose to import the
classes that i want to now say for
example i do not want to import class
component here so let me take it off and
here let me
comment this now let's compile and see
here another class the second class got
imported while the first class that was
defined earlier is not imported here all
right so next up we have higher order
and pure competence now i won't get into
the nativities of it because they're
advanced topics but to give you a brief
insight higher order components are
basically functions that take in a
component and return a new component the
whole ideology behind higher order
components is to facilitate the
reusability of component logic okay so
let's see how this works let's go back
to our code editor let's create a
component in our components folder let's
call the component
click
dot js all right so here we define a
class i use this snippet rce here we go
we get the entire format using the small
snippet rce and here i'm going to make
use of a button now see i use the tag
button and i'll say
clicked
one time every time the user clicks on
the button the value gets incremented so
for this i'm going to use a variable say
count and i'm going to use the concept
of states so let's go ahead and define
our variable count and initialize it to
zero so for that i'm going to use
another snippet called r const and here
this dot state equals my variable count
initializing it to zero so let's define
the count variable in a render method so
i say const count equals this dot state
so every time we click on the button the
count value has to get incremented right
so we make use of an event called on
click equals this
dot
update click
now update click is going to be another
method that we have to define now so
every time the button gets clicked this
method is called so let's go ahead and
define the function so it is update
click equals it's going to be an arrow
function and i say
this dot set state is nothing but count
this dot
state dot count plus one okay and here
we say
count times all right so once this is
done let's import our component in
app.js so here again
i say import click from
components click and let's define it
here so let's check our browser every
time we click on the button the value
gets incremented all right so let's go
ahead and create another component say
counter.js wherein every time the user
hovers the mouse on the button the count
value increases so let's go ahead and do
that i say
counter dot js i'm again going to use
the snippet rce to create a class
component and here in my div tag i
define a button and say incremented
to for now i say x so now let's go ahead
and add the event say button on
mouse
enter
i'm going to call the method this dot
increment count okay so once you're done
with that let's go ahead and define the
increment count method i'm going to copy
the same code that i've mentioned in my
click.js so i say copy this all right so
one change is that i change the name of
the method and
call it increment count again let's
define the count in our render method so
i say const count equals
this dot
state and here i change x to
now let's go ahead and import it in our
app.js so i say import counter
from
components and counter and let's define
it here all right let's save it and
let's run the code okay so as you can
see you see another button here
incremented to zero and every time i
move my cursor on the button it
increments mind you i'm not clicking i'm
just hovering my mouse okay to learn how
higher order components work we'll have
to pass counter.js and click.js as
parameters to give birth to an entire
new component so for that let's go ahead
and create another component for our hoc
let's call it
higher order dot js okay so i say import
react from react after that i say const
updated component equals
original component that's going to be an
arrow function again and within curly
braces i define my class that is class
say new component extends
react
dot component inside let's define a
render method
that returns the original component with
a modification that is i want to type
the user i want to append the user
before the actual message is displayed
all right so let's go ahead and close
the tag and return new component and
let's export this say export
default updated component
now we import higherorder.js in our
counter.js and click.js and pass these
components as parameters so let's do
that let's go to our counter.js and here
i say import
updated component
from
dot slash higher order component and
here while exporting i say updated comp
and pass this as my parameter let's do
the same to click.js here i import
data.com from higher order component and
here i pass this as a parameter now here
in a higher order component we've
defined a property name and initialized
it to the user so we'll have to include
this in our other components that's
counter and click so let's do that and
here right before incremented to i say
this dot props dot name let me save it
let me do the same thing here and say
this dot props dot name so if you go
back to our browser here you can see it
says the user clicked zero times and the
user incremented to zero okay so this
basically shows how react implements
reusability of components moving on our
next topic is pure components now
another way to create class component is
by extending pure component from react a
pure component avoids unnecessary
re-renders now how does it do it it does
not implement the should component
update method now you'll learn about
this method a little later in the video
now this method enables re-rendering of
components to the dom but a pure
component on the other hand ensures a
shallow comparison of states and props
and checks if a re-render is actually
necessary only then does it render to
the dom a react component can be
considered pure if it renders the same
output for the same state and props so
let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create two component classes
one for a regular component and the
other for a pure component now using
this example i'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create a
purecomponent.js file i say
pureform.js so here i'm going to use a
snippet rpce that is going to create a
pure component class let me get rid of
this export and here in my div tag i'll
display the text say i'm
the pure component all right now let's
go ahead and create a regular component
let me call it
regularcomponent.js and here i'm going
to use the snippet rce and the message
that i want to display is
i'm
the regular component so to draw a
comparison between the regular component
and the pure component let's create a
parent component for the two so let me
create one here i'll call it parent
component.js and this is again going to
be a regular class component and here i
display the message i am the parent
component to change the state of the
component we're going to make use of a
constructor so let's use the snippet our
const and here let me create
name you can give anything and i say
simply learn now we make use of the
component did mount lifecycle method to
set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn about it
a little later in the video so moving
ahead i'm going to make use of the
method and say component
did mount and here i say set interval
and the first argument is going to be an
arrow function and the second will be
the time interval and i'm going to be
setting it to 3 seconds now within the
arrow function i'll make use of the set
state function to set the state of my
property however i do not change the
name i keep it simply on itself moving
on let's import pure component and the
regular component into our parent
component and then pass name as a
property so to do that first import
purecom from your component and then i
say import regularcom from regularcom.js
and here let's say regularcomp name
equals this dot state dot name and i say
pure component name equals this
dot state dot name now let's include the
property name in both our regular and
pure components so to do that let's just
say this dot prop dot name and here i
again say this
dot prop dot name and finally let's
import parent component into our app.js
component so here i say import parent
column from okay and here let me define
parent.com
so now if you look at the browser we
have i'm the parent and regular
component simply to set the state and
we're going to set the state for search
results to whatever is passed by the
system so the search results are going
to be returned as a callback and that's
what we stored as an updated state now
coming to the add track method so let's
scroll up and we'll say add track and
this will take the track to be added
let's declare a temporary variable
called tracks equal to this dot the
current state of all the tracks that are
there in the playlist now if track start
find i'm going to call the find method
so if we are able to find which means
that the track is already there in the
playlist then we would not want to add
it if it's not there in the playlist
that's when we would want to go and add
it the triple equal to is an equality
operator that will check for both a
watch value match and a match on the
data type as well okay so if the track
is uh already saved to nothing if the
track is not safe just track the track
id because that is the track that will
uh have to be added if it's not if it's
already there then just return if it's
not there then we've got to go to this
variable called tracks we'll use the
javascript method called push and we
will push the current track into this
tracks
array and then update the state so we
want to set the state of the playlist
tracks and this is how uh your state
management that we discussed in detail
is actually being practically
implemented here okay so the track has
been added now let's talk about the
remove track so that's the remove track
function and that's the track that we
want to remove so let's let tracks equal
to this dot state dot playlist tracks
those the set of current tracks that we
have and
let track search another temporary
variable equal to this dot the current
state of the search results then let's
take the tracks array equal to track
start filter so filter is of javascript
function that will again allow you to
remove a certain value create a
temporary variable called current track
use the lambda operator and if the
current track dot id is
not equal to the track dot id which
means this particular track is not there
in the list okay so you need to remove
that and again i have a method called as
unshift which will actually get rid of
the track in the array and then we've
got to so we'll search whether that
track is existing in the tracks array if
it is then we simply want to remove it
if not we do nothing so we set the state
we need to update the state of the
playlist because the track has been
removed so the playlist tracks will have
to be updated with this tracks array
okay then we go for remove track search
that's the next method that also will
take a track as a parameter okay here we
are going to say let tracks which is
another temporary variable we'll give it
this current state of
search results and then we are going to
set tracks equal to tracks dot filter
current track current track dot id not p
equal to the track dot id and then this
is where we would want to say this dot
set state
and we'll pick up search results
and let's go and assign that to track so
that's the updated uh set of tracks
after making the change let's remove
this and correct it okay so that's fine
so the remove track uh
is now the remove track and the remove
track search is now in place let's add
the do these functions which actually
again takes track as a parameter and
here we'll say this dot add track okay
so it adds the track and then it
removes the track from the search
criteria so the search component which
is managing searching of the tracks it
will go and remove it from there after
adding the new track so that's a
combined
operation we want to execute then i've
got update
playlist name which will take the name
of the track to update and this dot set
state the playlist
name is what we need to update with the
name that is passed to this function
then we've got to save playlists so
here let me create a constant variable
constants are variables whose values
will not frequently change we'll take
all the track uris dot state dot
playlist tracks
will be dot map create a temporary
variable called track track dot uri so
we actually want to go and
now save this on uh spotify so that's
the reason we'll access
spotify's save playlist method this dot
state dot playlist name comma track uris
and if that is successful we then go and
do a callback so that's the callback
anonymous function where we're going to
say this dot
set date and the playlist
name that we want to create on spotify
will be called new playlist so that's
the custom
name that i want to provide and the
playlist tracks
define that this closes here
okay so that's for the update on
spotify
now here is where uh the render method
is going to return the html now this
html is the view
and react simplifies this by having the
javascript and the html in the same
file so you can actually go and access
the variables you've declared in the
script directly in your html view
and synchronize and bind the data
together so it helps
from a maintainability perspective so
even though everything is in the same
file it's well classified and
differentiated into different code
blocks so we'll add the anchor tag and
we'd say href is http localhost so
that's the default server port on which
this application will run okay and we
want to give it a custom url name of
musical file so the h1 terminates will
then say div class name equal to app
within that this is how we're going to
inject our search bar that's going to be
the search bar component injected here
and on search so that's the custom event
we will call a method called search so
on search we just call we bind to a
method called this dot search then we'll
open up another div here we'll have
class name equal to app dash playlist
and if you remember that's exactly the
css
class name that we referred to in the
css file
we have another component called search
results
that we're going to inject here and
that's going to be search results here
search results will be equal to this dot
state dot search results so that's how
we can actually go and bind so that's
simple data binding the component is
going to be displayed with the data
bound and if somebody says add if if i
click on the add button for search
results
do these so it will add that new track
to the playlist by calling binding to
the 2ds function and it will remove it
from the search results text box then we
have another component called playlist
and here the playlist tracks
will be bound to this dot state dot
playlist tracks okay so on the top if
you look here we started with defining
all the function declarations in the
constructor then we provided the
function definitions okay that's how and
this that we passed refers to the
context of the current
component itself so whatever you put
into the app component or into the
respective component those values will
be then passed out here to these
individual functions okay so that's with
the playlist couple of things we'll have
to do is if somebody changes the name of
the track so on name change is going to
be another custom event where we'll have
to call this dot update playlist name
and we also have remove functionality so
to remove a track we would say equal to
this dot remove track on save equal to
this dot
save playlist okay so that's done and we
close this so we seem to be pretty much
on track the export
app will make this all of these
functions accessible across other
components it's very similar to the
public access specifiers etc that you
provide
in other programming languages so that's
done we've created our app component now
let's create another folder under
components and we've got to define all
our various components here this folder
is going to be
for the search bar so we'll name it
search bar we'll add two files within it
the search bar dot css okay and another
file that we'll need here is
search bar
dot js
so that's in terms of the search bar
let's start with the css file so we'll
start with first styling search bar we
will say that the display should be flex
flex
direction should be column we want all
the items to be aligned at the center so
that's align item center then we'll add
up padding so padding top
is going to be 6.94
rpm and
margin
bottom is going to be 6.33
rem all right now let's add up for the
search bar so that's search bar we'll
add
for the input element we want the width
to be 287 pixels the padding to be 0.880
the border should be 1 pixel solid white
the border radius
will give a slight rounded edge to give
a web 3.0 look and feel so we'll set up
the border radius then we've got
margin bottom so we've got a bottom
margin that we want to add up then we
have color so let's add up the color c3f
so that's the color black then let's add
text alignment of
center and let's add up a font size of
one rem okay so that's how we've set
this up let's add
the search bar input is going to be
so if someone focuses so focus is the
got focus so if someone clicks inside so
the end user goes and clicks inside the
text box
we change the outline to none okay and
so for the search bar we are interested
on input and if the input is
focused so that's the event that we are
looking for and then we would have a
button called search button so on the
search button the cursor will set it to
pointer so that's the cursor pointer the
width we set it to 8.1
rem the padding we are going to set up
to
0.77 rem and 0 the border radius
we'll set it to 54 pixels so we get a
slightly well defined search button with
a nice little border let's also add
background color hash 1db
954 that gives me a color then i've got
my text alignment let's set that to
center then we've got a font family
let's set up the font family to the same
standard font 80 and it's a part of the
sans serif family then we'll set up the
font size
to 0.833
rem correct this
uh and finally
we will need transition so all of these
are basic uh css properties so that will
add a slight uh transitional effect with
a delay of
that many milliseconds
so transition background color we've
provided what else let me scroll up uh
let's also provide a border here so
we'll remove in fact let's remove the
border we would not want a border on the
button that would look odd so i'll get
rid of the border and color we'll
specify as per our standard color that
we've been using okay so that's the
color we've specified and then i've got
font weight of 500. finally we'll take
the search button and on the search
button we will register for the hover
event so if someone takes their mouse
over the button that's the over the
event in that case if we hover around
the button we would want the background
color to change so it will appear to
have a slight little glow there a mouse
pointer moves over the button okay so
that's the opacity and
the rgb combination so that completes
the css file for the search bar and we
obviously now need to go and get the
code in for
our search bar component and that's
exactly what we are going to do next so
let's start with setting up the code for
the search file first thing let's go and
import
react from
react
next thing we would want to do is import
the search bar dot
css file then we define a class
called search bar which extends
react dot
component we define our constructor and
we go and
pass these parameters to the base class
we also define
the state we'll just need one variable
here which is
the term to search for in the search bar
and then let's say this dot
will define a function called handle
term change which is going to be equal
to this dot handle handle term change
dot
find
so that's going to be the first function
then a function that will do the
searching for us
which is this dot search so that's the
search function and we'll have it bind
to this
then we've got this dot
handle enter so the moment we enter into
that search text box
handle enter dot find this
so the functions are ready now let's go
for the first one which is handle term
change
we'll pass it a system defined keyword
of event this dot
set state and for the term
we will use the event keyword we will
get
the value that is there inside that text
box the moment the search term the user
is entered changes so the search
criteria changes we trap the updated
value then in the search function we
will update
the local property props dot on
search
okay so we'll access the on search and
pass it the updated term and then we got
the handle enter on which
we're also going to pass the system
define event keyword so if there's any
data flowing along with the event we are
interested in it in this case the data
is the key code that the user is
pressing and if it is 13 that indicates
that's the ascii key code for the enter
button so if the enter is hit then the
user is completed entering the search
criteria and we need to start searching
and that's where
we write our render method that's going
to render the html view and we return
the complete view here so that's the
view now that we want to return let's
say diff class name equal to search bar
then on the input text box we will use
placeholder equal to enter song album
or artist that you want to search for on
change on the on change event the moment
the term changes we connect that to
handle term change we already have an
function that manages that and the
moment
keys are pressed and released so on key
up is where we would want to connect to
this dot handle enter okay and this is
place bracket that i'll have to put up
here so in the render function uh we're
going to return a value i shouldn't
forget to export the search bar okay so
that's uh what i want to export so we've
exported that okay so at the end of this
uh what we've done is we've written a
render method we've written our div tag
here is where we'll go and close
the div tag we've added an input and
here is where i'm going to add a button
provide a class name called search
button and the moment the end user
clicks on the button we're going to
connect it to this dot
search and we close
the button back within the pattern tag
search so that
completes the
render function so in the render
function again let's run through all of
what we've written we started with
extending react.component we then added
a constructor passing props to the super
class constructor we created
state we set it to a value of
term and null so the state uh currently
we defined as term then we said handle
term changes search and handle enter
should be functions
that we want to add then handle term
changes
we defined search we defined and handle
enter we've also defined then we used
render render we said is going to return
to us
the html that we've specified okay we
dumped all the html that we want this
component to return to us
so on change and on key up are
two functions that
or two events that we connected to where
we called handle term change and handle
enter then we added a button where we
registered for the click event and
connected it to this dot search so all
the three functions uh that we
are actually written
so two things we have completed now
in the app class
okay if you look at the app class we've
actually defined a set of functions here
that deal with the playlist and adding
applications etc adding tracks removing
tracks
then we've created
the search bar okay so we saw that the
search bar also we have specified a set
of functions
and all the functions that we defined we
have taken care to structure every
component separately so the search
component is doing something completely
different which is managing the search
bar we have the core the root app
component in which we have imported all
of the other set of javascript classes
uh that we are creating and that's how
the entire application is now structured
so and that's the core uh
concept when you're working with react
where you would actually have every
separate uh block of
code or every separate functionality
handled in a different component
altogether so we've completed the search
bar component as well so two components
done and two components good to go so
we've got to start up on the next set of
components that we will need to build
and the next component is the track
component that will manage individual
tracks so a new folder a new file called
track.css
and
track.js
so that's going to manage
the tracks for us
so let's start with dot track we would
say display is flex
align items
center border bottom one pixel solid
rgba
256
256
56 0.8 that's the opacity then let's
come to track action so we'll use all of
these classes uh when we write up the
html view we'll add a padding here of
0.5 we'll set up a font size
of 1.05
set up a transition color of 0.25
s
order of 0 pixel and
a background color of rgb a
0 0 0 0 color ash so that's the color
that we continue to use then we bring in
track another class track action and if
we hover over this class we want
the gb values
change to 265 265
265 5 is the last parameter so that's
the hover
then we have track information so track
information is the next class that we're
dealing with we'll add the flex
parameter first display flex
and
then flex direction
is going to be column let's have justify
content set up as
center and let's have height as
180 pixel so that's uh track information
let's have another track information and
the h3 tags nested inside that for all
the h3 tags nested inside that we'll
need a margin bottom of 0.22
rem finally let's have track information
and paragraph tag we'll have the font
size
of
0.83 rem and a font weight of 300 and a
color as well that we'll add so let's
add up a color here rgba 2 6 256
256
256 and 0.8 okay so that's uh that's in
terms of the css and let's move to the
track and we will move into the
javascript file so let's move into so
let me take what we added in the search
bar i'll go to the track.js
this will change to track dot css
okay the constructor this will change to
add track so add track change this to
add track this is
remove track change this to remove track
get rid of this and that's going to be
the add track function and here we're
going to say uh this dot props
so we'll modify this this dot
props
dot on add this dot props dot track and
then we have the remove track so that's
going to be the remove track function
this function is not required so this
dot prop starts on
remove
and this is the track that we would want
to go and remove we'll add up another
function called render action so this is
going to be a function
that we are defining called render
action and in this we'll just check if
this dot props dot is
remove if this dot props dot is
removal so in that case
we would want to return so this is a
view action method that we are adding
which is going to go and add this button
with a class called as track action that
we've already written the css for and
this button will actually get added
via this render action function and this
dot
remove track is what it's going to map
to let's close this
this is going to point to this specific
function so that's uh the closing button
tag okay so the closing button tag is
what
we've added there and the binding is
what we have done to this dot
remove track and
we will terminate this
here so now the render action uh let's
also have the return here and we just
add up the button and this is going to
add track so you can look at how the
component is completely dynamic
in nature so we have two buttons that
are going to be added this button with a
hyphen is going to remove the track this
button uh with a plus sign is going to
add the track and you can actually see
how simply it was done in a render
action function so the render action
function actually helped
with
checking that if
on the value of the props
and if the user
depending on
the action performed you will actually
be able to remove a track or add a track
from the existing playlist okay and then
uh the class name here is now going to
be track the class name for
uh the enclosing div inside it so let me
get rid of this the class name for the
enclosing div here
is going to be
track dash
information within it we'll add h3 we'll
bind to this dot props dot track dot
name so the name of the track is going
to get bound here then in the paragraph
we will find to this dot props
dot track dot artist
and
with some gap this dot props dot track
dot album so that's what
we've data bound to
and then let me add an iframe an iframe
allows us to uh very easily inject some
content into the page within a small
embedded window the source parameter of
the frame is going to be https
open
dot so here i'm connecting to the
spotify stream
spotify.com slash embed slash track and
close this so that's the spotify stream
that we're going to connect to and this
dot props dot track dot id so that's the
track id the width is going to be 300
the height parameter this the height
parameter is going to be 80 of the
iframe and
the frame order is going to be 0
and the allow
transparency so that's the opacity we'll
say true let's add allow
encrypted media so if spotify has
encrypted media that also would be
embedded here and we can also have the
title set to preview so that's uh with
the iframe okay at the bottom is where
we would want to so this could be an
empty element and we can close it
right around here so we wouldn't need
this part and then here i'm just going
to say this dot
render action so we call the render
action method uh which will actually
give us plus minus button to add and
remove
new element okay and that's uh what we
can actually go and add up there so
let's check now whether uh all that
we've done is good to go fine so
everything looks good uh in terms of the
track component now and
we have all of the functions in place
it's now time to jump into the
next component that we would require
after the track component and
that's going to be the track list so
this is going to be a list
component that will comprise of a list
of tracks inside it so we'll create a
new folder call this track list
and that's going to have
track list
css
and it's going to have track list dot js
so that's the track list
component now which
we're going to go ahead and use
and the css we don't need much so let's
just say track list
and we just provide a width of 100
okay that's all we need uh in the css so
let me add this in the css file save
this
and come to the js file now which is
going to have
the track list code that we will need to
add up so here again i'm going to say
import react
from react we'd also want to import
track list dot css
and
we
also want to go and get track because
this component is going to be made up of
a collection of tracks individual tracks
so we want to get this from track slash
track and we'll define class track list
which is going to go and extend
react dot
component
we just need the render method here
because this just needs to go it does
not really have any state of itself it
simply goes and returns a list of
individual tracks
so this class name is going to be track
list
and we'll find to this dot props dot
tracks dot map create a temporary
variable
and this will go and return
the track component
which is going to bind to individual
track data the key is going to be track
dot id so the key is going to be track
dot id
and on add on adding a new track we want
to bind to this dot properties dot and
we already have on add defined so that's
what we connect to add up my
base bracket here okay and
then we would also need
is
removal
equal to
this dot props dot is
removal and the on remove will do this
dot drop slot on remove so that's for
the track removal and
so we've got our track list
oh yes we'll have to go and
also close the tip tag correctly and
also we need to go and export
so we'll have to go and export
the track
list
so we've got one more component done
which is track lists and let's move on
to the next component now so we've got
app which is root we've got the search
bar that takes care of uh entering the
search criteria we've got individual
tracks that are searched and returned
and we've got a tracked list that
manages a set of track records so the
track is more relevant to the playlist
and then we've got the search results
also to manage once we search for some
set of tracks so we'll add a new folder
which manages search results
and this is going to have
search results dot css
and it's going to have
search results dot js
okay so we need a search results.css
and js and here in the css file we'll
keep it simple for the search
results so we'll say search results
we'll set up the width of 50
we
set up the height of 950
pixels
we'll say
overflow y is
scroll we'll say padding is 0.88
rem background color will be rgba
95
23 23 0.7
and we will use the box model so we'll
provide a shadow dropping shadow of zero
four pixels to pixels to pixels ash
and then uh let's add
a scroll bar so
webkit
and mozad are the constants specific to
mozilla and
chrome browsers
so they target certain animated features
etc or properties
that are specific to those individual
browsers that's the reason we use those
constants
and then we'll also add a media query
that if it goes with a max
with one zero two zero pixels
in that case dot search results
width is ninety percent
with a margin bottom of two are
okay so
we're going to add the hyphen so it's
hyphen webkit scroll bar zero pixel
width
and we've set
transparent background so that's that's
about it with
the css i need to get to the uh js file
now let's move to the search results uh
js file and
that's where we will now have to go and
add up
the component code for search results
and let me take
pick this up from track list
add it up here this will be
search results
and
we'll need the results will return to us
a list of tracks so we'll have to get uh
track list this will be track list
and
i'm just going to return class name will
also be
search results so that's the component
and this is going to export out search
results so it's accessible across
other components then we've got h2 with
results
let's go and create
track list with a set of tracks and we
will bind it to this dot props
dot search results
and on the on add we are going to bind
to this dot props dot on add so we
already have that so that uh basically
completes
search results and
that leaves us with the last component
which is going to manage the playlist
for us so we'll add up a new books we'll
add up a new folder in components
and that's going to be playlist
and within that we will have a playlist
dot css
and
a playlist dot js
so that's our
playlist component now that
we're going to work with and the
playlist component is
uh we'll first set up
the css that we will need
to add up to the playlist and
i'm just going to
pick that up from my code snippet so
that's my playlist and let me get all of
that css here so that's uh just a css
for the playlist nothing to do with
react again pure css uh let me get uh
into the js file and that's where we
will need to go and add all of our
component code so again let me go to the
track.js
the track list rather let me get this
and add it
out here we'll make some small changes
this is going to be playlist
i need to import the track list
because the playlist is going to contain
a list of tracks
this is going to be
playlist and
let me
here this will be playlist and we leave
this
for later okay let me also get uh the
constructor in so we'll add up the
constructor here and just one function
that we will need here which is handle
name change you know if i need to change
the name of the playlist so handle name
change and that's exactly the function
that we will need to write code for so
that's the event
and this dot props
dot on
name change that's when we'll say event
dot
target dot value so we get the updated
playlist name coming to the render we
now need the input
input
is going to be on change equal to this
dot
handle name change
the default
value we have already provided with a
hard-coded value which is new playlist
so that's the default value if
not provided then we'll just pick up the
default value then we've got
track list so track list is what i will
add the tracks i'm going to bind to this
dot props dot playlist
tracks
so we're going to bind this to playlist
tracks
and here we will say
is
removal equal to
true and on remove
equal to we'll find that to this dot
props
dot on remove
finally we will need a button we will
use
class name equal to playlist
dash
save that's what we've added in the css
click equal to this dot props
dot on save and here we're going to say
save to
spotify so that's with the
playlist and yes we need to go and
export playlist and not track list
now we'll need to uh do a quick look up
in spotify so let's go to this website
called developer.spotify.com
and once once we sign in
and create an id it takes us to our
dashboard
that's where we can create a sample
application the name of the application
will be musical file okay and
we'll say that we are building uh some
kind of desktop app for example for
which we want to uh connect this to and
we'll also need to provide
so we'll say next
refresh the dashboard so it's
asking me for a login so let me log in
once more so moment i login that's going
to be description and i'll say maybe
this is why i need it i'll say no not
commercial integration agree with the
terms and conditions and we will say
submit
and that's the application that has got
created and now i can say edit settings
and
the redirect url here is what is
important
so it should accept connections from
http localhost 3000 that's the port on
which we will host our application okay
and we'll say save okay so that's uh now
there's a client id that is generated
here for my app which is unique so i'll
just copy that up let me come up to my
application under the source folder i'm
going to add a new folder called util
and under that a new file called
spotify.js
so we will start with
adding our code to the spotify.js file
that we've just created as a new file
within the newly created util folder the
first line of code is going to define a
client id variable that equates to the
client id uh that we will generate on
spotify so this is going to be the
spotify generated client id which is a
unique id associated for the developer
to connect to the spotify api and we
will look at uh the source of that as we
go through the demo the next variable
that we'll create is the redirect url or
let's call it redirect uri and that will
equate to localhost colon 3000 which is
the port and we'll create another
variable called the access token let's
also create another constant variable
called spotify and this will work like a
function expression so we'll equate it
to a function called get access token
and we will say if access token is true
then return the access token now let's
declare a constant variable called
access token match which will be equal
to window dot location dot
href dot match
and we will say this is equal to access
token which will be equal to and we will
give a rejects expression to do a
pattern match ampersand so that we can
actually get into the url and extract
the token information from that and
hence
the patent match is crucial here another
constant
variable called
expires in match
equal to window dot location dot href
dot match here we will read the expiry
information using another hx expression
from the url ampersand asterisk so
that's the second constant variable
we've created now we will say if access
token match and
expires in match in that case
the access token should be equal to
access token match of one then we create
a variable called
expires in equal to we'll do a typecast
to number and we will take the first
parameter from the expires in match
that's done then we will say window dot
set timeout and we're going to say
access token equal to comma
expires in multiplied by thousand then
we will say window dot history dot push
state and we will say access token we
pass the second parameter as null the
last parameter as slash and close this
and we will return access token else
we will say const access
url equal to https
accounts.spotify.com
slash
authorize
client underscore id equal to dollar
client id ampersand response type equal
to token ampersand scope equal to
playlist dash
modify so we're actually building the
url that will now get generated so we'll
say modify dash public and redirect
url
equal to dollar redirect uri so we have
constructed the url now that will go out
and get generated in the browser and
here we are going to say window dot
location equal to access url then we'll
add the search criteria function which
accepts a term as a parameter to search
on here we will say constant access
token equal to spotify dot get access
token so we get a reference to the same
access token return we call the fetch
function and we're going to pass
https
api dot spotify
dot com slash
v1 slash
search question mark that's the query
string that we will add type equal to
track and ampersand g equal to dollar
and we will pass term comma as the
header information we will need to pass
the authorization where we will say that
the pairer is dollar access token dot
then
response return response dot json dot
then so the return of this function once
it completes we will then call the next
function so json response
and then we will say return response dot
json after that another then block so
we'll now say json response
and if
not
json response
dot tracks in that case we will return
an empty array else
we will return json response dot tracks
dot items dot and we will pass
we'll create track as
a variable with a lambda expression and
we'll create a temporary json object
with id and that's where we want to
associate track dot id that was returned
as the search result the name is going
to be associated with track dot name the
artist is going to be associated with
track dot artists of zero dot name the
album is going to be track dot album dot
name and the uri we will equate track
dot url so that completes uh this block
will open the next and we this will be
the save playlist which will take the
name and the track uris and here we will
check if not
name or not track uris dot len in that
case we simply return out of the code
and then we declare a constant variable
called access token which will be equal
to spotify dot get access token so we
get a reference to the access token we
then declare headers
authorization bearer is going to be
dollar access token and we'll create a
user id and now we will return the fetch
result where we will pass https
api dot spotify dot com slash v1 slash
me so that's the url comma headers
will be the header information then we
call the then function declare response
as a variable use the lambda expression
and access response dot json we use the
then block to declare json response
here we say user id equal to
jsonresponse.id
and then we return fetch
https
api.spotify.com
slash v1 slash users slash dollar of
user id slash
playlist so this is how we've
constructed the urls manually here we
will say assign headers to the headers
variable we'll assign method as post so
the data is sent as part of the body and
not as part of the url and as the body
we will say json.stringify
to convert this parameter name and then
we will generate a response variable to
response.json
and then we'll create jsonresponse with
the lambda operation we'll create a
constant playlist
id which is equal to json response dot
id we will return fetch
https
api.spotify.com
v1 users
dollar user id slash playlist slash
dollar again we are constructing the url
so playlist id will be replaced here
then we will say tracks and close this
comma and here again we will say headers
would equate to the headers
variable we constant headers and this
goes here okay everything fixed now so
here we're going to say headers should
equate to headers and
the method is going to be post and
the body is going to be json dot
stringify uris
track uris and we close this we close
this block we close this block and we
close this block so that completes our
code of course one more thing we have to
do which is export this class out so
export default spotify and that
completes the code for
the spotify.js
which is part of our utils class so
let's move on now to the next step so
uh here is
the client id that we'll have to exactly
match so i'll copy this client id and
provide it here so that's the client id
that we actually need and we could also
store it
out here
so that's the
client id and that's the redirect url
that we've also defined there and we
just create an access token if your
access token is true we return access
token so the access token is something
that we are going to do a match from uh
the moment we try and connect with this
particular url and you can look here
that this is the access url that we are
trying to connect with okay with the
client id and post fixed with the
redirect url right and then i've got a
simple search function which returns an
observable so we try to fetch data using
the search term that we provided okay we
try to fetch data using the search term
provided if we are successful we get a
response of the data and accordingly
we'll iterate over the json response and
get a list of tracks out of it and do a
mapping of this json object to the track
id name artist information album name
etc and here
just like a data access layer very
similar to a data access layer we've got
a save function which will save this
data to spotify as well so i've got a
save playlist and i've got search so
these are the two functions which will
go and connect to the spotify service
by using this client id
and it will allow me to
access that information in terms of
returning a stream of json data and will
then allow me to
go ahead and push that json data into
our application so now we
actually need to start up the
application so i'll go to the terminal
and rather let me go to view and
bring out the terminal so this is the
integrated terminal that's there in the
tool and it just opens powershell from
which you can actually fire your
commands so i'm going to say node
package manager npm start to actually
start up this application so that's
going to do a full compile and
so we will fire this up give access so i
need to grant access
to that port 3000
let's give it time to run and that's the
app now that
you can actually see here so this is uh
the search bar that we actually had okay
then we had the results we had the
playlist now the results is going to
consist of
a set of tracks which are maintained by
the track list and then you can take
individual tracks with the plus and
minus button and add them into the
playlist okay so that's how
it's typically going to work okay so as
you can view here i'm just going to
search for an artist
and we'll click on the search button it
goes to spotify tries to connect there
and says
that i need to agree to the terms and
conditions and i've just agreed to that
so the very fact that it actually uh
gave us
a confirmation link the moment we tried
to connect and execute our application
uh that's proof enough that it actually
went and connected to the
service there and tried to return a
value to us so this is what we did we
just added an artist we said search
and you can see now it's successfully
connected i've got a list of tracks
available from this artist and you can
see the plus buttons getting added on
the fly so that was the render action
these are
buttons that got added onto this list of
tracks dynamically the moment the search
results returned a value so i can click
on this plus sign and you can see that
the track gets added to the playlist
okay as in when i click here so i've
added a couple of tracks
uh if i go back to my dashboard of my
music file application and that i've
created here in the developers portal of
spotify on
developers.spotify.com it's blank so now
i'm going to click on save to spotify
okay and that clears the playlist
so let me come here
and
now when i come out here we saw that it
actually got
successfully it out here now i'll have
to log in to so this was the development
app that we actually created on the
developers portal of spotify now we will
go to spotify.com
so i'll just go to the spotify website
and it says do you want to launch the
web player and all that so let me click
on that so it just launches
and can you see here this is the new
playlist
that just got added right and there were
four songs that i'd actually added to
the playlist and you can see here those
four songs have got added out here okay
so i can go here and
i can delete this playlist and say i
want to delete it okay so there's no
playlist now i'll go back here
i'll add two tracks and i'll say save to
spotify so that's how you actually saw
that the new playlist you can see the
new playlist has come back here okay and
that's the playlist the playlist has got
generated again and that's the new
playlist that
got created and we deleted it but it
still got created again and that
indicates the connectivity
that we successfully created with this
react app and the core concept of the
react app was breaking it down into
components which is the search component
then we created the track component we
created the track list to maintain a
list of tracks
then we created the search results which
will generate a list of results which
further contains a track list and this
is the embedded iframe which gave us the
response which is scrollable here and
you can see that the iframes we created
allowed us to scroll this
with this embedded web page inside the
iframe container so with that uh i hope
we've been successful with explaining
the concept of component based design
and architecture with react and how
important it is to create individual
components and the benefit of that being
that you can isolate change requests to
a certain component you can promote
reusability wherever you want the same
feature to be implemented on the page
you can just inject that same component
and the same implementation and the same
features can be reused so it promotes
reusability it promotes flexibility to
change it isolates your change request
to single components preventing the
massive effort of recompiling and
re-testing the entire application as a
whole in this session we'll be comparing
the three cutting-edge ui development
technologies that is react.js angular
and vue we learn about the key
differences that make them so distinct
all of these technology stacks have been
replacing pure server-side technologies
and we've slowly progressed from
server-side applications to more
distributed applications where a part of
the job is done on the client side and
apart on the server side and now we've
transitioned to something known as
single page applications or sba and all
of these technologies that you see on
your screen right now are based purely
on javascript as a result they're
lightweight and aren't dependent on any
third-party runtime tools so let's
compare the three technologies and learn
about the factors that make them stand
out so let's see what's in it for you we
learn about their features use cases and
where they're applied their performance
how they handle data the languages they
use and the testing mechanisms we learn
about the dedicated user community that
backs these technologies and finally
we'll see the growth curve first we'll
look into the salient features now react
is a front-end javascript library while
angular and vue are javascript
frameworks now although the terms
library and frameworks are used
interchangeably they're significantly
different now library is a set of
classes or functions and the user is in
complete control to call them frameworks
on the other hand are like models they
have limited choices and come with a
blueprint of their own and as a result
the user doesn't have much control so
javascript being an interpreted language
where code is executed line by line
makes all these tools very efficient
mainly because converting the code into
an intermediate code would require a
runtime environment and would definitely
encounter a delay now these are avoided
and as a result these tools are fast
moving on react is used to develop
mobile and web applications and angular
is used for single page applications and
you can also develop hybrid applications
using the stack mainly because it's
purely based on css html javascript and
jquery single page applications as the
name suggests are built using single
page now the entire page is broken down
into several components wherein each
component performs a specific task say
for example one component handles the
login the other one would display icons
and images and so on all these bits or
components are then put together to form
a single page application and moving on
react was developed and maintained by
facebook while angular was built by
google and view was developed by even
unx google employee now react represents
the view part of the mvc framework and
angular is a full-fledged mvc framework
in itself and view on the other hand is
focused on view and the model layer of
the mvc framework now what exactly is
the mvc framework now mvc framework is
an object oriented design principle that
mandates the separation of control
meaning one thing can only do one thing
so the model deals with the entity
classes the data and the business logic
while view deals with the representation
and the ui logic of the application and
the controller drives the functionality
of the two any changes can be easily
factored and isolated and as a result
testing becomes a whole lot easier
moving on now let's look at the use
cases from the business perspective in
terms of react we have top websites like
facebook instagram netflix that use
react on the other hand we have angular
that is used by nike hbo forbes sony and
vue is commonly used by alibaba.com
grammarly nine gag and adobe moving on
we have performance now performance is a
very crucial feature now the moment you
build an html view and render it into
the browser this view to the user is
basically just html tags however if you
look at the internal working the code is
actually converted into a balanced tree
structure this b3 algorithm is extremely
fast so when the user makes any changes
to the ui the changes are reflected
immediately this is facilitated by the
b3 algorithm so as a result the
performance is improved so how does
react make use of this tool it uses a
virtual dom dom is an api developed by
w3c it stands for document object model
and defines how the document is accessed
and manipulated this dom parser converts
the html code into an inverse balance
tree structure so react uses the virtual
dom while angular uses the real dom and
vue uses the virtual dom again now the
virtual dom looks at the differences
between the current and the previous
html pages and only changes the parts
that need to be updated angular on the
other hand updates the entire tree
structure regardless of any changes made
or not and view again only updates the
ones that have changed since there is no
time spent on making unnecessary changes
to the entire tree react is extremely
fast on the other hand real dom updation
is time consuming risky and error pro
vue also ensures faster and bug free
performance now let's talk about data
binding the core reason why we would use
single page applications now consider a
scenario where you'd log into an
ecommerce website as say user1 then you
should be able to see the items in your
shopping cart while user 2 would be
seeing different items in their shopping
carts and so on so identifying the user
and retrieving data corresponding to
that specific user is facilitated using
the help of data binding data binding is
a process that allows an internet user
to manipulate web page elements using a
web browser now it is used in
interactive components such as
calculators tutorials games etc now
react supports one-way data binding
meaning you can take the data from the
view and push it to the model or vice
versa angular on the other hand uses a
two-way data binding while vue also uses
a similar two-way data binding in react
every time the model state updates the
view changes accordingly however the
reverse is not true in case of angular
any changes made to the view are
immediately reflected in the model part
of the architecture view follows the
same principle now this hugely
influences the performance due to
one-way data binding react is modular
and fast improving the performance
angular's two-way data binding adversely
affects the performance and view on the
other hand performs according to the
input type moving on to scripting
languages react combines ui templates
and javascript logic resulting in a new
language called jsx so react only
requires a knowledge of javascript
angular uses templates again in html you
can also inject javascript code into
html using a clever implementation in
angular called directives so you can
create a class and then inject it into
html angular also does something better
you can also write code for an angular
application using a newer language
developed by microsoft called typescript
it is a compiled language and is very
similar to java and c-sharp in terms of
syntax now view again uses html based
template it uses html5 throughout for
the ui and the combination of javascript
for business logic all view templates
are valid html and can be passed by html
parsers let's move on to testing now
just is a framework or an api that is
developed by facebook and is used to run
tests on react applications to ensure
that they are bug free now it is
embedded typically in every react
library and requires zero configuration
now angular on the other hand uses the
jasmine framework now this framework
allows various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases this also
ensures that the application is error
free the view cli or the command line
interpreter has built-in options for
unit testing with the help of jest or
mocha now vue typically has single file
components and hence these components
can be tested in isolation this makes it
modular and extremely fast now let's
talk about community support since all
these tools are open source they have a
large developer community there are a
few popular github repositories for
react such as react.js 101 react.js.org
and so on you can raise queries solve a
few and connect with the larger
community that's working on react here
are a few repositories for angular view
also has a few popular repositories you
can commit download third party plugins
and also explore these stacks even
deeper all of them surely have a very
happening community at the time of
writing there were about 1 million
repositories 5 million comments and 1
million issues with respect to react
here are the figures for angular and
here are the figures for vue according
to npm stat over the past two years
there have been approximately 360
million react.js downloads there have
been around 38 million downloads for
angular and around 63 million downloads
for view now let's look at the future
scope learning a new technology always
comes with questions like what's in it
for me what's its growth potential how
far will it take me in my career and so
on so let's go ahead and see the growth
rate of react angular and vue according
to google trends over the past 12 months
react has been on a way faster upward
trajectory than angular and view which
have considerably lost their momentum
now this indicates that react is growing
faster than the other two with respect
to popularity industry adoption and
community support welcome to this
session on how to connect
react.js with node.js and in this
session uh we are actually going to look
at
how do we connect react.js with node.js
so a very warm welcome to this session
on react.js connectivity with node.js
and in this session we are going to
focus on how do we connect our react.js
application with the node.js platform so
we are going to dive into creating a
hands-on demo which will have two parts
to it we would have the client
application that we will first create as
a react application we will then create
an express gs application with node.js
and we will then try to connect both of
those applications together so
express.js is a rapid application
development framework that allows us to
create a web application very quickly on
the node.js platform and we'll use it to
create a custom api and then connect
that endpoint to the react.js client
application so let's dive into our demo
and
let's start with creating our client and
node express applications and see how to
set them up and then get them connected
to each other let's start with our
hands-on demo and we will first go to
the node.js website nodejs.org we can
download the lts version which is a
stable version of node.js moment i click
on this it will prompt me for a download
it will download the msi file and then
all i need to do is double click on it
keep clicking on the next button and
install that would install node.js for
us next we'll open our editor you can
use any editor of your choice so i'm
going to use uh an editor called
visual studio code and let's open up the
terminal here and i also have the
command prompt open where i've navigated
to a folder that i've created called
react.js demos now we'll invoke the npm
package manager which is invoked by the
command npx so npx will not only install
packages but also execute them once they
are installed so once they are
downloaded it will execute the package
and
we will use npx to go and create a react
application called client so while we
give it time for the installation to
complete we can then open it
within our editor so we'll give it time
uh so that the installation completes
so the installation is completed and so
we've seen here that the installation is
now completed and let's uh go and open
up this project so i will say file and
open folder and
let me pick up that folder and we will
open this application called client so
that's my client app let's fire up the
terminal so
okay so that has launched the terminal
for us
and here
all we need to do to fire up this
application and get it running is npm
start which will compile and start up
this application that is created let's
close this we'll go to the browser and
now let's say localhost 3000 so that
gives us a startup page the sample uh
default startup page for the first
client application uh and this is going
to work as a client we'll now go and try
to create uh the backend uh application
which is going to be another application
that we will set up and to create that
let's say npx
express
generator api okay so this will uh
create an express application on node.js
called api and let's give it some time
for installation okay so that's done
clear this screen we'll come out here
we'll open another instance of the
editor we'll say open folder and that's
the api application we'll say select
folder and the api application is opened
let's go to the terminal now in the
terminal we will attempt to install all
of the packages that are required that
would be logged in the package.json file
so the package.json file here would be
listed uh so you can see we have a list
of packages that it uses and npm install
will go and install all of these
packages that were pre-listed here so
let me ensure it's executed correctly
and we'll fire that once more that's
done so npm install has installed all of
the packages required and let me
terminate this run by pressing a control
c so this terminates
the client application that was
executing and now we will say npm start
so that this application executes and
let's refresh
so that's the standard express
application now that has got installed
now let's go to the api application
we'll go into the bin folder and here
we'll have a file called www we will
change the default port number from 3000
to 9000 let me stop this application
from executing we've just updated the
port number now let's go to the routes
and we'll create a new file in the
routes folder called test api dot js
here we will say variable express
equal to require express
and here we'll say variable router equal
to express dot
router and here we will say
router dot get we'll open this
so that's the default route root route
is going to be slash for which we'll add
a callback function which will take the
request and the response parameter and
next pointer in case there is another
function to call post that and here we
will just send a simple message saying
api is working okay a simple message
sent out for the root default route and
we'll have to export this so we'll say
module dot exports equal to router all
right so that's uh done let's go to the
app.js file and here let us import that
so here is where we will import this
by saying app.use we want to use the
test api file and that is
test api router and this is exactly the
same variable name that we will declare
here which will be equal to require and
we are going to say routes
test api all right so let's try
launching this now we would say npm
start after adding this code let's go
out here and 3000 test api is going to
be the url to hit it's not 3 000 but
9000 now because we just updated the
port so 9000 test api and there we have
a message which says that the api is
working properly so this is tested now
let's go to the client application in
the client application let's go to the
app.js file okay this is the file that
we would have to revamp a bit so let's
uh revamp this here we will declare a
class app which extends so that creates
a new module so it extends
react.component and here we have
constructor we will accept the props
here i would pass props to the super
class constructor and
set the state to api response
currently it just has an empty value
next we'll add up a new function called
call api which will generate a call to
that
api url which was http localhost 9000
was the port and test api was the url
once this is called we will then call
the then function declare response
generate a call to response.txt and then
we will again say this dot set state api
response
is going to be equal to the response
that comes in from that url which is
nothing but a string which says api is
working another function called
component will mount so the moment the
component is initialized on the screen
and loaded we will generate a call to
this function we created called call api
then comes
the render function in the render
function we would go and return a div
class name is app this would be app
header the standard logo after which
in the paragraph we wouldn't need the
link here right after the header we'll
add a paragraph where we will print this
dot state and the variable we created
called api response and we will data
bind to that so that largely completes
uh the return so we simply create this
application uh that's the react
application that will talk to this api
that is and this uh url that is hosted
on node communicate with it get a simple
string as a response print that string
inside this
react application so once that's done uh
we have the component wheel mount which
is a life cycle method here it's a life
cycle event that gets triggered the
moment the component loads and that's
when we have actually gone and executed
the call api custom function let's go to
the api application we'll terminate the
execution here there's one more step
that we'll have to perform which is
cross origin
resource sharing which means that to
allow the react application to
communicate from another hosted domain
to this particular domain server we will
actually have to enable cross origin
scripting and sharing otherwise it will
block the request coming from another
application so for that we have to
install globally cross origin module and
dash dash save indicates that it's going
to do a global install for all
applications
that are on this particular system so
we've installed this
and we'll clear the screen let's go to
the app.js
and right here is where we would want it
to go and use cards so we will say
app.use course so that it uses this
particular api and here is where we will
declare the course variable and go and
import the new library package that we
just installed which is quartz so looks
good and now let's uh fire up this
application with an npm start let's also
fire up client with an npm start and now
when i go and
try looking for localhost 3000 which is
the react application the react
application should go and talk to the
api that is hosted on node.js which
returns to me that string message so if
i go and ping that api separately which
is localhost
9000 test api you can see this is a
standard message so here i've directly
ping the api that's hosted in node.js
now we are consuming it through the
react.js application and if you scroll
down you can see the message returned
from node.js into react saying the api
is working properly so the practical
impact of this is to actually host
restful services etc on node as a server
and you can go and consume the data that
is written there could be in string text
or json format directly into the
react.js acting as a client application
today we're going to cover react with
redux
so with our session today we're going to
go through it's going to cover why you'd
want to use redux when you're building a
react solution
what redux is what are the core
principles of redux and what are those
pillars that drive what you do in redux
and then finally what are the pros and
cons of redux and after we've gone
through the powerpoint presentation here
what we're going to do is we're actually
going to go through and actually do a
demo of actually using uh redux so you
can actually see how this would all look
so why would you use redux well the
reason why you want to use redux is that
redux actually understands and helps
manage the state of an object
and redux was introduced to help address
some problems that you're having with
react so the state for an object stores
values and properties that belong to
components that could potentially change
over time so
the state could be modified by actions
in your network uh they could be
changes to the re-render of the
component in the browser
the object could also then
potentially store multiple properties
and then with redux it actually takes in
and actually will create a
you know
take a a large application that you
could create with app with a react and
breaks it down to several components
instead of having this massive number of
states you have to manage and so every
time that you you know an application
would then switch from a current with a
react you'd actually be then changing
the states and this is a a really big
problem because when you're like doing
that switching back and forth there is
the potential for applications to be
re-rendered which reduces the efficiency
of your application and so this is why
redux was introduced
so you know what is redux so redux is a
way to be able to have a predictable
state container for your javascript
applications and allow you to run your
applications in multiple different
environments so whether it's a client
solution a service solution or a native
app solution and then more importantly
um or one of the key
elements that i like about redux is that
it's really easy to test and so with
redux you're able to manage the state of
your tool
you can actually use it to work with any
javascript framework or library and you
can actually then store the um the
application and the components in a
state store which makes it easy to be
able to manage the state of your
application so in simple words redux
stores all the state objects in a single
store and organizes it it provides
information about the current state of
the application
any changes in the state the application
can be described to the store by the
user and then it notifies any
modifications made to the state of that
application so let's jump into the key
principles of redux and there's three
key areas i want to focus in so the
first one is that redux provides a
single source of truth um and that
source of truth is being able to store
the state of your whole application in
an object tree in a single store and
this makes it easier for you to debug
and inspect uh components of your
application uh also enables you to be
able to persist your app stage for
development and improve fastest
development cycles the second principle
is its state is read only and that's why
you're able to
describe more effectively what's
happening because it is read only and
this ensures that no events like network
callbacks
would uh
create and any issues with the code and
the re-rendering of your application
and that object actions become then just
plain objects and then finally changes
are made with pure functions and so what
do we mean by this
so we can actually
take actions and transform the state
tree with pure reducers and we'll go
into a demo electron to show you this
but a reducer is essentially a function
that accepts an accumulation value and
then it takes back and returns that as a
new accumulation and this allows you to
have a single source of truth value the
user can return the new state objects
instead of mutating to a previous state
the user can
start with a single reducing as the app
grows it can then split off into a
smaller reducers
and then finally the reducers just
become functions so let's talk about the
pillars of redux
and so there are three key areas we have
the store the actions and then reducers
and then the store itself is the actual
main object that holds the application
tree
state
and there are four key
states there's get state which turns the
current c to the store and when we
actually run the demo later on you'll be
able to see that we'll be able to open
up our terminal window and be able to
get the state store from from our
terminal window
the second state is dispatch and this is
a an action it's the only way to update
the application state and here we have a
action on a button change to actually
change the state of the application and
then the final two are subscribe
unsubscribe
and these are our ways in which you can
actually change the listener to the
state so an action is a plain object
that represents an intention into the
state so with actions you have payloads
of information that send data back and
forth to your application store
so you can send any kind of data
that can go back and forth and that
actions must also have been a tight
field that indicates the type of action
that has been performed and finally with
reducers reducers are
specified how the application state
changes in response to actions sent to
the store and so actions only describe
what's happened but don't describe the
application state change
they are a reducer is a function that
accepts the current state and an action
and then returns a new state with the
action performed and then finally you
can use combined reducers utility which
can then combine reduces in an app into
a single a index
so let's look at the pros and cons of
using redux because nothing is perfect
so a pro for working with redux is that
redux provides a single source of truth
which is the store so there's no
confusion over where you're getting your
values
this then leads to having a predictable
and strict outcome redux is more
stringent about how the code is
organized this makes it easier to
onboard developers because there is a
very structured way of writing redux
code this makes it also then
easier for the initial render which
allows you to make uh your solution
really optimized as an experience
and then finally developers can track
everything that's going on inside the
app in real time the cons
so
one of the big cons is there's no
encapsulation so you're using redux to
test out the code and the writing of
your code um but the component cells can
access data and is potential for
security issues
you do have to use boilerplate code so
this kind of takes us back to the
structured code format it is um strict
in its setup and it is memory intensive
so with that let's go in and look at a
demo of using redux to
reformat a react application
so in this demo we're going to use react
to show how redux can work first thing
we want to do is go ahead and download
node.js we're going to go to nodejs.org
to get the latest download the downloads
are available in windows mac os and
linux you can also download and
recompile the source code if you want
i encourage you to go with the latest
lts version it's the latest stable
version now there are other versions you
can use but that's one you would want to
use i already have it installed so i
just want to show you how that looks so
i'm just going to go in and put
node dash version it's going to give me
the version number so that shows it's
installed and we'll also use npm which
is node package manager because we'll be
using that validate that it's installed
by doing node mpm
version okay so looking good and we're
gonna go ahead and create a folder um on
our desktop um normally you wouldn't put
a project folder on your desktop but you
know this is just for an experiment so
we're gonna call this one
redux react it's going to be taking a
react project and we're going to show
what it looks like as a standard project
and then what it will look like
as a project that's being
taken through redux
so let's just move our cursor to the
correct folder
and so we're going to go to cd redux
react
and there we are we're in at the correct
folder using our command prompt you use
terminal on mac os
so let's just type in mpx and that's for
our redax
and we're going to do create dash react
dash app so we're going to create a
default react app and then we'll also
install redux dash app
and these are the two
components that we need to be able to uh
build out our solution one is react and
it's react js
and the second is redux and we hit
return
and this is going to go ahead and
download the latest versions of both of
these applications and install them into
the folder that we just created on our
desktop
just give that a moment
and so it's installing the different
packages react react dom
react scripts
and there we are have everything
installed great
and these are just different commands
you can use
and it's recommending that we select npm
start
to get everything up and running so we
use visual studio code to do most of our
work here vs code
is open source solution for scripting
and it's available on all the platforms
now it is from microsoft but it is open
source
and uh there's just a ton of stuff here
but we're going to go ahead and open up
the folder we just created on our
desktop
and so here is redux react app
and we're going to select that folder
and on the left hand side you'll see all
the files from that folder which is
going to get rid of the welcome screen
we don't need that anymore
you'll see there's some commands we use
we do uh
control plus
uh i'm not sure what that's called again
anyway it gets us to the terminal window
um
not an exclamation point
so you'll see that in our project folder
we have all of the files we need for our
solution we have both the node modules
and then the public files the product
files is just the application itself so
here on the index.html you see the index
file there and we're going to actually
show what this looks like inside
as it's broadcast from a web browser in
a moment now uh we're going to create a
very simple application here
and the application is going to look
exactly the same in both um uh uh just
standard react and uh redux react it's
the optimization that's gonna be
improved so we just did npm dash and
start it's gonna take us to local host
call on 3000 give it a moment and then
we should get our
floating uh logo showing that the
application's up and running up there we
are
we can go ahead and head and edit app.js
to
create our application
okay so let's go in and we're gonna go
into app.js
and we are gonna create an application
called
newcomp.js
and we actually have some code that
we've already created that you can
download as part of this application
so but we're just going to type in here
import react
and then component
from
[Music]
so i'm going to pull in our react
library
and we also import
connect
from
react
redux
and that's the
package that we're working in
let's
terminate the bat shop yes
and then rerun
npm
install
save
react
dash redux
and there we go takes a moment just to
install that
so our goal here is to show
how you can optimize your solution with
redux for the uh using the store and
reduces in redux
again
the the solution is going to look
exactly the same what's going to change
is the performance of the solution
and this is what redux gives you all
right so we're going to go ahead and
we're going to go in and type in class
new comp
extends component
and then we're just going to select our
constructor
props
and then we want to add in there
super props
and then this
state
equals
i have a message here
subscribe
to simply learn
very simple little app
don't forget to save your work as you go
along
and we're just going to apply some
styles
let's just make the
apply some font style
like italics
then we're gonna
make the color
purple
and let's have a button that we're going
to press a
button change
equals
this set state
oh sorry get state
and we'll have a message that comes up
basically saying thank you for
subscribing
there we go we have our button we'll
change the state here in a moment
and very simple
little application
and we want to rent that
on the screen
i just have some basic
html for where we're going to place
everything we use div tag
for our app
again we're going to keep this really
simple
and we're gonna call
reference this styles for
this h3 tag
so our message is going to be subscribe
to simply learn
this will be created dynamically we use
our style i'm going to add in a button
one click
action
subscribe
and nope change too many s's
save that
all right save now let's run
the script
you guys have js
and we're going to actually import that
into
our app.js script
good
rid of this
and then
and we'll extend
the newscorp js
component into here
all right
font style here
and
i'll render this correctly
and i'll pull in the text
and styles
again it's pretty simple little
application
now playing from use code
so we'll actually have
a welcome screen a welcome line and then
pulling the two lines of code
all right let's
run that
npm start
and here we go
refreshes our page
so what we've just created is a basic
standard state object
and oop
let's see now oh yeah this is good now
we actually can show you that we didn't
actually write all our code correctly so
let's go back and fix that
it's newport and use
newscomp.js and we have to make sure
that we
have a correct export feature here so
that the image that the
everything can be exported effectively
and import we also need to have an
export
all right let's run that again
okay should take care of our
uh problem hey there we are so welcome
and then we have the standard state
object of subscriber simply line and hit
subscribe and we change the text too
thank you for subscribing
okay so let's kind of go in and modify
this now so it goes from being a
standard state object to one that uses
store and reduces
so we're going to go ahead and terminate
our batch job
and essentially reset everything
and what we're going to do now is
install redux
this is what's going to help us
it takes a moment to install
redux all right so we have redux
installed
that's good
and now we want to
start
our package
and it looks the same but now we're
going to make some changes
so let's go to
our index file
index.js
and here's our react dom
now we're going to add in
contour
so this is going to be our react this is
going to be our redux store so we're
going to create a new store
and it's going to be a reducer
and
we're going to
put
in strict mode
okay juice is not defined let's go ahead
and define that
so
we're going to come over to our new comp
js file
and what we want to do here is we're
going
to
take out the one class file that we just
created
and
just kind of stripping it down here
now let's go in
and
let's map our state
to
props
equals state
and we're going to do return
message
is state dot message
and then
[Music]
construct map dispatcher props
and this is going to be our dispatch
and we're going to be in
return
and we have our button
change
for dispatch
and we'll type in what the message is
now we have message change
let's turn from the button okay
so we'll pass the value over
all right
and now we actually
connect
as of our export and in our connection
i'm going to do map state props
and map
dispatch props
all right now we're going to go in and
it's going to be for our new comp
now we want to switch over
and we're going to just change some of
our linking variables here
so serve to button change we're going to
do props dot button change
otherwise we won't be able to find in
our code
this is some pathing
and
[Music]
you go ahead and create a new folder and
this one is going to be our store
and again this is going to be our redux
store
we're going to call the store
reducer.js
and
const
initial state equals
this is what the default state will be
for when the page loads which will be
subscribed to simply then
and then
the reducer
we're going to place to where the
reducer is
and con's new state
and it's going to be
an if action
dot type
i'm going to change the message
it's unused comp
so that's the
action there we
pull that
so it's identical
and then new state dot message
equals
thank you for subscribing so
we have the default now we have the new
message
again this might seem like extra work
but actually makes your
whole application much more efficient
and export default
juicer
all right so make sure we saved all our
files which we have
and
now let's go ahead
so we have let's just inspect everything
it's all looking good
all right
now terminal window we're going to do
npm start let's see what happens
and our web browser should load up
oh we have an error
that's good so now we're learning stuff
so this is again this is all part of
your standard coding is just hunting
down errors in your code so let's go to
index.js
and
let's say
we're gonna pull in here
so we have reduce and it should actually
be
spelled correctly there we go
okay all right everything is now
as it should be
let's go back
recompile
let's
rerun uh
file
and we want to move our file let's just
go ahead and move the store
i'm going to update all the links to the
store
and we're going to be trying major
provider
store
is referenced correctly
okay let's rewrite our application
and
there we are
so let's go back through
our applications running much faster now
we're able to manage our changes and our
elements for our applications different
objects
we're able to change the messages after
you click
and able to then create the new message
again this is a very simple application
but you can see how for more complex
solutions how this become useful and you
start using the different components you
create
for your whole solution
and that's our demo
hi guys welcome to this video on react
native
if you wish to build mobile applications
and are confused as to which tool to use
then you're in the right place
this video on react native will explain
what react native is and guide you
through it
but wait before beginning if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already then
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
so here's what you'll be learning in
this session
first we'll understand what exactly
react native is
then we look at why react native is
being so widely used off lately
moving ahead we look at the differences
between react native applications and
platform-specific applications after
understanding why react native is used
we'll understand some of the
prerequisites for building applications
using react native
then we'll understand react native
fundamentals like view state props and
style
and lastly we'll end the session by
looking at some of the industry trends
of react native
so let's begin
what exactly is react native
now react native is a framework that
combines the best parts of native
development with react to build user
interfaces
these applications that are developed
using react native are downloadable on
google play store and apple store plus
because most of the code you write can
be shared between platforms react native
offers a wide collection of ui kits and
makes it easy to simultaneously develop
for both android and ios devices
but you must be wondering why is react
native used
so let's look at some of the reasons why
react native is used
first up is cross platform
cross platform means that the
applications can easily be run on
microsoft windows linux and mac os
so you can build your code base once and
then run it on any platform as opposed
to software built natively for a
specific platform next up is performance
now the react native apps are compiled
into natively written code which enables
it to not only work on both the
operating systems but also functions the
same way on both the platforms with no
lags at all
moving ahead there's quicker development
now react native offers excellent
developer experience it provides strong
developer and debugging tools with
meaningful error messages so working
with this tool becomes very easy
a large developer community now there
are several github repositories on react
native and groups on facebook
stack overflow is an excellent website
with several developers interacting
about issues on a regular basis
next up is wider audience
now since react native applications run
on both ios and android devices there's
a huge user base
and lastly react native has a great
career scope
considering the pace at which the
framework took over the market and its
simple approach to resolving development
problems the future of react native
looks more promising than ever
so these were some of the reasons why
react native is being widely adopted
so now let's go ahead and look at some
of the differences between react native
applications and platform specific
applications
as discussed earlier react applications
work on multiple platforms while in the
case of platform-specific applications
as the name suggests these applications
are built for the specific platform only
developers have a stronger web
development background while in the case
of platform specific apps they have a
very strong platform's language
background
in this case when you consider ios
developers have a very strong hold of
swift which is a programming language
used to develop ios applications and
talking about android developers have a
very strong hold on java
when it comes to react native it has a
faster build time and is less suitable
for complex applications
comparatively platform specific
applications have a slower build time
and are suitable for complex
applications
react native is best for small
development teams with limited resources
while in the case of platform-specific
applications it is best used by
experienced developers who have adequate
experience in building mobile apps
so now that you know what exactly is the
difference between react native and
platform specific applications
let's look at some of the prerequisites
for building apps using react native
first up you should have a strong hold
in programming concepts like functions
objects arrays and to lesser extent
classes
now understanding javascript and all the
javascript libraries and frameworks is
crucial
and lastly you need to be familiar with
html and css concepts so as long as you
have a strong hold of these then react
native development becomes very easy
so now that you know what react native
is you've understood why it's being used
some of the prerequisites for react
native
let's look at the basic concepts like
view state props and styling in react
native
let's begin with view now view is the
most fundamental component of building a
ui
it is a container that supports layout
with flexbox style some touch handling
and accessibility controls
now view maps directly to the native
view
equivalent on whatever platform react
native is running on so here you can see
there's a simple code snippet and the
output for it so as you can see there's
a hello world message in a render method
and the same is being rendered and the
view component here is being imported
from react native
now view as mentioned earlier acts as a
container with support for flexbox
layout and other styles
so flexbox is designed to provide a
consistent layout on different screen
sizes
moving on to state now there are two
types of data that control a component
one is props and the other one is state
now props are generally set by the
parent and are fixed throughout the
lifetime of a component
but for data that is going to change we
make use of state
so here you can see you have made use of
the this dot stay dot my state in my
render method you can also use the set
state method when you want to change it
moving on let's look at props
most components can be customized when
they are created with different
parameters these created parameters are
called props short for properties
now props are passed from one container
to another as a way of passing data
between them
so here using the name as a prop
lets us customize the message in the
component so we can reuse our component
for each of our tv shows here
so this is how we can use props in our
component
lastly talking about style react native
uses the conventional javascript
styling for components so the style
names and values are similar to how css
works
now to style we either use inline style
or style sheet
so you can see here we've provided
inline styling with a background color
a color and a font size and accordingly
the output is displayed
moving ahead to our last and final
section
let's look at the industry trends today
talking about salaries the average
salary of a react native developer in
india is around 6 lakh indian rupees per
annum
and the salary of a react native
developer in the us is around 96 000 us
dollars per annum
now as you can see react native has a
higher growth trajectory compared to
other frameworks
as a result is being readily deployed by
many companies
applications like facebook instagram
netflix pinterest uber uber eats among
others are developed using react native
welcome to this session on react native
versus flutter in this session we would
look at identifying some of the
differences between the react native and
flutter frameworks let's start with
understanding the core areas of
comparison as part of this session we
will be looking at key aspects to
identify differences between both the
frameworks predominantly on the language
front the ui aspect the performance the
documentation the popularity the
community support that is available for
both these frameworks along with the
industry trends
in terms of the industry adoption for
both these platforms the core objective
of the session would be
that at the end you should be able to
decide and make an informed decision as
to which framework is the best among
those available let's start from a
language perspective now if you look at
react react is basically completely
written and built in javascript using
the react.js api on the other hand if
you look at flutter it is basically
written in a very new language called as
start and we do not have too many
developers that are skilled on dart
however uh every browser and every
platform being shipped with
an inbuilt javascript execution
environment that makes javascript
platform the language of choice for
developers so every browser today or
every browser manufacturer would have
inbuilt support for executing javascript
programs similarly most popular
platforms mobility platforms like
android and ios have default support for
executing javascript programs and that's
the reason when you compare this with
flutter flutter uses start which is
predominantly a newer language and we
really do not have too many developers
who are skilled on this so that really
is the selling point
and the usp of react native because when
you work with react native uh you really
do not have to relearn a lot you don't
have a sharp learning curve most of the
javascript developers who are working
with memes tag already working with html
css and dhtml can easily align to this
that as we have discussed
is pretty new in the industry and would
not have that much of penetration in the
developer community from a ui
perspective uh when you talk about react
native it's based pretty much on native
components for the android and the ios
platform and flutter on the other hand
uses a very proprietary
set of widgets and it has its own page
structure that needs to be set up so
it's a closed ecosystem as compared to
an open ecosystem in react native which
allows you to go and implement
third-party widgets and ui frameworks as
well now this is really what allows you
to pick and choose with react native
because you can go and decide whether
you want to use kendo ui or a set of
generic controls or any other
third-party ui framework can be
implemented but for flutter you have a
pretty closed ecosystem and that's the
reason the ui components that are
available out of the box and built into
the platform are all that you can use
from a performance perspective when you
talk about react native it basically
is built and uses javascript out of the
box and that's the reason when you want
to write any code in javascript that
connects and tries to access
native services on that specific
platform it uses a bridge to do that but
when you're using flutter on the other
hand flutter does not need any kind of
bridge so there's no concept of you
write flutter code and then it uses a
bridge to go and connect to the native
set of components to interact with and
this is what really impacts the speed
and the performance aspect of developing
and executing applications between both
these frameworks because if you look at
react the speed of development is a
little bit slower when you compare that
with flutter and that's because it has
an intermediate bridge that it has to
communicate with and every layer of
additional communication and computation
that you put in between two tiers in a
application that you built obviously
would have a performance impact from a
documentation perspective if we were to
compare flutter typically has a very
well defined uh documentation repository
and it allows developers to go through
it in a very simple manner so it's all
structured it's all organized unlike
what you see on react native because in
react native it actually since react
native is an open ecosystem and allows
you to implement third-party widgets and
you can do a lot of configuration and
plug-and-play and that's the reason uh
the documentation also is not very
strong well organized and impactful and
that's the reason uh most developers
would find it a little challenging to go
through the react native documentation
when you compare that to the
documentation available in terms of
flutter popularity is always a key when
working with platforms and that should
be a crucial decision maker because when
it comes to open source technologies and
you're stuck somewhere you obviously go
to the community to the community to go
and find out how best you can solution
the problem now flutter being relatively
a new entrant into the market it does
not have a lot of developer penetration
and that's the reason the popularity in
the community is not very strong react
natively there for a while now it's been
around for some time and that's the
reason uh it's pretty popular among
developers also since uh it uses
javascript it's a natural transition and
a progression path for those who are
working with html5 css and building web
applications or have been building
hybrid mobile apps find it very easy to
migrate to this because flutter requires
you to learn a new programming language
which is start and that is one more
reason why the popularity of this is
much much better on the react native
front as compared to flutter again if
you look at the google trends uh you
could actually look at both of the lines
here the red line indicating flutter it
started on a very positive note and then
there was a plateau and then suddenly a
spike react native has been much more
steady in terms of its growth and
ultimately if you look at it now both of
them seem to be trending at par with
each other so the community support as
we were speaking about if you look at
stack overflow which is one of the most
popular websites to go for any kind of
developer
trends and movements and for a q a that
most developers would have you can
actually look at the number of questions
here and
also
react native is part of
github as its open source it was
released in 2015 and uh it's because of
the huge community support that it
becomes
easier to implement this you have a lot
of confidence as a developer when you
start building on this stack because if
you're stuck somewhere you will have a
lot of help available on the way on the
other hand if you compare that with
flutter you can look at the question
count here on stack overflow and this
being a new entrant in the market
it has a smaller footprint on the
community aspect but of course that
keeps increasing every day again from a
react native perspective and you talk
about stability in terms of stable
releases
there again you would see that react
native does a much better job as
compared to flutter so the industry
tents are something which all of us have
to be aware of specifically if
we would need to make a decision in
terms of our careers the technology that
we are learning what is the growth
aspect what is the industry adoption and
how we could really move ahead on our
career graphs in terms of the
opportunities market the job market etc
so again getting back to stack overflow
which is the benchmark for understanding
technology trends in ide sphere and
software development if you look at a
recent survey conducted in 2019
62.5 percent of developers uh seem to
have shown interest in react native as
compared to a marginal rise of 65.4
percent where flutter seems to be doing
much better and of course that could be
due to the uh time frames that uh both
these technologies uh have been around
react has been around for quite a while
and hence the job prospects are much
better a lot of organizations
implementing this clutter has been a new
entrant and hence uh
slightly fewer opportunities as the
penetration still needs to happen in the
opportunities job market and uh from a
developer skills perspective so these
are some of the big names that are using
react native in their implementations
right from facebook to pinterest to wix
skype tesla insta bloomberg
you can actually look at
the implementation across industry which
is absolutely crucial when you're
learning something new because when you
want to join a large logo obviously if
there are a lot of logos using this that
enhances the credibility of your
learning puts a justification to why you
would want to learn this technology
flatter on the other hand associated
with big names like google sonos alibaba
the largest retailer out there from a
conclusion perspective if we were to
conclude on what we've discussed from a
language perspective obviously we said
react is much more popular since it is a
natural progression for developers to
work on javascript and move to this as
compared to dart which is relatively a
new language from a ui perspective the
open source plug-and-play capability of
configuring and adopting seamlessly to
newer platforms of widgets and
third-party ui platforms are much better
as compared to flutter which is a closed
ecosystem and depends on inbuilt widgets
to implement the performance aspect we
discussed because of the bridge from the
code that you write to the native
component access exists in react and is
isolated and not locked any longer
required in flutter and hence the
performance is impacted because of the
additional layer in between the
documentation much much better in
flutter because it's a closed ecosystem
and they can control what you can use
react native being open-ended it really
has a lot of third-party integration you
can do and hence the documentation is
not really well organized the popularity
perspective react native much more
popular among html5 css three mer mean
stack developers since it's all
javascript flutter needs you to learn
new skills and you need to spend
additional time for that from a
community support react native has been
there for a longer time as compared to
flutter and hence has a stronger
community support as compared to flutter
and that translates into better job
prospects in the industry for react
native as compared to flutter so if we
were to give it a score react scores
much better with a total score of 5
leaving flutter with a total score of 2.
so i hope we were able to understand the
differences between the react native and
flutter and this will help you make
better decisions with planning your
career and deciding which technology you
should latch on to
so our demo is going to be about
creating a calculator using react and
node.js and so we have here just a basic
calculator nothing crazy um but the
whole thing is going to be created with
react and so we'll be using javascript
to be installing react and installing
the various components such as node.js
and the different npm solutions that we
need so as you can see my calculator
works just fine and now let's go ahead
and
let's go and install the different tools
that we need so the first one is going
to be node.js
and we do google search on node.js we
always start with google searches
because it's the easiest way to find
things and so we go to the default
node.js site and you can go to downloads
and there are windows mac os and also
linux installers you can also download
the original source code and compile it
yourself if you want and you'll also
need a text editor i'm going to be using
visual studio code it's just my favorite
text editor it's free works across all
platforms
uh it comes with a ton of extensions so
you can get up and running really
quickly with it um so we're just going
to go ahead and install the windows
version i already have installed so you
have to download it again you also want
to make sure that you have the latest
version of nodejs installed now with
that node package manager so we're just
going to open up our terminal window and
validate which version that we have
running
and we can do that fairly easily we can
just put in node
version and it'll tell us which version
and which means that's installed and
same thing with npm
node package manager we'll do npm
version and that will give us back the
version number again you have to have
them installed for them to be able to uh
do that and we're gonna also now create
a react app so we're gonna do
install and then it's gonna be create
dash react dash app that's the command
to create a new react app
and we're going to install it right off
our desktop
so let's go in and we'll put mpx
create dash react dash app
and then the app is going to be called
calculator which will install a folder
on our desktop with all the appropriate
react code
and this will be just a template
application but it'll have everything
there that we need to get started with
hit return and
that will take a few minutes just to
install everything
here we go
and so as we go through some of the
components that we're going to be
creating today we're going to be
creating an app component and they'll be
the main component that has all the
information that will then be disabled
on the screen then we have a layout
component and that will be the actual
look and feel of the calculator and the
output component which will be the
results from the calculator and then the
output row and this will be all the
different tools that we will need and
here we have
our new folder right there
uh on our desktop um but we're actually
gonna go now into visual studio and if
you've seen any of the other uh node.js
videos that we've created you know that
i like to work with the node.js in
visual studio code because i can run
terminal window right there so i'm going
to open up the folder that we just
created that's
called calculator and we open up the
whole folder and not a file but the
whole folder and here's our folder on
the left hand side
we have all the different files there's
our json package that has the
instructions for what the calculator
looks like
including which version of react and the
dom and here's our default
uh element
as you can see because we're using our
react it's going to
embed the code into a html page and so
we have a div with the id of root that's
going to reference um some
class files that we create and so the
app.js file
has the application code that we're
going to be modifying in a little bit
and you'll see that it actually then
references up to
our
index.js file
and if in index.js file it has the id
element root which ties back to
the id element of root in our html file
so we're constantly referencing and
cross referencing our application
and this is where we're going to be
doing most of our work
right so we're going to go ahead and
open up the terminal window
and the first thing we want to do is
start
npm
and
it's now going to have everything
running on let's have localhost and
everything running on port 3001
we'll give that a moment and this will
actually then bring up just the standard
default react boilerplate app
it's just taking a moment to load
should probably get a faster computer
okay there we are
just not patient so here we have our
basic boilerplate react js application
nothing to create crazy here
so let's actually go in and start
working in some of our code so
see now yep everything is running where
we expect it to run
all right so let's go into fjs
and
we can actually go ahead and if you want
to type control plus c and actually stop
the ad boy
in the terminal window you can actually
stop it
now you can also go up into the terminal
command to stop it as well
and if we do stop the app then we'll get
an error message there we go
site can't be reached
and you'd expect this
we go back in
and
we're going to just restart
our application
everything should now be working just
fine
we're going to refresh the page
and we'll see
our default react app
[Music]
there we are
looking good looking good
okay
so we're going to delete out what we
have there because we want to put in our
own content
and we're going to call this one class
app and we're going to go in and we're
going to be modifying that class here in
just a moment
we'll put in default layout
i'm going to create a new folder
this folder is going to be called
components this is going to be for our
calculator
and put a new file in there i'm going to
call this one layout.js
and this is where we're going to start
breaking down the structure of our
layout
and we're going to
select import
layout
and then we want to do the path to our
layout
components
layout you need so we have the dot
because we have to go up one folder
that's the command for that so dot up
one folder components folder layout
notice we don't have to type layout.js
it automatically knows
to add the js extension
constantly making sure that we're saving
let's go over to layout.js
and this is our layout
do this using css
then we're going to import
react
from
react
and then select import
and then we're going to link to layout
css it's going to be a css file that
we're going to create
so we're going to have to type that in
layout.css
and notice we had to write out
explicitly that it's a css file
and so
here we have
and then we're going to put in
[Music]
the constructions for the layout
what our props look like
and then we'll export default layout so
it can
show up correctly
okay so we'll go to our webpage now
yep that's good we're expecting to see
that so we need to
change some of our pathing here just
quite quickly
so
let's see now
[Music]
we're going to move a file so it can be
accessed appropriately
you run this
you know what i think we didn't we have
to update
uh yep i know we have to go back to
layout and
we have to start adding in
some values here
so that
the application knows to lay content out
so we just put in
a
hello world
there we are okay so that shows us
everything is pulling through correctly
so we want to get rid of hello because
we're going to replace that with our own
application
i'm going to change this
div so that actually starts
pulling in the application
put in the class name for calculator
and this will be a css reference
okay
so you
need to have some image files
and what we're doing here is we're
essentially building up the
different elements that will need to be
presented on the screen
and then we'll have a
css file that we'll use to create these
elements
and as you can imagine i've i've already
got this written so i'm cheating a
little bit because i know what i'm
putting here
but uh as bottom line is that
the calculator really is
a bunch of form elements
um such as buttons on the screen but we
use css to reformat them so it looks
more like a traditional calculator
um
that's one of the the things that you
get comfortable working with when you're
doing web applications is how to take
technologies that you're used to using
and then modifying them so that they
look different and so in this instance
we're used to using button elements
within an application so
why not use the the same bottom elements
which consistently work from browser to
browser
and then just simply
update the look and feel of them with
some css so that
they they look good
and here we are just doing a very simple
on click command
um this is some basic javascript
that will render inside of the browser
itself
okay so now we see boom there's a button
all right so and again you want to be
constantly testing and verifying that
the code you're writing is working
correctly
and we're going to do
another button
and this is going to be the delete
button
so we've got we're going to start
building out our different buttons here
so let's delete now we have an unclick
event for that
okay i'm just doing some formatting here
okay so we just used
going through our code here
making sure everything looks good
and one of the things we can now do
because we've got a base line
that looks correct we can just copy that
and then we want the percentage sign and
then the forward bracket so this
so it gives us our two buttons so we
have a
new row here
i'm just going to copy everything over
just make it a little bit easier
ourselves
and then we're just going to pipe in the
numbers
seven eight
nine
and then
plus single
sorry the multiply symbol
and we'll be able to move these into
multiple rows here in just a moment
and we just want to keep
going through making all the changes
here so we actually fill out all the
different elements
so as you can see most of this
isn't really complex it's
just
the uh we use the word fiddly yeah i
guess again the the fiddly parts of
putting this content together
so we refresh our screen start seeing
all the different elements
we'll have to come back and make some
updates
to
our css class names
and then we do our final three buttons
across the bottom
hmm
okay so let's now add some styles to the
content that we've created
we do then our layout.css file
um so we already have some styles that
we created so we're just going to go
ahead
and for the
for the sake of brevity we're just going
to pull those over
um
we can
if you want to um and have us do a more
detailed video on how to
create csc css files and
um you know we'll certainly do that but
i think most you probably know how to do
this already
all right so here's our css file and so
we have our calculator keys our buttons
and the different types of button here
so we can just copy these all over and
so these these will have the background
color the border color et cetera et
cetera
and so i'm going to do that
here we have our
buttons
for our app
easy way you know how
okay so we take out the css then we just
have basic buttons
we have the css link back in
we have
nice laid out application
so we've got a couple of areas that are
still missing we've got the results
screen and the
uh default logo
so
let's go ahead and add that information
in
and we'll create a new folder called
assets from the assets we'll put
another folder called font
and that'll be where our fonts will be
then we'll create another folder we'll
call this one images
and we'll put our images in there
so we have our logo image just simply
learn logo
and then for layout we can then
just reference that in our image
reference
so i'm going to import the logo
i'm going to import that from
our assets folder
and under assets we go to img which is
we have our image
and then we'll do the path for the
logo.png
so remove this
and then we'll do source
and we'll do the source is
from
our logo variable which is the as the
import of the image
we'll put the width
and we have to know it's 150 pixels and
the
there we go 750 pixels wide
and the style that we'll reference from
css
will be
block
so just some inline styling here
generally normally do this i normally
have all my styling in my css
folder
um but uh in this instance because we're
just putting up a solution i want you to
be able to see that you can actually do
this in line so there we are however
that logo
okay so now we need to have the
results screen make sure that looks
correct
okay
and so we're going to create a new
folder and this is going to be got our
output
js file and this is going to control the
output of that blue screen
i'm going to put our react objects
and we'll export that
and we will put a new file called
outputrow.js
so we'll put our
instructions uh this is going to be our
component the users will put their
results into
and
now put row
and we're gonna
put our instructions here so we're gonna
like export
default
output row
all right so we're going to start
putting together the code that allows us
to construct our solution
and we're going to update the output
row.js file
and
we're going to
add in our return value
so we'll put a div
and this will be
input type
so essentially we have a text field um
that will be read only on the top of our
calculator and here we see our text
field here and that will allow us to be
able to
put in our values
and we use the class screen that allows
you our formatting
i'm going to put a file it's going to be
output road or css we're going to add in
our specific css
for
this output row
and as you can see we're just using all
of our standard html5
skill sets here
and
let's go over to our
style will pull in our
props dot text size
and then the default
value
and so this is going to line with uh
go over to our css file and we'll update
that
output.js
make sure the results get returned
correctly
as we're tapping on the buttons
and so this will
play in our output row
and the value will be
we bring our text size for our output
flow here
[Music]
and we're just going to put some
sample css styling here
nothing too crazy
and we have two
rose
save that
our two rows will appear in a moment
let's go into our layout
let's add in our rows
so this is our output i'm going to
pull in those values
and there we have our two values
and so we can apply some css styling to
this
so the top row will be
the calculation broken out as we've
written it and the bottom row will be
the results
and it's going to our css file here
we're going to copy over some
css and you have
some
font styling
we have our screen class name
there's our screen here
again this is
nothing no rocket science here and we've
done any css
editing you'll be familiar with what
we've done here
and you see that we're referring to a
font asset we actually have the font in
there we have to
pull that font over and
it's just a ttf font true type font
now you can use and any of the
internet fonts as well google has a
massive library
of fonts
and there we are
i'm going to change the size of our
font so that the second row the text is
a little bit bigger
a little bit small and we don't have
anything wired up yet we'll do that in a
moment that'll be the
easy part of this assignment
all right so let's go over and
now layout
okay so net
input
set input
and use state
now we can default the initial state
and for the result
the you state
the initial usage will be just blank
there we are
just what you'd expect to see
so the results
um are blank and this is just when you
run the app for the very first time
okay so going through
and now we want to put in our actions so
we can have an event
when we click on any of the buttons
want to take the value of the button
and
so this
you're going to be
any of these actions here
and
we're just going to put together a
script to do the calculations
so as you can see so far
we've put most of this application most
of the hard work has been setting up the
base react application
putting together the
different files and folder structure
making sure we have the correct assets
such as images
fonts
css files
laying out our core structure in html
form elements
and now
the part that we're doing at the end
here
is putting together the script
that will actually write
that actually do our calculator
uh events and and honestly and this is
going to be um
i've got this running here it's just
javascript so there are lots of
javascript calculators on the internet
so you can actually take any of those
and use those as a base
for what we're doing here
there we have it if there's an error
we'll do math error result we didn't
expect to see that
and we'll just keep putting together our
code
[Music]
here there are different results
so depending on
um
which commands you use so for instance
it's the equal sign and
have the results
so we're using the value to actually
then trigger
what we would actually be
seeing in which screen
okay that's looking good
so we'll capture our value and
this is all concatenate together
and
[Music]
if there are any error
messages so if the value is
c from the button so if we select c
so we want to set the input to zero
which is to reset
the screen
and
if the value
equals
and this will be delete
what we want to do is we want to
manipulate the string on the screen
which means we're going to
[Music]
eliminate
the last character entered
and this is
manipulation here
and this is all reducing the length of
the string
by one character at a time
again this is your standard javascript
control
so hit delete
and that gets rid of a character another
character
hit it again i'll get rid of the third
character
and
put if the string is
zero then put
five as the value
all right
this allows us to test out our
application
all looking good so far
okay
i want to make sure that we're then
calculating our values correctly
and here we have
the
display and the input
it's all coming from here our output
class
and then we'll put in our results
okay it looks like we're letting lining
everything up just always want to go
back and double check that you have all
your commands or your variables lining
up
correctly
eliminate those
now we'll make sure we have the answer
and the user
into there
and we have the answer in the user and
we'll change the font size
let me say that
we'll go over this is now this is our
local application
and we test it we can start putting
together our construct
and we'll see that our calculator is
working so clear gets rid of both values
everything's looking pretty good
and here we have our first application
and this is the sample application
this is the application we just wrote
here is the original application that we
were testing against
and as you can see everything lines up
correctly
and so you've seen how in just 45
minutes you can actually
write out your own
uh
react js application with nodejs
and so we terminate the application
so this is the one we just built
it's going to fail so that
allows us to validate that we actually
created we will restart the services
say
yes
i'm running on another porch because we
already have an app running on
another port so it's going to run on
3001
refreshing the web page
and voila there we are there's our
application up and running
everything looks really good
working fine
it works absolutely identically
now if you want to you could actually
then take this application and
um make it a native application as well
right now we're just using it as a web
application
and we're just updating some of the css
making it a little bit tighter
everything looking exactly the same
there you go that's your app
all up and running
hello everybody and welcome you all
so
we're gonna talk about something very
interesting topic of the day
and that is called hooks in react
see friends actually what happens
when we work on react-based development
so in react 16.8
we have introduced a new feature called
react hooks
these hooks have
really changed the way how the react
development really happens
because prior to these react hooks
we were writing so much of code because
of that it actually increased the
complexity to our program
but ever since the react hooks came into
this picture the development time has
slows down
okay and we have actually increased the
productivity of our development
now how the react hook really changes
the way this we're gonna see it now in
those slides
now what are the react hooks see the
react hook is a special feature that
lets you
hook
intro
now what is this
see they say fuse important thing they
say normally hook allows you to reuse a
stateful logic without changing your
component hierarchy
your application can actually divide it
into the smaller pieces which later on
can be used together
okay so hopes that you use most of the
react features without using classes see
actually what happens
in react we have a two type of ways how
you write your components number one is
called class based component and second
which is called functional component
now
class based components are little more
heavy lifting because it comes
pre-loaded with state management as well
as the life cycle management
but not always you need these two
so you need to keep your components
light weighted so if you want to keep
your components light weighted so you
need to basically approach towards the
state
less or functional component so by
adding those hooks features so you can
have this normal functional components
on the top of that you will be having
some add-on feature that's the beauty of
react hooks
now the rules of react hooks
so there are few rules of the react
hooks which you need to understand
and what those are
number one they say
only call hooks
at the top level
don't look hooks inside loops conditions
or nested function so there are certain
conditions
they say
only hook only call hooks from the react
function component don't call hooks from
the regular javascript function instead
you can call hook from the react
function component or call hooks from
the custom box so there are multiple
options are available which you can
expose or use in your regular
react-based applications
okay
so after that we will see the demo how
the three different type of hooks are
used state hooks event hooks and create
customized hook and we will see some
demo on the top of that
hello everybody so once again we are
going to start working with another type
of hook see
in our previous examples we have seen
how you can have the state related hook
now my next event will be all about how
you can have
the
event based host we're talking about
something called use effects so how the
usefx really works let's take a look now
so here
in a similar example if i just give the
name call
[Music]
okay let's try to make it here only so
what i'm trying to do now is in my
current application
i'm already having this count and set
count to me but
i can also provide some default values
that anyways has been provided so rather
than hard coding it i can provide it
from somewhere else so how we can so
let's use one property called props here
and here rather than providing this i'm
saying
props
account so my question is like what do
you mean by count here
see count is nothing but a property
which initial value i don't know so
which you can set it from outside
so what you can do is here
before you export it you can say give
the name call
hook stand dot
default props
default
props
okay equal to i'm starting with the
curly braces and after this curly braces
here saying
count
okay that value is what
zero
what initial value we are giving count
initial value equal to what zero now
and of course this
this value whichever we are giving it so
what we also do in the same line is
here we would like to also perform the
another actions for setting the state
initial value is called count
and
this way
i can say set count count plus one
okay that is anyways fine
so increment let me copy this
so here let me say npm space start
so i must see some values have been
presented okay you can see still
initial value was zero
that's why if you see initial value was
zero so now because of getting the
initial value called props dot count and
now i can say increment
and i want to talk about decrement so
decrement and here we say reset
so
here
we can say minus 1 and this value rather
than saying count plus 1
okay
you can say
props dot count means whatever the
initial value would be that value will
be initialized here
so now the code will work just the way
it is now you can say increment
decrement reset
so it's working fine
so in our react hopes is of an option
which is available called
life cycle hooks
life cycle hooks are very very important
that means you're trying to say whenever
you would like to call anything
related to your life cycle like when
your component starts you would like to
learn something when the component
you know update you want to launch
something so these kind of activities
you can certainly make it so are you
gonna be making it now let's take a look
now so initially what i'm doing is
i'm just creating a new function called
use
because it is a predefined
okay available from
okay react 16
so here onwards you can see it is coming
from the same property
from react and under this use effect
what i will do is i will just say
log and i'm saying
called
every time
now if i just launch my application and
see the inspect
you can see it is saying called every
time even if i say increment it is
getting called even decremented is
getting called and reset it will get
called
because this is a life cycle method and
the life cycle method means it will get
called
normally in the react we have a call
component did mount and component did
update so it is a copy of both
okay
however you can
is stick this particular use effect to
the specific need only like if you do
not want this to be get called
on updates only when the component
launches so what you can do here in its
comma parameter you can make it as a
square bracket
this square bracket will contain those
values which you would like to watch for
those changes
so if you do not keep it anything by
default it will be what blank so now if
i just go ahead and start it is saying
called every time and now you can say
it is not getting called at all because
now
it is knowing that hey it is a blank
value so i'm not seeing any value so it
needs to be get called only when it is
launching not every time
however you also can offer the condition
where you want to call this use effect
only when the changes happens not
every time when it is loading
so what you can do you can just call
this
again
and paste it again this use effect and
say called
on
update and here you can provide the
value which you would like to listen so
actually if i see
the state is getting changed for this
count so i can say
count and now once it is ready
i can start my application
and you can say here
increment now you can see it is getting
called
okay but it is not getting called on
loading every time
so you are specifically telling like
this use effect should get called only
when
state changes to the count and this you
are not listening to anything so you are
making it as apply
i hope you are clear about what use
effect is all about
okay everyone so the previous example we
have seen like how
this books with regards to your uh
current application works like as i'm
saying we're talking about like in
this
state hook where we have seen use effect
we have also seen
another feature that is called use state
and now we're going to be talking about
our next okay everyone so now
we're continuing to our next feature
here and that is known as called use
context
see when we talk about react use context
we always have a very special feature
coming up with us where the reusability
comes as in priority
okay so if you really want to use a
reusability
okay you always think about an option
called use context now first of all i
would like to show you the problem and
then we discuss about the solution so
now here
i'm gonna say
uh use
context.js and in this use context.js
what i'll be doing it i'll be creating
some few functions here i'm saying
function
name
okay
so in this manner i can create const
i can say
user
set user equal to
use
state and initialize the value which
call what
admin that is the initial value we are
saying like in main app user set user
use state admin
and now after this
i am using return
and in this return
with my div tag i would like to offer
the message
okay so we are giving the name called
h2 and within this h2 we are
using this a value called
welcome and with this dollar sign
we can give the value like a user
whichever the initial value will be that
will be represented here
so that's what my first component
likewise
if i want to share the data
to the other components
how i basically try to use
that's an important thing i would like
to consider it now
so this is my first component
like i also want to create another
component which is accepting the data
and utilizing its own way
okay so like this
i can copy
and say
user 2
with this function i'm creating this
user tool
in this user tool
i will not be defining any state as of
now because it is there already defined
okay so in this it will be expecting
here it will be expecting
user as in parameter okay so return
you can define it anything i can say
paragraph
in this i can say
[Music]
user2
component
okay and i'm saying
component 2 and now i would like to pass
this value further to the another
component now
so what i'm trying to say now here
if i say user
2 let me copy this the whole bunch
and paste it below here and i'm saying
user3
which is also taking this data
and here
i'm defining this value called
user3
okay space
user
equal to
user
like this
we are providing it
okay
so that's where
i'm trying to use this
functionality
so we are having this function user two
okay so after this
we are taking function three and adding
the data right over there
okay so this dev tag whichever you're
taking it
so we have a called main app we can say
user2 and followed by user3 so the data
we can keep on passing from one copper
into another component
so we have got this component with me
user 2 and same time we have called user
3 now
ok and this user 2 whichever is
available to me
ok when we are saying hello user
this user 2 i can provide this data
right over here
ok so in my main application i can say
user
2
okay
and with this we can provide the value
called
user equal to
once again user
like this so you can see here
we are passing the data
down the line to all my components
whichever we are
utilizing it
okay
so that's fine
so
after this what we'll be doing because
we are passing the data just like that
but the only thing is what if this main
app
wants to pass the data directly to the
user 3 it cannot pass
okay it can pass the data to the user 3
only from its immediate child which is
the user too
and that's what the problem i would like
to sort it out but here
let me say
export
default
the name is called main app
okay let's make initial capital that is
always good
okay export default main app
and let's add this main app right inside
your
app.js
okay now let's see
see the value is coming up welcome admin
welcome admin will remind me
so that's pretty fine uh components are
basically rendered but there is no
reusability if you see like it is a
plain old technique
you pass the data to the child and you
cannot pass the chat to the grandchild
these are the certain challenges
okay so let's try to sort it out this
issue
okay everybody so it's time to basically
talk about the solution we have already
seen our problem
there's no reusability there's no
sharing of the data
and the sharing of the data is happening
from parent to child
only when you are a direct parent
otherwise not
so how are you going to be fixing this
issue
so fix this what i'll be doing is we
just want to say
const
app context equal to
create
context
okay so we're gonna say equal to what a
create context
so as usual the states are there
return
now in this return what i will be doing
it i will be using this
context so anyways i'm having this dev
tag
so i'll be using this option i can
use a context
or the context which you have created
that is called app content so we are
saying what
app context here
okay dot
you see there's an option available
called provider this is the one which
should be helping you to share the data
to the all the components value equal to
user
okay and this app context
i would like to cut it
okay and paste it after here
okay and here
user to use it whatever it is the value
is there so you are passing it to
user two
okay and later on you can pass to any
components those who want to really use
it
okay so whosoever wants to access your
context it can be easily available
okay so you really don't need to pass
this data again and again so if you are
in second component
okay so your anyways wrap this second
component right over here
so here in your second component
you really don't need this any data like
this
and you really don't need this
like that so you can easily pass this
into the user three also
okay so it's very simple and
straightforward
so
let me try to remove this value from
here also
and you can get the data the way you
always want
okay
so
you're saying value equal to what
user here
so after that you are saying
user equal to what user whichever value
you are basically passing it
okay and say use context.provider
okay and the second component
when you say user 2
you just say
you really don't need this in fact i
would say
you can even remove it
okay and the same you can remove it from
here also
okay and when i see my component swag
see
still working like the weight is
expected
okay so that becomes the idea of what
your
use context
okay which is designed for sharing the
data between and among the components
okay everyone so now it's time to
basically discuss about our another very
important topic that is called user f
okay user f is basically what the use
ref you can say it is the kind of hook
which allows you to persist value
between the renders
again i'm telling you users allows
actually to persist the value between
renders
normally you can store
or you can use to store a mutable values
which are changeable
okay that does not cause
a rerender when updated
okay
that means
you can persist that value in a storage
okay as a mutable value which does not
cause
a re-render when the updates actually
happens so normally it can be used to
access your dom element directly
clear so how it can be let's take a look
with using one simple example so you all
can understand how we can utilize this
okay so i'm gonna create another one
here
name call use ref dot
cheers
inside this use rest.js so let's get
started with this implementations the
one which we're looking at right now
so called users so once again i'm
creating
a function
app
and inside this i would like to say
const
input
vl
comma
set
input val
equal to
user state
okay
we want to use it now we want to use one
more const
value
okay equal to now we would like to say
use
ref you can see it is coming once again
from the where from the react here in
this user we can pass initial value plan
we do not have initial value so that we
are sending it as a what is a blank
now post that
we want to create
first important thing is we would like
to use the use effect first use
effect you have already seen the use
effect earlier because it is holding the
life cycle related
conditions so now here we are saying
prep value okay dot
current
equal to
input file
okay and after that which value you are
seeing
we get updated so we are passing
input value for sure
okay
post that once it is ready okay i'll be
saying return
okay inside this return
i'm having
div tag
and here in this div type we can say
input type
equal to
text
okay value
equal to which value would like to take
it so we are giving
input val
okay and we are also saying on change
equal to
taking this e is an event object here
and
we're calling
set
input val
with
e dot
target dot
value
okay
so we are holding the values
just like this
okay and after this once it is ready
i just want to use the
h3 tag
to show what is the current value so we
can say
updated value
okay here
i'm having this input value with me
and now i'll be using one more
h2 we're saying
last value of
using
priv
value
okay dot
current
so that's where you are basically using
so
this will be offering you what
the kind of value you are actually
expecting into your program
okay so use ref hooks can be used to
keep track of the previous state values
this is what we're doing it now
okay so this is because we are able to
persist use reference value between the
render so now let me try to say
export
default
and
i'm just giving the name of
app and this app i'm using it here in my
app.js
app
let me terminate it and
launch it again
[Music]
let's see
blue color 3000 again
so it is taking some more time but i'm
sure
we'll be able to see the outcome
soon interval system so now you can see
these values are coming up so now when i
pass the value call
one it is containing the one when i say
two you can see it is holding the
previous value when i said three it
containing the previous value when i say
four it holding the previous value
expecting it from all of you
so everyone we have already seen like
our previous example like how we can use
the use ref in our previous project now
it's time to talk about
our another interesting feature in hooks
continuation to this
and that we're talking about called
working with a use reducer
so what is the use reducer see use
reducer
is again a hook which is as same as like
in use state
okay it allows for
custom state logic
unlike the normal state how we maintain
using new state allows to
having some custom logic also see if you
are finding yourself where if you have a
call multiple portions of the state
that actually depends on the complex
logic use reducer would be very very
beneficial for you because it contain
the centralized logic
okay and can help the users to develop
some more fantastic applications so
let's see how we can really do this and
how we can utilize that so in hooks demo
i'm gonna create a new file here i'm
gonna give the name called
not app.js
and in this node app.js i would like to
have some initialize state i won't like
to make it available to the user
so
let's try to use one
very simple logic called
const
node reducer
node
reduces equal to here
i would like to take the parameter like
in state
and
action it is just like a normal
functionality we are writing it down
and inside this we would like to use a
switch
here we use a switch and we will judge
what type of action client is trying to
invoke action this is what kind of
condition client so client is ready to
invoke i'm saying action
dot
type
okay
and here we use the first option like in
case
first
condition i'm taking it is called
populate nodes
okay
populate
which
underscore
the existing nodes are available
populated
okay and here
after this
we would like to say return
[Applause]
dot
nodes
okay or else in a default case
or in a default case we are saying
return
the default state whichever is available
to me
so that's how the condition is now
going back
i would like to also check what are the
type of
states are available which i would like
to show it back to the client so we are
using this option like it
const
let's create a states first so we are
saying const
nodes
comma dispatch equal to use
reducer and inside this rule is user
first parameter we are passing is called
node reducer whichever we have taken as
an action here
and comma initial state which i'm making
it is a blank
i do not have any states of making it as
a blank again i'm using this option
again const
title
set title equal to
use
state with initial value blank
so that's how we are passing it now
okay now the next thing is like i would
like to
check in my code
how to basically display the list of
nodes back to my application
okay that's what the whole logic i want
to write
okay so let's check in case if i want to
return
the bulk of nodes how will i do this
so here
let's try to create the
nodes app so
this i would to make
it that was the reducer for us
now here we're gonna create const
node
app equal to
and i'm closing it here
okay so we are having these two
properties with me
and
we can have a number of actions also
but let's talk about return
in this return
we want to display the list of nodes
which are available to me
in case if i'm having it i will display
it so
i'm having the dip tag inside this tab
tag i can say
h2
notes
after this notes
notes
dot map in case if i'm having a array of
nodes map is a predefined function
for me so here we're using what
note
okay so
so inside this you would like to provide
the
object where the details will be
available to me
okay so
i can use
the div tag
where i can have the property with me so
i can use
the div
okay so i can use
key
equal to
you can just use
the default sheet which is available for
nodes
equal to what nodes
and provide
the other details too like if you want
to iterate it so you can just provide
data accordingly
okay so
that's what the whole idea is
and here
under this we would like to provide
note
okay
and
here if in case if i want to have some
data that can be displayed
okay so
now say
export
default
not app
and this is not up i'll be making it as
a child of app.js
okay
you can see i have got initial data
displaying here so in case if i have few
more records
suppose if i set data
okay so you can basically make
this data also available here so you can
see our god
list of records are available
okay so
that's make your development even more
easier
and that's the beauty of how the nodes
can be used for the further development
okay so i hope you're clear about
what in case if i want to use
you know this reducer so how we can
further utilize it to initialize
the data with this but later on if i
want to some add some actions
i can also add it
okay but this is what the initial state
which we are using it
in case if i want to display the data in
my code
hello everyone so in the previous
sections we have seen like uh
how we will be utilizing
our
you know use reducer applications now
i'm going to tell you about another
react very popular tool that is known as
called use memo which is once again a
very very popular
tool so what is the user memo it is
again another hook so
use memo hook returns some memorized
value what it was the previous value was
so we can
say think of
memorization as a caching value so that
it does not need to be recalculated it
already contain the value within that
so use memo only runs when
of its dependency update
okay so use memo
okay
is one of the very very popular tool but
it can be
you know little expensive resource
insensitive function
okay so it is
used memo can be used to keep expensive
and resource oriented function
to avoid needlessly running so we will
see how this uh used memo can work
so let's check this out and see
see
what my intention is in my application
is like
use memo is basically perform
some
actually memorized your complex
uh calculations so that it doesn't need
to run unnecessary every time
okay so it does a kind of caching
behavior for you to make your life even
more simple so let's see how it works so
accordingly you will also get the
implementations
okay so
you need to understand the use memo hook
except the second parameter
okay to declare dependencies so the
expensive function would only run when
this dependency has been changed
otherwise not
okay so let's see how we will be using
those so now here
i'm creating a new file and give the
name call
[Music]
memo.js
okay so inside your memory.js what you
do is just take a look let me try to
close rest of those
yeah so here you see
okay so we are saying
set count
equal to
user state initialize value with what
i would say zero
for a time being i am trying to use now
okay
and
after that if i want to perform some
calculations i can do that but let me
try to perform
this job only okay count and set count
according to my
rule
okay now
what i'm planning to do now is in a
similar line
i want to offer one more feature here
called const
const
equal to use state
i am making it as a what type area type
okay and i'm saying
const
calculation
equal to
expensive calculation
and here we are passing what
counters and parameter here
okay now let's perform some functions
i'm saying const
increment equal to
set count
see
plus one
okay and we are using
we're calling this set to dos here
okay and use
all the previous states whichever are
available and
new data this will get added so three
functions are basically calling
after that i am saying
return
in this return i'm having what
div tag
within this div tag i can use
another tip tag here and here we're
using
my
after this h2 we would like to use
toodles dot
map
slash what index
and here we saying return
paragraph
sorry key
equal to
add task
okay and
here here
sorry
equal to what index here
and here
to rules
[Music]
okay
could you make it
okay so this is how we have it now
after this we would like to create a one
button
inside this button i can say
add to do
and here
we will say on click and in on click
we'll be calling
at task
so this is what it is happening now
okay everybody
so here after this
div tag is getting closed
hr is getting closed
again we are opening up another tip tag
here
and here we are seeing
count
and here we are using
in this button we would like to
click on plus
increment what we're calling it here
increment here and
call something called
calculation
just like a normal message
and here
put what
calculation
okay so once it is done so your dip tag
is also close
both the tip tag is kind of getting
close
okay and they're also getting close and
now
we would like to perform one function
whichever i would like to use it for my
standard calculation
okay so let's see what we are trying to
do so here i am saying
problem calculation equal to
okay and we are using this
lock button inside this lock button i am
saying
calculating here and post this
this thing is called for
let
i equal to 0
is
less than
okay and we're using what
i
plus plus
and say
now
equal to one
okay
and after this
i can say return
now
and after that i'll be rendering this
function
by saying
export default memoir
that's it
okay
so this would be my application here
okay so now
here in this example
the expensive function which is called
long running function
okay
whatever i'm talking about
the long running function okay will only
run when the count is changed
and not when the to-dos are added
that's a whole picture about this code
here
okay so you can just see here
we are using this statement
and
here
we're gonna give the name of this
long-running calculations
to here
okay so i'm calling it there
now this memo app i'll be using it in my
app.js
okay so that is what we have it now so
i'm clearly saying like here
so
in this application
hook accept second parameter to declare
dependency this expo so the long running
functions will only run when the
dependency have changed otherwise not
that's the whole picture
so it is adding it saying calculating it
and then it is getting changed
okay so that's what the whole picture of
what we have done so i'm sure like you
all are clear
about how
this memo is really performing some job
the one which is actually expected
and once again we're going to start with
another feature of books as we have got
many hooks seen in our development
okay and uh
now on this top of this i'll be working
on our new concept that is what's called
use imperative handler it is again a new
concept as we have already seen multiple
different type of
hooks into our development now we'll be
talking about use imperative handler
now what is the use of
this particular hook look when we talk
about use imperative handler if i just
get you this
so if i say
use
now when we talk about use imperative
handler
okay so this use imperative handler and
the user is what we've already done
allows to pass a reference object
but the letter which is called
use reference
which you've already seen
this use reference
doesn't allow to customize the instance
that are
also passed with the ref object so use
imperative handler hooks is a different
from user friends
because it allows again it allows
handling and customizing the return
value
it allows handling
and customizing the return value
and it also allows to replace the native
instance of the ref object
now how it works let's try to understand
in our development
so
here we're gonna start working with a
very simple approach
into our code
okay
so we're gonna create a new one that is
called
[Music]
imperativedemo.js and after this we are
writing
function
converter
okay here we are passing two parameters
here one is called
props
and seconds call what
two parameters we are passing it now
here we are saying
const
use ref
okay
now
after this we we're using use
you can see we have called use
imperative handler comes from
this one so we are using this use
impellative handler and here we are
passing what refers in parameter
okay and
okay now in this case we are using one
type of functionality called blur
okay and here with this blur
and we are using
log
and writing
custom blur is called
after this once it is ready i would like
to say return
in this return
we are saying button
okay
and with this button
i want to use rift
okay equal to
btn and
props
we both are passing in here
in this using
click
okay that's it
and
once it is done then
we would like to
use this
okay into my application
wherever i can actually access this
in my application system
so once it is ready i would like to
make it
available so by using i'm saying export
default and i'm using something called
forward reference
you can see it is again a part of what
the react application we are using is
called forward reference
and here you're passing what
button so that is what my code is
now here
i will be making it as a child off but
[Music]
in my app.js so we already have this
earlier
memo app so here in my application
i'm just using const
btn equal to
use reference
i'll be using what use reference
so react and i'm using
okay so we're using this option called
use reference here and we're passing
null here and after this
this value whichever we are having we
just say cut
and passing it here
and this under this written keyword i'm
using
button
and in this button in our
options i can provide the events
so inside this button we would like to
one second
yeah
so inside this button using
one click
equal to
we're saying
btn okay dot
current dot
okay so we haven't imported
anything so let me import a button from
here
okay so we say
import
button
which class you created here imperative
demo
okay
so
so once it is there so
[Music]
so we're providing what btn.current.
blur
so closing this here and along with this
we are saying ref
equal to
btn
that's it
so this is where exactly the
options are so you understand in this
particular example we have developed a
custom button component that has a user
defined instance attached to the
reference object
attached to the what the reference
object now so we have developed the
button component that has a user defined
instance
attached to the reference object so
button component is the child component
of the app component
are we clear so when we click the button
here
the button is clicked
okay it called
user defined blur function which is
attached to the pass reference object
okay so that's the whole idea now
so i haven't tried anything another
button
that certainly i can add it
so under here
okay
so now
okay so
here
the things are working the way we were
expecting
okay so you see like what we did here is
now
we are now
using this approach
okay you see like we are using this
approach with using this
use empirical reference so we have a
call function button
we're passing two parameter props and
ref so we're getting this use reference
object
and uh use imperative we are passing
this ref
and this object here so we are using
this blur
as in kind of custom objects where
console.log custom
properties getting called a reference
button equal to
button and you're saying dot dot props
click here button and export default
forward reference button here
and followed by app.js
we are just using this
normal app component
const button equal to use reference null
return we are returning this button on
click
you see here equal to btn
okay it's just a reference what you're
using dot
current dot blur
and uh after that it's getting close
using f equal to what btn whichever
you're referring it and that's it so the
job is done
[Music]
so friends now after this the previous
example we have seen called imperative
now it's time to basically discuss about
another very interesting example that is
called use layout effect there is
another hook which is available to you
so this use layout effect actually works
similar
okay
to use use effect but rather working
asynchronously like what a use effect
does because use effect works
asynchronously
it fires synchronously after all
loading is done
again i'm repeating
the use layout effect works similar to
use effect but rather than
but rather working asynchronously like
how the use effect works okay what it
does is it basically it fires
synchronously after all norm
is done loading so this is pretty useful
for normally a synchronously
re-rendering the dom
okay so it is very useful for
synchronously re-rendering the dom and
also to read the layout
from the dom but to prevent
blocking the page loading we should
always use use effect otherwise it will
block
so the use
layout effect okay works in the same
phase as component mount and component
did update methods we should only use
use effect
layout effect if use effect is not
outputting the expected result
so let's take a look with a simple
example of the one which we are looking
forward for
okay so here in my code what we're doing
is
we're going to give the new file name
called use
dot js
okay so let me add
constant
layout
okay
and here we're using const
equal to
use state
and give any value whichever you would
like to give it okay let's say
welcome
and after that
you come down and say
use layout effect
okay and say if
value
equal to
welcome
i am saying
set value
welcome to react hooks
okay so that's an expectations and after
that we are using what
the log and inside this type is saying
use layout is working
okay with value so
using what the value here
okay
and
whenever the value changes
and listening to what the value here
and after this when we talk about return
so you have to return the values to
okay so we say
return
inside this tip we will say
value
that's it
and after this
left
in here
okay
so once it is ready you will see here
in your program
okay we need to check
[Music]
so
value okay
all right so here i need to use
to make it okay so now
i go to the inspect
go to the console
let's refresh
and now you can see
it is loading synchronously
okay
so your application is now loading the
way it is expected used out is working
well it is working to the react it's
perfect so that's where the idea of this
particular example so
in this example we have built a name
changer application that changes the
name of the state when the use layout
effect is called
okay and it's working fine
okay everyone so now if it is ready then
we'll be talking about our next feature
here
that is called working with
use debug value this is once again
another hook
of the react based development
so when we talk about use double value
so what use double value actually does
and
what we uh really do with the use debug
value this we would like to understand
okay see what happens not too many
developers nowadays know about
use debug value hook okay though
although it provides a much better
debugging experience when it comes to
the developing custom books so use debug
value is a simple in-built hook that
provides more information about the
logical of a custom mode within a
reactive tool so react dev tool is a
tool which you can
get it downloaded for your chrome
extension
okay
and
it allows you to display the additional
information
okay
next to your hooks with optional
formatting
okay so that's what the
redux
react views debug values basically be
useful for
now how you basically use this so you
can just consider in this way
if i just go back
okay
so inside this youtuber.js
here we would like to use function
and in function we can use this option i
can use
friend status
use frame status so here
we can say
trend
id
and here we can use const
is
online
set
online equal to
is
online
question mark
here we say
online
okay and here
we say what
okay and after this we are talking about
this option
return
okay
so that's where exactly you perform
this condition for after that what you
can do you can just use this option i
can export
default
trendline online status
so this is where you can
basically perform this online debugging
sorry the debugging for all the
react hooks whichever you're looking for
so this is very popular and utilized and
useful option for the regular users
hello everybody and welcome you all
so today we have a very interesting
session coming up for this react which
is called react router so let's get
started with react router and see what
it offers
so friends the first important thing
about what is the routing
as we know it very well the routing is
synonyms of
navigation
any application whether you talk about
multi-page application or single page
application it always requires a routing
through this routing you will be making
your applications
uh you know to be navigate from one part
to another part like you never call
login page registration page and you've
got a lot of links available
and when you click on those links
application will take you towards those
necessary pages but here in react these
are component centric architecture
so here you will be having a components
loaded
okay
so as we know in a traditional web
development routing plays a very very
crucial role so that you can navigate
through
okay
now
react router so what is the react router
so we know this react router is a client
and server side routing library provided
by the rehack it is a javascript
libraries which is normally known for
creating the attractive user interfaces
now here the traditional react router is
available on the web
okay and the server
so
with using traditional node.js
based application which is you know it
is designed for developing a server-side
java based javascript based applications
and on react net which is once again for
mobile based
environment for react applications
now react router components so browser
router so typically we say the browser
router is this is one of the component
because react router comes with lot many
api so here's one of the api which is
called browser router so browser router
is something from where
okay it uses the traditional html5
history api which is one of the main
component
so
it keeps your
url in sync with what you are navigating
through
okay so next we have a call routes
so routes are basically chosen based on
what best matches you are providing it
so that when you click on those links so
appropriate route will get loaded for
you so called components
so now we have a call link so the
traditional link components are used to
basically create a hyperlinks like ahrf
how we used in html pages
so
to different
uh from the traditional react replica
application so it is mainly designed to
focus on navigation throughout the
applications
and now we have a call switch so
traditionally switch what it does it
renders the first routes and matches the
location rather than rendering all the
matching route like whichever has come
it is like a typical switch case
whichever comes it make it available and
come out
that's how it provides
okay so installation wise you need to
have
first
you have to create the react based
application by using
npx create reactor so
create react app is a tool provided by
the
official facebook and the router hyphen
tutorial is the name of the project
okay so you'll be using this command to
create a new project for you and post
that
you have to install
this particular dependency called react
hyphen now to hyphen dom so this
dependence you need to install post
first
uh i would say
the message is executed so once the
first command is ready then you will be
going inside this npm
install and then you say react router
dom so this is how the steps are
and
now we'll talk about demo so let's get
started with the demo part
okay everybody so it's time to
get into some hands-on so i already have
a project ready with me which we have
created with using create react app so
my project name is react hyphen app
and i would like to create a new
uh
router base example here so the
dependency regarding react hyphen router
hyphen dom is already
installed so if you see this
package.json react router dom is already
there in place
so we would like to start now
developing those router based examples
so to make it happen what we will do is
here in my src
we will create a new folder name called
components
okay and inside these
components we will create some file name
called
login
dot
js
likewise we would like to create a
register
user
details.js
one more
name call
um
yeah
portfolio
so we have got these pages already with
me
okay
out of which i want the first components
to be get launched here that is known as
call a landing page so here i will also
create
landing page.js
so let's go back and create a new
components here which will be helping us
to
move
here and there
so first thing in my landing page my
component.js i have called app.js which
is a
base component for me
so as i can see this is how you go back
and create a new functional component so
i just copy the same
and here in login.json paste it
and give the name to
login
login and here we can say welcome to
login i just
this is my small component i copied
and i pasted in a portfolio
so you call portfolio welcome to
folio
register
register
login we look at user details
okay so we have got these components
with us i will start with
landing page first
so
i would like to create a class based
component here
so
import
react
from
react
now
4d for class
landing page
exchange
component
now
render
return
okay so this
one so we is tube tag here
well
this is my component which is available
to me
so the landing page is a component which
through which i'll start working on
so
[Music]
i can say
welcome to landing so here i want this
components to be available outside
so what i will do is
this landing page in my index.js
i'll make it as a first component to be
launched
landing page
so when i start my application i should
see here
okay welcome to lending is coming up
perfect
so this has become my first component
which i want to launch
and furthermore we would like to add few
more components here
okay so in a previous program we have
seen
how to create a multiple components and
how we can make one of the component as
a
learning component now it's our next
program where we will be enabling the
routing into our code
syllable landing page we would like to
create some more
dependency we are saying import
from
hyphen router hyphen down
so we will be choosing those
dependencies one by one but from there
we want to start working with
cons routes
equal to
first thing
as i discussed with you that is we would
like to start with the browser router
okay
so
from this point onwards we would like to
start with
switch
as you can see they are taking from the
react router down
after the switch we will say
route
okay so here
with this route we would like to see the
navigation path we say path
equal to if it is
login
then which component i want to launch so
we can say
component
here i'll say c small
component equal to
okay
it's not loading so we can say import
and since i want to launch
the component which is a type of login
so we can say import
from login
so if you see here
we work for login so we will be using
this login only
okay
so this is my login component likewise i
will say
from
register so here
i would like to say
login
and in a similar way
we also want to have the another
registration
we copy the same
use this
register
register
so this is how the components are used
here
okay
well
these are the quick two components we
have created one is called login and
second for register
after that what you will be doing this
routes you will be adding it under this
dev tag so i'm removing this landing
page
and here
i will give the name call
routes
that's it
so once this route has been given
now it's time for us to
see
what it differs
so landing page
or sorry we have a register we have a
register also
so
[Music]
say route is not defined so what we can
do
we can also import it out from this page
now let's go back
okay nothing is shown so now we have to
manually type by saying
login you can see i've got this message
go welcome to login
now let's see register
and there we go register
so two components are loaded correctly
now we would like to import two more
import
portfolio
portfolio
okay
and last
we have a call user details
import name call
user details here
so we got user details let me copy these
two
so register
portfolio
so this is how
our components are so now
we can see all the registered
successfully
well in our previous program we have
seen we were typing those urls manually
into our browser
but in real time this won't be a
solution
in a real time you would like to make
this example
by clicking on a hyperlink you would
like to make it possible
so i will be doing this
so to make it possible what you will be
doing is
like here itself you create a new
component called
header
okay
so this is how we're going to create the
new component called header
okay so within this
you're going to add
the new
i call header within this you will be
using
nav link which is once again
the tool provided by
react to which you can create a
hyperlinks
so this is the nav link for you
so within the snap link you will provide
the option like into
equal to
login
and
along with this
you will also provide
the name so here i say
login let me copy the same
login
register
register we also have called
last we have
portfolio
so this is my component which is
available to me and this i would like to
use
within my application so here
after this browser router we would like
to add the component call
header here
that's it that's the only thing we need
to do now this header component is now
the part of
routes and let's see how it makes a
difference now you can see
very clearly it is having those links
with me and now when i click on those
links
you can see how these are easily
accessible to all of us
okay so these are the links which are
available to us through which we can
make our components
simple and easy to access
one more thing we can do it here
and what's that
this component whichever we are talking
about okay
this component we can attach
to one of my
base component when my components start
it should work automatically so i can do
one thing like my login command to be
the base component for me
so in order to make this possible i need
to write one more tool here called
exact equal to
true
and here also we have to use the same
so here
we would like to add one more property
here
okay and we will say exact equal to true
okay what i would like to use
exact equal to true
that's it any job is done now let's
check
and now you can see the by default login
page appeared
because the login is in root location
and that's how
your url works
okay everybody so in a previous example
we have seen how the links are working
but these links are all internal links
but what in case if i want to go to the
external link so let's try to understand
that point so here let me try to open up
i'm opening up simply learn link and i'm
clicking on this
the url is right now https
simplydone.com
that's a link which is available so let
me try to copy this link
and
[Music]
here if we want to go to that location
so what do we need to do now
so to make it possible
here i can just make this another nav
link
copy the same
and i give the name call
simpler
and
and here i'll just copy the same
okay
so now it is asking me for the component
because i do not have any component here
right now
so here what i will be doing instead
i'm making it as a blank
okay and here i want to give window
dot location
dot
href
equal to
website which is available
okay so that will be the link which i'm
providing it now
and
after this link what has been provided
i'm saying
return
that's it
okay so that will be the link so i'm
saving this and going back to this
location now
so you can see we have a call simply
done the moment i click it here
so
it will somehow try to take me towards
where
this external website the one which you
are actually looking forward for
okay so this is the way
through which you can basically make
the application accessible outside so if
i just go back to my browser and
[Music]
refresh this and click on simply and you
can see now it took me to an external
location called simplyland.com
likewise if i just go back and open
the
simple learn
as a youtube channel
also just say
okay simply learn
youtube so if any of the
i would say
the link
which is available right you can see
right now we have got
multiple websites so if i just click on
anything suppose
this is a link for me
and
i try to create one more link here
just like we have a call simply learn so
let's create one more let's say
simply learn youtube
simply on youtube so here
i copy the same
okay so here
in my browser whatever the link is
provided let's just copy this link
and
paste this link right over there
okay so this is what a link which is
available to me
now i go back to my code
i can say simply learn youtube i click
it
and you can see it took me two way to
the right
so this is the way you see
how the links are basically created
and they're simply available to us
in a very simplified manner
okay and that's where
the hyperlinks are basically working
with us
welcome to the session on react.js
interview questions through this session
we will explore the most commonly posed
interview questions that you would face
if you walk up to a developer interview
on react.js let's start with going
through and exploring the general set of
react.js interview questions that would
be commonly asked in an interview the
first question would be what are the
features of react.js now right through
this session we would follow a common
methodology where we would explore the
question and then look at the best way
in which you could have answered that
question if posed to you during a
react.js interview so starting with the
first question what are the features of
react so react has many extensions for
complete application architecture
support jsx is used with react to
describe what the user interface should
typically look like react is broken into
small components so you look at the
complete application you want to build
break it down into individual components
and a component is typically a piece of
user interface like a function that
would return a stream of html characters
speedy performance is one of the core
features of react as only the updated
components need to be re-rendered on the
screen and not the entire page the
one-way data binding feature on the
other hand keeps everything modular and
fast the virtual dom is also a
lightweight representation of the real
dom which is again a feature which helps
speed up performance and avoids a full
page refresh and a full tom tree shake
which really speeds up performance so
what is jsx how do you answer this so
jsx is typically the extension used for
react and it's nothing but an extension
to the javascript programming language
because all that you can use inside your
browser for execution typically has to
be javascript because in html5 you
cannot have any third-party plugins
installed in the browser and that's the
reason the browser would only ship by
default with a javascript reactive
engine so by using jsx you can write
html structures in the same file that
would contain your javascript code as
well making the updates to the code very
simple so it's simple to update and make
modifications to your code because the
code and the data and the business logic
is all composed in a single file so
because the code and the business logic
is in a single file it makes
updating and incorporating change
requests to the code very simple and
easy so it's basically used with react
to describe what your user interface
should look like and it's what you
typically would term as the html
template or the view coming to the next
question can jsx be directly read by the
web browser so web browsers cannot read
jsx directly now why is that well the
reason is simple it's because they are
only built to read regular javascript
objects and jsx is not a regular
javascript objects it's a react
component so for a web browser to read a
jsx file the file needs to be
transformed into a regular javascript
object and for this there is a
javascript api called babel which is
internally used by react so what do you
understand by the virtual dom that we've
been speaking about in react so react
gives a very lightweight representation
of the real dom the actual dom structure
of the page so dom is document object
model it is uh an api created by w3c and
it creates an in-memory representation
of the html elements as an inverted tree
structure a balanced tree structure
which is the fastest search algorithm
when you want to search for html
elements and do a dynamic update on them
but again updating the basic dom tree
structure of the page causes a full page
refresh and if you only want to update a
specific component you wouldn't need the
entire page to be refreshed and that is
where react comes in it uses a virtual
dom which is a layer on top of the
actual dom which ensures that only a
certain part of the page is refreshed
and that speeds up performance so when
the state of an object changes virtual
dom changes only that object in the real
dom instead of updating all the objects
and this is what makes things really
fast so why use react instead of other
frameworks like angular first of all
it's very easy to create dynamic web
pages dhtml where you can update the
view or the template at runtime the
components are reusable so you reuse
rather than reinvent the performance is
great since you're working with the
virtual dom you don't need a full page
refresh the unidirectional data flow
makes data move one way there's no
two-way data binding by default and
that's the reason the page does not have
to do a lot of heavy lifting of
remembering whether the view is changing
whether the the base javascript entity
class is changing and that saves a lot
of processing time again to debug react
is much more simpler and that's what
makes it more popular in terms of its
simplicity and speed as compared to
other frameworks like angular what is
the difference between es5 and es6
standard so these are scripting
standards okay that are defined by the
european computer manufacturers
association or ecma and all of the
scripting languages
are a subset of the standard and are
derived from these standards to ensure
that the code will execute on all
browsers and the code that we are
writing is standards based so these are
the few instances where es6 syntax has
changed from es5 if you look at the es5
first syntax at the top we are creating
a simple react class component and the
render function just returns a stream of
html content in ex6 there's a new
keyword that comes in which is extends
so you are extending from the base react
component and creating a custom
component and then returning a stream of
characters also the function keyword no
longer needs to be used so the exports
versus export also changes so you use
exports to export out class from a
module so that it can be accessed from
another module in es6 you simply say
export and the component require versus
import so you would require a
third-party component or an api into
your javascript file to use it in es6
it's replaced with the import statement
very similar to the syntax that we use
in core java so how do you go and create
a react app first you install node.js as
a base platform which you can download
from the node.js website next any text
editor of your choice could be atom
visual studio code or sublime text third
you create a react app using a command
prompt terminal depending on the os you
are using the command to give is create
hyphen react space my first app okay so
the command that you would give to
create a new react app is create hyphen
react hyphen app space and the name of
the application you would want to create
in this case it is my hyphen first
hyphen app and that could be a custom
name of your choice so what is an event
in react well on the web when you talk
about dynamic html it's all about
interacting with the user so the user
performs some interaction event with the
web page which could be a click of a
button a mouse move and these events in
action
can be triggered by a user or any system
or could be pressing a key or a mouse
click etc and in response to that event
you would execute a block of code which
is called an event handler so here we
have class simple which is a custom
class that extends the base react
component the name of the function work
which triggers a simple alert message
box and a render function which returns
html when you click on the button we
would want to bind that to the event
handler this dot work and that's how you
connect a click event to an event
handler function what are synthetic
events in react well a synthetic event
is an object which acts as a cross
browser wrapper around the browser's
native event it combines the behavior of
different browsers native events into
one api which makes sure that the events
are consistent across different browsers
and this brings in the standard space
development to ensure in this digital
age the code that we are creating for
different browsers have consistency in
terms of its execution so here we see a
function action link we see a function
handle click which takes e as an event
parameter e dot prevent default ensures
that there is no error that the browser
is raising in case the event function
call is not directly compatible with
that specific browser so prevent default
is used to suppress any browser specific
errors or crashes and a simple
console.lock which will lock into the
developer tools window which says you
just clicked a link and then we've got
the return where we are returning the
view to the html template where on click
we connect to this event handler called
handle click so handle click is
basically a wrapper and the entire
action link is a wrapper object which is
a synthetic event we don't directly go
and bind to the on click and then
associate a function with it we actually
associate a synthetic object with it
which binds the base default event that
could be specific to a browser so some
browsers would probably understand an on
click some another browser would
understand a click and to ensure that
it's consistency of syntax and from a
development perspective the code that we
write will run on all browsers we need
to take care of using the synthetic
events which isolate the developer out
from the complexity of writing code
specific to different browsers so you
just write generic code which will work
on different browsers so how do lists
work in react so the list display data
in an ordered format the traversal of
lists is done using the map function so
here we see there is a function called
list of names which takes a variable
props as a parameter props dot names
will allow us to get a reference to all
of the array of names that are passed
constant list names is another variable
created equal to name start map and uh
we are using the arrow operator which is
now an ecmascript standard and
again we are using the opening tag of
the li html element the key is equal to
the name attribute so the brace bracket
will bind that to the name attribute
then we just print the name itself and
we close the li tag so that's the
names.map function and finally we return
in an unordered list the list names
themselves so the map function will run
through an iterate over the list of
names list them in the li tag the li tag
will get injected into the unordered
list and will finally get returned out
as a stream of html elements in the next
code snippet below we create a constant
variable names we are associating it
with a set of five names and we simply
say render list of names names equal to
names the moment we do that
we are using list of names as a custom
html element which is not system defined
it starts looking for the function list
of names passes the names added to it
iterates over it using the map function
which is an inbuilt react function
brings out all of the lists it's very
similar to a for loop that you would
write for iteration in other programming
languages and then finally what you get
returned in the get element by id app is
nothing but a list of simple names
wrapped in a li element that are printed
on the view so why is there a need of
using keys in lists so keys are very
important in the code snippet that we
saw due to the following reasons the
first reason the key is a unique
identifier if you would want to search
for a name in the list it is used to
identify which items have changed
updated or deleted from the list so if
you want to perform clud operations on
the data you would want to search for
which element do you want to update or
delete or change it also helps to
determine which components need to be
re-rendered instead of re-rendering all
the components every time and it
increases performance as only the
changed components have to be
re-rendered and not all the components
on the page what are forms in react so
using forms users can interact with the
application and enter required
information whenever needed so forms can
contain certain elements such as text
fields buttons checkboxes radio buttons
etc and forms are also used for many
different tasks such as user
authentication searching filtering etc
how do you create a form pretty simple
again create a custom component called
name from that will extend reactor
component we create a state variable
this dot state is equal to value we
handle the change by writing a handle
change event and we handle the submit by
writing a handle submit event in the
change event we just change the state by
saying set state of the value to
event.target.value event being a system
defined keyword passed as a parameter
and in the submit we simply alert that a
certain name was entered and we trapped
the value that was entered into the form
prevent default to suppress the browser
from raising any errors on the render
function we return a form on the submit
we connect to the handle submit event
and we bind the data submitted from the
form to the handle submit event and we
pass the this pointer which is a
reference to the current context of the
view itself we open a label specify the
name we then specified input box as text
the value is set to this dot state dot
value and on change we simply connect to
the handle change event and bind to it
and pass the context of the text box
itself so the moment we change the value
in the text box as we are typing the
handle change event will receive the
updated value and set the state and when
we click on the submit button the handle
submit event handler executes and we
alert out the current value printed in
the text box and that's it so how do you
write commands in react when you're a
developer if you want to comment out
some code or if you want to set comments
to enhance the maintainability of the
code a single line comment is as simple
as given in most other programming
languages backslash asterisk to open
astrix to close multi-line commands
follow the same syntax and can span
multiple slides to add comments to
functions in terms of what the function
can do and what are the types that it
can return what is the arrow function
and how is it used so an arrow function
is a shorter way of writing a function
in react if you look at the snippet on
the top my input on change equal to we
are connecting to this dot handle change
dot bind and that's the longer version
of how you can connect it to an event
handler the shorter version is on change
equal to e arrow operator this dot
handle on change so you don't need to
call the bind explicitly you can replace
that with the arrow operator and reduce
the amount of code that you typically
write how is react different from react
native so react and react native are
completely different react was released
in 2013 it's a web-based platform it is
html compliant it generates html views
it uses css for styling and it's based
on javascript html and css react native
on the other hand is targeted to
mobility devices it's meant to create
installable apps on android and ios
released in 2015 not based on html and
css and it basically requires the
react.js api to create these installable
apps for these mobility ecosystems how
is react different from angular another
popular framework by google so angular
created by google completely based on
the model view controller pattern works
on the real dom layer and requires a
full tree shake at the tom layer to
update views and components supports
bi-directional data mining the rendering
is purely done on the client side the
performance comparatively slow react.js
on the other hand created by facebook
it's the view layer of the model view
controller pattern it works at the
virtual dom layer and it sends faster
it's unidirectional data binding and not
two-way and the rendering is typically
what is done at the server side and what
you get is a response on the client as a
stream of html characters as an output
let's talk about and discuss some
questions around react components so
what are components in react so these
are the building blocks you can think of
them as lego blocks so you break your
problem down into small parts each part
identifying a certain solution of the
problem which is what we define as a
component so they are building blocks of
a react application and a single app
usually consists of multiple components
so it splits the ui into independent
reusable pieces that can be processed
separately a component is essentially a
piece of the user interface or the html
view what is the use of render method in
react so it is compulsory for each
component to have a render method if not
there wouldn't be any html for the
component to render on your view so the
render function returns the html which
is to be displayed within a component
like you see on the screen there is a
class app that extends the react
component and it returns a simple h1
element called hello simply learn and of
course do remember to export the app out
so that it can be accessed from other
components as well if you need to render
more than one element all the elements
must be inside a single parent tag like
a div or a form what is state in react
the state of a component is an object
that holds some data within it the data
would influence the output of the
component now how do you implement state
in react so state holds the data that a
component renders on the web application
for example
here we've created in the constructor
this dot state equal to and this
temporary anonymous object has two
attributes car and pi when we return we
simply return this dot state dot car and
this dot state dot by now this is how
you would create stateful components and
access the state properties within the
view how do you update the state of a
component by using the built-in set
state method you can go ahead and update
the state of the component so here we
have a simple render function that
returns the state itself state dot
message and on the on click connects to
a button press function the moment you
click on the button the button press
function sets the state to another
message so the initial message in the
constructor is welcome to simply learn
the moment you click on the button the
set state triggers and changes it to
best place to learn so the data on the
view would be updated what are props in
react well props is just a short form
for properties and that is what allows
us to pass arguments or data to a
component props are passed to components
in the way similar to that of attributes
that are passed to an html element so
how do you pass props between two
components so let's say we have an
app.js component on the top and a
main.js component at the bottom at the
top we are trying to return this dot
props dot car and the pike so two car
and bike attributes associated with this
props of the app component in the main
component when you look at the render
function we are associating car prop
equal to a value of 1 600 cc and bike
prop equal to value of
150cc and to access it if you look at
the import statement we are importing
app from app.jsx and this is how you can
cross access properties from one
component within the other so what are
the difference between state and props
well state holds information about the
components they are mutable they can be
changed they cannot be accessed by child
components and they cannot have state
props allow to pass data from one
component to the other as an argument
they are immutable they are read only
and props can be accessed by the child
component and they can have props as
well what is a higher order component in
react so these act as a container for
other components which helps in keeping
components simple and induces the
reusability factor they are generally
used when a common logic has to be used
by multiple components that's when you
group together a set of components
within a higher order component in react
how can you embed two or more components
into one this code snippet demonstrates
the app component which returns a hello
text and it has a custom tag called
simple the simple tag is defined in the
component below and it returns text
called simply learn and in the render of
the react dom
we simply go and render the app
component so hello simply learn would be
the final output and that's how you can
embed one component into the other using
this methodology what are the
differences between class and functional
components so stateful components would
extend react component in this case and
if you could look at the render it
simply renders this dot props dot title
the constant stateless component would
be equal to props the div tag returns
this dot props dot title so you can look
at the style very different in terms of
class and functional components one
using the arrow operator one using the
traditional class and render method so
the class component can hold or manage
state complex as compared to stateless
components can work all of the life
cycle methods of the component and it
can be reused the functional component
cannot hold a managed state they are
simple and easy to understand it does
not work with any life cycle method and
it cannot be reused let's explain the
life cycle methods of components we've
got kennish initial state which is
executed before the creation of the
component component did mount which is
executed when the component gets
rendered and placed on the dom should
component update which is invoked when a
component decides any changes to the dom
and returns true or false value based on
certain conditions component did update
it is invoked immediately after the
rendering takes place component will
unmount which is invoked immediately
before a component is destroyed and
unmounted permanently let's move to the
react redux set of questions so what is
redux it's an open source javascript
library used to manage application state
and react uses redux for building the
user interface what are components of
redux the first is the store which holds
the state of the application store
contains state which defines the user
interface which triggers a set of
actions which are then sent to the
reducer so store holds the state action
is the source information for the store
and reducer specifies how the
application state changes in response to
actions sent to the store what is flux
well flux is the application
architecture that facebook uses for
building web applications and it works
in this way the action is triggered
which is sent to the dispatcher the
dispatcher sends it to the store the
store sends it to the view and the view
sends it back to the action and that's
exactly how the steps would continue in
sequence so when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified once
the dispatcher has dealt with an action
the stores listening to it will get
triggered the view gets updated when the
state of the store changes user action
at the view is sent to the dispatcher to
then be processed how is redux different
from flux redux is an open source
javascript library used to manage
applications state the store state is
immutable it can only have a single
store and it uses the concept of reducer
flux on the other hand is an
architecture and not a framework or
library the store state is mutable it
can have multiple stores and it uses the
concept of dispatcher let's look at some
react router questions what is a react
router a rear router is a package which
is used to create routing in a react
application react router is used for
developing single page web applications
it allows multiple views in a single
application by defining multiple routes
in that react application how is react
routing different from conventional
routing react routing has a single html
page it uses or the end user rather
would navigate multiple views within the
same file called a single page app the
page does not refresh since it's a
single page file and there is improved
performance since you are not navigating
across multiple pages conventional
routing each view is a separate html
file the user would navigate multiple
files for each view the page would
refresh every time the user navigates
which would hence result in slower
performance how do you implement react
routing you can implement react routing
using a very simple method considering
the above components let's say you've
got a component called app about and
contact so here you can specify the
route path if the route part is just
slash the root default route it takes
you to the app component if the route is
slash about in the url given by the end
user you automatically navigate and
activate and load the about component
and if the url is slash contact it would
take you to the contact component let's
talk about react styling questions how
do you style react components either you
use inline styling by using simple css
by simply saying color blue and that's
going to be the output of the h1 element
or i could use a javascript object by
specifying a constant simple style
object and specifying a keypair value of
color background color margin font
family and apply that object as the
style parameter which would result in
this styled output how do you style
react components using a css style sheet
so here's an external style sheet so
we've written all the styling rules in a
separate css file app.css we've imported
that at the top of the app.js react
class and lo and behold you have the
output simplified as generated on your
page let's explain the use of css
modules in react so a css module file is
created.module.css is the extension the
css inside a module file is available
only for the component that is importing
it so there are no naming conflicts so
dot button is the css styling inside
button.module.css
and that is what we've imported from in
the app.js file so when you view the
button style start button is the styling
picked up from the button.module.css
file so let's talk about some
introduction to react context
now first important thing we need to
understand
a typical application when we talk about
react application so data is always pass
through what from the top down approach
with the help of props as we know it
very well
if we have a component like an a b and c
and if c components wants to get the
data from
a so a cannot directly pass the data to
c because
c is the child of b and b is the child
of a so according to the rule so data
has to be passed through the proper
hierarchy that is what is called
drilling down the props
which is one of the very very
complicated area because when you have a
call complex hierarchy and if you are
making lot of middleman in between so
this create a lot of confusion in your
development and hence your application
gets more and more complex
so to avoid such kind of scenarios so we
have this option like in
react context so in context api what
happens like here
the data can be passed directly
to any of the component whichever
needs that
so data gets stored in a centralized
environment and from there
it gets passed down to all its child
whenever it needs whether it is a direct
child or it is a indirect
so this is what the benefit you get with
the help of props here
so if you see the main component i've
got lot of childs so using the props you
are passing the data to all its child
directly but the challenge here is that
all childs are direct child of main
component what in case if we have
further
childs so that create a lot of trouble
okay so create context is basically the
way where you can pass a data directly
to
the components and cut down the all
middlewares
okay to your applications
and that's what the context api and the
question is like when to use a context
api
so as you can see it is clearly written
like context is basically designed to be
considered as a global state which any
of the components tree can easily get it
directly from its parent
okay without involving any of itself
directly
now you see like here we have a call app
component which have the language as a
function
and here we have a call select language
so you are passing the data here to its
child
okay so you see here the language
component needs to take a very important
extra component that is one is called
what lang
and pass it to the selected language so
this could be further painful or more
complicated when on every single button
if the app needs to know the language
and what it is pass through the other
components so we want to basically cut
down all
so context api we want to use it
okay with using this areas like a
react.createcontext
so this create context helps you
to create a context in a parent
component whichever you want and let
other components subscribe to this so
whenever the changes are happened
they would be immediately informed about
that so here we have a call provider
so here every single context
okay so comes with a react provider so
they are basically trying to consume the
state whichever is being available with
the context
so using this property like in class or
context type you actually consume the
nearest current
of the context with using this dot
context
now we will call consumer
so this particular component which is
actually subscribing to the changes
okay so this let you
basically subscribe to the context with
a functional component and here you have
a call context or display name it
basically
accept a display name as a string
property
okay which you can easily drag through
when you talk about react dev tools
now let's talk about a demo
of our development
so now here
let's get involved on the demo part
but before that i would like to show you
one simple problem statement which you
feel it so this is if you see difficult
context api which is available here so
here you can see this is a property
drilling where you have a called parent
you have for the child and you have a
further childs so the component
properties are keep on going through
through multiple mediators
which you want to avoid
okay and the right hand side if you see
this one is basically the parent and
immediately passed on to her to the
child
and you see like here it is happening
this is the wrong approach where the
data is basically going in the waterfall
model
this is better because here the data has
been passed from parent to any other
child directly
so that's what the benefit you get it
okay everybody so it's time to basically
talk about some
quick demo so that it can help us to
understand
how we can utilize this react context
api for our development
so here
uh this is my project which is there
already developed
in my browser
i just when i open up i see here
in local 3000 i'm getting this as a
welcome message
so nothing fancy let's get started with
creating a new component i'm creating a
new folder
when you call
components and insert this i'm going to
create a new file
and give the name anything whichever i
want i say
index
dot
js or else i can use some different name
called
main app.js that looks fine
well here i need to import
okay import
react from react
well let's go back and start developing
a function so i'm developing
function
app
because i'm talking about functional
component
return
okay
within this dev tag i'm using this h2
tag
and now here we are saying
welcome to app component
okay so that's a just a basic example we
have it
going ahead i would like to add few more
components like
function
imply
and the same thing
return
and here once again
okay
and here once again i'm saying h2
welcome to
employee component
okay so
like this i can copy
and have one more that is called
salary and i'm saying
welcome to salary component
so these are the basic component sets
which are available to me
now certainly you will be having some
parent
and
employee
here
i would like to make
okay
that means employees are com child of
app and
salary is a child of employee component
okay so it's very very simple
and straightforward
and later on
i can have
the new component ready
in which i can deploy
this
and make it available to the
end user
okay
so let's see what i'm having it now
so
here we have a call app
and here we are saying
finally
equal to
i just use the name called main app
that looks more better
main app
and here we are using
react
dom
so we want to basically render it
wherever you want it
so what else what we can do is on the
other side
we can say
export
default
main app
we can do like this in this menu i can
add it under my
app.js file
so it came from here and let's check
well i got this message printed here
so
this is
very simple and straightforward like you
in creating a parent and child
relationship
so now
the actual job comes
when my application is having
some of the details which i'm looking at
it
okay that means i want to have a data so
as i said earlier that when you are
creating the react based component so
you need to have some
relationships where the data can be
stored in anywhere so in the next
example i will show you how to store the
data in a main and how we can pass it to
the others
now we will be providing the data to our
main component
which is my main app
so here i would like to provide
const
here we can have
because we're talking about state
management so using employee
employee
equal to
use
state
use state
and here
in our use state will provide some of
the important information like an id
suppose i say one zero one
and i say name
and i can just give the name called
admin
and
so we have a call id we have a con name
let's try to
[Music]
put it
okay
it has to be here
yeah
id
name admin and now we're talking about
location
we can say pune
and
let's talk about
salary
and we can give any satellite like one
two three four five so
here we have got this uh quick
state which we have created
okay so the next thing is like once your
state is ready
okay so you have to provide some input
through which the data can be available
to the others
and to make this possible
here
above this we are providing
construct
employee context
equal to
react.createcontext
so we are initializing our context
to confirm
what we're really doing this now
and in this context whichever i'm having
it now i would like to provide a data
which i can easily access to my other
components
so now here once i provide a context
here
okay so when i see this welcome to this
component you can see we have called
employee available
yeah so what i will be doing is now here
we will be saying
employ context
using employee context
dot
provider
okay
now here
we want to provide
we close this
yeah so here we are providing value
value equal to
the value object so what value object we
are having it right now here
that is called employee
so this is state we are initially
providing it here
and
this
area wherever the context is basically
available will be providing this
employee object and pass it within this
so this employee object which we are
having it
so now you can see the context is closed
here so now within this context we have
passed as employee so the all data will
be available to this employee object now
and that's the best part of this code
now
okay
now this context i can easily get it
in my employee
okay
and access all the details whichever i
wanted
now if i see here
i can come down and i say
let
context
equal to
now we are using this option i can use
context and inside this use context we
are talking about
employee context so we got the details
whatever we have set it on the top
okay and here
i can set
the details like we are saying welcome
to the employee company so we have got a
lot many things available here so
label
so let's provide the details here
so we are saying employee id
colon
here
we can use the details
okay by saying
context start you can see we have got
details available
like an id
likewise i can just copy it
paste it
employee name
typical employee name
so we also have a part of this
id name location so we can also pass
location
okay
so we have got those
details available with us
and in a similar line
whatever details we have taken it from
there i can also pass it where
in my salary component too
where i can display the salary related
details into my code so like here
i can just copy this here
okay so we got employee context which is
available
and here i can provide the same number
of amount
like but this time
i may require sorry
i may require the name
as well as the salary booth
okay
so these two details
whichever you want you can easily get it
and make it available to the client
okay so this using use context
you're actually trying to retrieve all
the relevant information
which was required and you can see it is
available here so the same employee
which is there now i can have this
employee details
under my employee component and under my
salary
we have a call salary component so
that's something which makes
your context api more interesting
because this is where you avoid
bringing any middleware and make this
data
or component easily accessible outside
and with that we come to the end of this
full course tutorial
if you enjoyed watching the video do
give it a thumbs up comment your doubts
below and our experts will answer them
for you
thank you so much for being here watch
out for more videos from us until then
stay tuned to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you